Leute, alle schon am Start hier, ich sehe es schon, ich bin gerade aufgestanden vor, keine Ahnung,
Viertelstunde oder so, ja wir sind dort relativ früh, das stimmt, Sekunde, erstmal das Kabel hier,
Alter, das ist mein Headset, Moment, ich muss mal kurz mein Headset entwirren, das ist, das hat
eigentlich glaube ich, was sind das, ein 3 Meter Kabel oder ein 4 Meter Kabel, das ist quasi noch
ein Meter lang gerade, ein bisschen durcheinander, so, so, perfekt, jetzt stimmt es auch, das stimmt
auch der Sound links und rechts wieder, da war die ganze Zeit irgendwie ein bisschen linkslastig,
ja, so, exzellent, auf geht's Leute, auf geht's, MonkaS, erst mal was trinken,
Zähne gebunden, nö, ich bin direkt, ich bin aufgestanden und jetzt direkt an den Rechner,
hab nix gemacht, muss euch übrigens was zeigen, was, Sonntag um 9.30 Uhr, Alter, du willst es aber
wissen, so, muss euch was zeigen, aber erst mal, weiß nicht, irgendwie habe ich schon was im Hals,
zack, so, exzellent, okay, ja, ich muss euch was zeigen, ich muss die Musik ein bisschen leiser
machen, muss euch was zeigen, erinnert ihr euch noch an den Stream, wo wir, nein, mich nervt das
neue Twitch extrem hier, dass man nicht direkt muten kann, ihr erinnert euch ja bestimmt noch
ans China, ans China-Chinesen-Geräte-Flashen, so,
diese Dinger hier, wo der Chat sich so gefreut hat, dass ich die kaputt gemacht hab, so, und die
gingen ja nicht, ne, und ich hab dem Entwickler, hab ich drei Geräte zum Testen geschickt, und
dreimal dürft ihr raten, äh, die ATC hieß das, glaub ich, und dreimal dürft ihr raten, was gestern
gepatcht wurde,
es heißt, wir können den Kram jetzt flashen,
siehste mal, sollst du mal einer, soll mal einer sagen, ich würde keine
OBSOS-Projekte unterstützen, ich hab das nur mitbekommen, weil er gestern, weil er mich gestern
auf Twitter angeschrieben hat, so, so, so, danke für die Donation, hab ich halt nochmal geantwortet,
danke für die Firmware, und, äh, jetzt ist es auch supported, es gibt allerdings wohl noch eine noch
neuere Revision, die ist noch nicht supported,
was sind das für Dinger, das sind, das sind Thermostate, oder Thermometer, oder wie auch immer man das,
das, äh, Luftfeuchtigkeit und Temperatur, und das Gute ist, in Kombination mit der Custom-Firmware,
ist der Batterieverbrauch relativ gering, normalerweise announced das Ding irgendwie alle 5 Sekunden,
oder so die Werte per Bluetooth, was natürlich viel zu viel ist, was interessiert mich 5 genau über, über Wireless,
Temperatur und Luftfeuchtigkeit, wenn du das aber runterstellst, sagen wir mal, auf 5 Minuten, oder so,
dann hält die Batterie wirklich, naja, ewig ist zu viel gesagt, aber ziemlich lang, normalerweise ist die Batterie
nach einem halben Jahr leer, ich hab eh das Gefühl, die China-Chinesen-Geräte gehen viel zu verschwenderisch
mit der Default-Firmware, mit der, mit der Batterie um, und, wenn ihr das auf 5 Minuten stellt, also, ich hab das jetzt
fast ein Jahr, oder so, würde ich sagen, im Einsatz,
oder ein Jahr im Einsatz, ungefähr, und ich bin jetzt, glaube ich, auf 78% Batterie, und normalerweise ist es nach einem halben Jahr leer,
also, das ist schon, das ist schon ein Riesenunterschied mit Custom-Firmware, oder nicht?
Also, YouTuber, schlägst du uns denn heute vor?
Was Dragon Age Origins, äh, was zum, warum ist das Video 3 Stunden 47 Minuten?
What the fuck? Was, was geht mit den Leuten ab?
In der Zeit kannst du ja quasi fast schon hervorrufen, dass es 3 Stunden 47 Minuten ist, aber, was geht mit den Leuten ab?
Wie lange ist Herr der Ringe Uncut? Na gut, übertrieben, äh, nein, kannst du nicht.
Wie lange ist Herr der Ringe, äh, Trilogie, Directors Cut, das ist irgendwie 8 Stunden, oder so, oder 9,5, oder irgendwie sowas.
Aber, 3 Stunden 47, WTF, was hältst du von Donald Trumps Social Media?
Habe ich noch null damit zu tun gehabt, bin schon null in Berührung gekommen, keine Ahnung.
Wurde es nicht gehackerment, letztens?
Ich hab irgendwas, ich hab auf irgendeiner Newsseite gelesen, dass es gehackert wird.
Ich kann, im Prinzip kann ich ganz kurz dazu sagen, ja, Dragon Age ist so gut, wie man das erinnert.
Vielleicht sogar besser.
Dragon Age, also das originale Dragon Age, alle anderen kannst du vergessen.
Das ist echt gut.
Das war so die optimale Kombination, finde ich, aus Einsteigerfreundlichkeit im Vergleich zu den alten Sachen wie Baldur's Gate und sowas.
Die waren ja schon ein bisschen undurchsichtiger.
Und ich muss sagen, also eine Sache, die mir bei Dragon Age wirklich in Erinnerung geblieben ist,
beim originalen Dragon Age wohlgemerkt, dass das ganz gut geschrieben war.
Also sowohl die ganzen Dialoge waren halbwegs konsistent.
Also du hast gemerkt, das war jetzt nicht irgendwie einmal irgendwie nur alles umschrieben und einmal voll direkt in your face.
Was mich ja ein bisschen bei den, ich habe ja jetzt das letzte Pathfinder Game gespielt.
Und da waren die Questtexte sehr, wie sagt man so, all over the place.
Die einmal waren die Questtexte übelst direkt.
Ähm, auch mit F-Wörtern und allem möglichen dabei, ja.
Und einmal halt total umschrieben, sehr komisch.
Also wie es ist geschrieben, also die ganzen Texte in Dragon Age Origins fand ich ziemlich gut.
Und was mir auch positiv in Erinnerung geblieben ist, dass du in den Dialogoptionen eigentlich fast immer das antworten konntest, was du auch antworten wolltest.
Ihr kennt ja vielleicht so RPGs, wo dich dann irgendwie der, irgendwie der, keine Ahnung.
PC fragt dich was.
So nach dem Motto, wie fandest du das?
Äh, ja ganz gut, scheiße oder geht so.
So in Wirklichkeit willst du eigentlich antworten, alter NPC gehen wir nicht auf den Sack.
Oder das kannst du nicht.
Und in Dragon Age war das in der Regel eigentlich fast immer so, dass du in den Antworten das gefunden hast, was du dir gerade gedacht hast.
Das fand ich echt gut.
Zumal man auch sagen muss, die, äh, Companions waren übelst, waren übelst nice.
Auch wenn die Companion-Quests ein bisschen kurz waren insgesamt, die sind ein bisschen, bisschen sehr kurz gekommen.
Aber insgesamt fand ich, also muss man sagen, war Dragon Age wirklich gut.
Dragon Age ist von wann? Von 2009 oder so?
Wann kam das raus?
Hm.
Nicht 9, also 2009.
Ne.
Doch, ja doch, sag ich ja 2009.
Das ist echt ganz gut gealtert, das kann man heute noch spielen.
Ja, also es ist, aber das ist auch eindeutig.
Das ist eindeutig das Beste Dragon Age.
2 kannst du vergessen.
Ähm, was kam danach?
Inquisition? Ne.
Ne, was war das?
Ich blicke hier nicht mehr durch.
Es gab Dragon Age, Dragon Age 2.
Das erste hat noch ein Addon, das habe ich nie gespielt.
Äh, kam das in Inquisition?
Mal kurz gucken, ich bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher.
Ach, ach, jetzt!
Es soll ja Dragon Age 4 irgendwann kommen, genau.
Ja, ja, ja.
Mal gucken, stimmt, das war Inquisition.
Heute Hetzner Teil 3.
Hetzner Teil 3 kommt tatsächlich in nächster Zeit, weil ich habe am...
...Weitag, wann das war, mit Hetzner telefoniert.
Und wir machen demnächst noch ein bisschen was.
Da bietet sich das an.
Oh, schon wieder der Typ!
Ich habe mir jetzt schon zweimal angeguckt, wie die Kekona Häuser mit der Säge Löcher in die Wand geschnitten werden.
Ne, ne, Karl, ich schreibe jetzt ab.
Ja, aber Dragon Age Origins war echt gut.
Ich bin ja immer noch ein bisschen traurig, dass man Wind nicht romanzen konnte.
Ich brauche hier irgendwas auch mal...
Guck mal, es gibt so selten was in meinem Alter in so Games, ja?
Und da gab es wenigstens mal was...
Nein, geht nicht.
Geht nicht.
Wobei, ich glaube, Wind war in dem Game irgendwie 50 oder so.
Vielleicht dann doch ein bisschen zu alt.
Aber es ist ja ein RPG, ja?
Roll, can you roll play?
So.
Was kriegen wir hier noch Schönes angezeigt?
Nichts.
Do not design your network like this.
Das ist ja auch der krasseste Klick bei Titel aller Seiten.
Ich meine, warum?
Warum nicht?
Warum sollte ich nicht ein Kabel zwischen den zwei Switchen stecken?
Das haben wir schon geguckt.
Tja.
Muss man sagen.
New World, drei Gründe gegen den Hype.
Na gut.
Der einfachste Grund gegen den Hype ist, New World suckt.
Das kommt jetzt ja immer mehr raus.
By the way, wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Ich habe sie, weil ich sie nehme.
Bei Aufhab.
Schaut mal.
Passt mal auf, ich muss es mal reloaden.
Also, es ist ja normal, dass nach einem MMO-Launch die Leute dann aufhören zu spielen.
Aber das ist ja eines der krassesten Drops, die ich in kurzer Zeit gesehen habe.
Ich meine, guck mal.
Die waren hier bei knapp einer Million.
Naja, okay.
Sagen wir mal.
Bei 900.000 sind die.
Okay.
Und jetzt sind die bei 480.000.
Die haben, wenn man mal, warten wir mal heute ab.
Aber letzten Sonntag war es auch nicht so viel.
War es 600.000.
Die sind diesen Sonntag, sind die wahrscheinlich bei 500k oder sowas.
Das heißt, die haben ungefähr 40 bis 50% verloren.
Das ist richtig.
Man sieht es ja auch hier.
All-Time-Peak, 24-Hour-Peak.
Hier sieht man das eigentlich ganz gut, wie viele die verloren haben.
Also, die haben es so verschissen.
Das ist genau das.
Es ist exakt das, was ich gesagt habe.
Die ganzen Leute, die jetzt New World spielen, wissen gar nicht, dass sie das eigentlich nicht spielen wollen.
Die spielen das nur wegen ihrem Lieblings-Streamer.
So.
Und dazu kommt, ich habe sogar, glaube ich, ein Video dazu auf.
Das können wir uns mal angucken.
Ja, das da.
Das ist wirklich nicht schlecht.
Dass New World wirklich einige ganz große Probleme drin hat.
Zum Beispiel, das ist eine Sache, Spoiler.
Da kommt noch viel mehr.
Zum Beispiel, dass die Sachen kleinzeitig checken.
Nein.
Aber 40% sind doch nicht normal.
Also, man, einen Monat spielen die Leute wenigstens.
Aber 40% ist nicht normal.
40% ist richtig, richtig krass.
Was genau checken die kleinzeitig?
Ja, also, die checken ein paar Sachen kleinzeitig.
Zum Beispiel, Geschwindigkeit.
Wir müssen uns das Video angucken.
Wir gucken uns das Video an.
Bewegungsgeschwindigkeit ist kleinzeitig.
Also, du kannst die easy as fuck speed hacken.
Weil das Ding, oder was?
Bewegungsgeschwindigkeit.
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich Koordinaten werden irgendwie mehr oder weniger ungefragt übernommen.
Also, du kannst easy speed hacken.
Du kannst dein Interface, kannst du umstellen, dass du, glaube ich, sogar die Fraktion wechseln kannst oder sowas.
Dass du Bonus bekommst, obwohl du gar nicht in der Fraktion bist.
Aber wisst ihr, was das Schlimmste, eines der abgefucktesten Dinger in New World ist?
Ihr wisst ja, ich habe nur die Beta gespielt.
Ich wusste gleich, ich will das nicht spielen.
Eines der abgefucktesten Dinger, die ich je in einem MMO gesehen habe, ist folgendes.
In New World gibt es ja drei verschiedene Factions.
Kurz, ich muss ich meine anlassen.
Ähm, du hast ja, du hast, also, das ist ja, im Kern eigentlich sollte das mal ein PvP-Game sein mit drei unterschiedlichen Fraktionen.
So, und jetzt ist halt das Problem, dass wenn irgendwie so ein Fraktionskrieg ist,
dass dann die eine Fraktion quasi die Leader der anderen Fraktion mass-reportet
und Amazon hat irgendein automatisches Reporting-Analyse-System
und wenn ein Spieler zu oft reportet wird,
dann wird er automatisch für 24 Stunden gebannt.
Und du kannst es zwar appealen, aber der Appeal dauert länger als 24 Stunden.
Das heißt, die gegnerische, also die Fraktionen, die bannen sich jetzt gegenseitig für 24 Stunden,
dass sie in dem jeweiligen Faction-War gewinnen.
Haha, das muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Haha, wie abgefuckt kann eigentlich das System von einem MMO sein?
Haha, die Leute abusen das Bann-System, wo das funktioniert.
Das ist schon echter Wahnsinn, also, dass die das hingekriegt haben, ich versteh's nicht.
Es gibt noch mehr Bugs.
Du kannst zum Beispiel, du kannst zum Beispiel, ähm, Area-Effekte stacken oder Contest-Area-Effekte stacken
und das hat alles one-hitted und sowas.
War ganz, ganz, ganz komisch.
Wir gucken uns das jetzt, wir gucken uns das Video einfach an.
Ich denke mal, das meiste davon wird er auch erzählen.
Ich hab schon mal, ich hab schon mal kurz reingeguckt, ja man.
Aber der zeigt, der zeigt dir irgendwann auch was Kleines.
Es sind einige Sachen in New World kleinzeitig, einige Sachen, wo man sich echt wundert.
Ich bin ja, ich bin ja schon quasi bekannt als New World Hater,
weil ich werd ja mittlerweile schon auf Twitter geflamed, dass ich New World Hater bei,
sag ich ja eigentlich nur, also sag ich ja immer davon, dass das meine Meinung ist
und Sachen, die objektiv halt scheiße sind, ne.
Dass man kleinzeitig Bewegungsspeed quasi ungefragt irgendwie, das ist halt dumm.
Ja, so.
Es ist nichts, weil Engagement das gleiche tut, egal welcher Art es ist.
Also danke für das.
Dieses Video wird komplett einseitig und sehr kritisch sein.
Ich werde über die größten Probleme mit New World sprechen,
weil es gerade zu viele sind und sie sind viel zu massiv, um zu ignorieren.
Einige dieser Probleme sind...
Muss einmal Zaun einstellen.
Einige haben top-votierte Reddit-Posts und einige nicht.
Einige werden fixiert und einige ignorieren.
Ah ja, ich muss, ich muss, ich muss, Moment, Moment Leute.
Ich muss euch was zeigen.
Die Fanbase, die Fanbase von New World.
Sekunde.
Twitter, New World Deutschland.
Die Leute sind so cringe, wie soll ich sagen, so cringe, pepega, realitätsignorierend.
Das kann ich, das verstehe ich nicht.
Moment, Shop-Update, Halloween-Geschenk.
Ach ja, es gab übrigens auch einen Bug mit Server-Transfer.
Man konnte, wenn ich das richtig gelesen habe mit einem Server-Transfer,
man konnte quasi sein...
...Geld sinngemäß irgendwie sein Geld traden auf seinem alten Server.
Dann konnte man umziehen und auf einen neuen Server und das Geld wurde quasi nicht gespeichert.
Also sprich, man hatte, man hat das Geld auf dem alten Server und dann hat man das Geld wieder auf einen neuen Server
und dann konnte man das irgendwie hin und zurück transfern und dann konnte das Geld Gold dupen.
Hier, hier, so, also, guckt euch mal die pepega-Community an.
Ah.
Ich meine...
Guckt euch mal solche Posts an, ja.
Die hatten jetzt das, also, ihnen sind 40% Spieler weggerannt
und es gibt jetzt ein kostenloses Emote, das quasi nochmal, ja, hervorhebt,
dass man jetzt zwei Wochen lang die Server nicht richtig verwenden konnte.
So, und dann gibt es Leute, die antworten allen Ernstes, das ist so Painschamp,
dann antworten die, die meinen das ernst, die Leute.
Wow, sehr nice, danke, finde es unfassbar toll, was ihr alles leistet.
Ihr gebt euch so viel Mühe, dass wir ein gutes Spielerlebnis haben
und dann wird...
Ihr gebt uns auch noch was geschenkt.
Herzchen.
Oh.
Da kriege ich Anfälle, wenn ich so Sachen lese, Alter, das ist der Wahnsinn.
Okay, ich muss das, muss das wieder zumachen.
Das ist echt...
Was ist daran jetzt so schlimm?
Dass sie sich auch noch freuen, dass das Game in einem scheiß Zustand ist.
What the fuck?
Und dann, oh ja, es gibt ein Warte-Emote, super.
Das Spiel hat 85 Billionen dran, 78 Probleme.
Ja, was ihr alles tut.
Ihr tut, ihr tut ja nix anscheinend.
So, wir kommen uns jetzt das Video an.
Next.
Oh, man hört ihm richtig an, dass er pisst ist.
Da war keine Ironie dabei, das meinen die Ernst, es gibt so Leute.
Allein schon, gibt es jemand, gibt es jemand, der wirklich Spielerlebnis verwendet?
Und, oh.
Also.
So, im normalen Sprachgebrauch.
Das Video ist immer noch zu leise.
Jetzt aber.
Ja, jetzt ist es gut.
Echt, ist es heute leiser als sonst?
Ne, aber jetzt, jetzt müsste es okay sein, guck mal.
Ja.
Das ist übrigens auch was, was mich immer stört, dass die Leute das dann immer abtun
mit scheiß Gehate, weil ich hab's auch oft gesagt, dass eigentlich die, die am meisten
haten, wünschen sich eigentlich gleichzeitig am meisten, dass die Games Erfolg haben.
Natürlich, Ausnahmen bestätigen die Regel, aber wie viele Leute gibt es, die beispielsweise
seit, nehmen wir mal World of Warcraft, ja, wie gibt's, wie viele Leute gibt's, die seit
World of Warcraft seit Release spielen?
Und da seit den letzten fünf, sechs Jahren permanent am Flamen drüber sind.
Das sind die Hardcore-Fans der Hardcore-Fans.
Game.
Will it stay that way?
I have absolutely no idea, but what it is right now is a failed product and a horrible
experience.
This might seem completely out of touch when compared to how many other creators are discussing
the title right now, and it might even seem like a sharp turn from my own thoughts on
the game during preview phases and even the closed beta.
And it might seem that way, because in essence, it's kind of true.
This game, as I discussed in my official review, which is up on the channel, by the way, has
two distinct faces, but I wasn't even aware at that point in time, while I made that
review, just how bad it really was.
Übrigens, was ich auch gelesen habe, ist, dass verschiedene Fähigkeiten auch total
verbuggt sind.
Dass die überhaupt nicht das machen, was dran steht.
On the one hand, there is a great experience that will probably last a hundred or more
hours if the game clicks for you, and you can have it for no monthly fee whatsoever
and a simple $40 box price.
That's a good deal if you get even, I don't know, 80 hours of fun, because pound for pound
the earlier parts of this game.
And the progression up until maybe a little over halfway through various different crafting
professions and basic level 60 content.
Pound for pound, it's very fun.
But I'm not here to talk about the fun parts and try to soothe the honeymoon phase dough-eyed
casuals who still haven't made it past level 20.
You're probably the most important demographic.
Erstmal schön geflamed.
Ja gut, das gibt's immer noch.
Und ich glaube auch echt, wenn man ultra casual spielt, so keine Ahnung, 1-2 Stunden,
wach noch nicht mal am Tag.
Was weiß ich, über ein paar Tage verteilt, dann kann man wahrscheinlich wirklich lang
Spaß haben an dem Game.
Weil man dann nie einen Blick unter die Haube machen muss.
Und bei New World ist halt beim Blick so unter die Oberfläche ist halt nie was, nirgendswo,
egal in welchem System.
... Traffic in Gaming right now, and that level of self-discipline will actually help
your overall experience in this game by slowing down the ticking time bomb.
But when that thing goes off, you will realize that this game is falling off a cliff and
was completely unfit to be released.
Let's start with what was a problem and still is, before moving to the new and exponentially
worse things that have started to come up.
Eine Sache, die mich persönlich bei New World immer noch ein bisschen abschreckt, jetzt
so rein vom Optischen, dass die Welt und die Charakter irgendwie nicht zusammenpassen.
Ich kann mir da nicht helfen, aber es sieht einfach nicht passend aus.
Sehr schwer zu beschreiben.
Ich kann das nicht.
Wisst ihr, was ich meine?
Ich kann das nicht anders erklären.
Normalerweise sehen Games in irgendeiner Art und Weise, wenn sie gut gemacht sind, so
gesamtoptisch stimmig aus.
Das gilt von Fortnite bis zu Breath of the Wild, bis zu World of Warcraft, bis zu ultra
fotorealistischen Dinger wie Crysis, wie sonst was.
Aber die haben alle irgendwie einen Grafikstil, dass da ein Gesamtbild rauskommt.
Und bei New World, finde ich, sieht die Welt aus wie aus einem, sagen wir mal, könnte
schon aus einem normalen MMO oder aus einem normalen Fantasy-Game oder sowas sein, aber
der restliche Charakter-Style, das passt irgendwie überhaupt nicht dabei.
...completely botched.
This has been an issue since long before release day and it wasn't changed.
Drop rates for certain rare resources that are needed in many different crafting recipes
either have a misplaced decimal point or they're sadistic.
There are specific resources that simply...
simply don't show up on the global market, can be farmed for dozens of hours without
getting a single one at all.
And that's perfectly fine if scarcity is the actual goal, but these are Tier 3 and Tier
4 resources, while the Tier 5 versions, hypothetically even more rare or should be, are dropping
at a frequency that is orders of magnitude greater, thereby totally undermining the entire
...
Es ist doch irgendwie so, dass keiner Eisen findet, oder?
Hab ich auch irgendwo gelesen.
...economic curve of certain professions.
Wanna craft Tier 4 legendary items?
You probably just can't.
Do it.
Not because you aren't skilled enough, not because you don't know where to look for
those components, but because those components just don't exist on your server.
I've heard rumors that some of these items are starting to drop, that people have one
or two here and there, but when recipes require 5, 10, even 20 of those items, and you only
see one on the entire server every few days, that's a broken system, and it's gonna get
worse as more players level into a bracket where they become affected by it.
Next up is...
Das ist wahrscheinlich Absicht, weil alles, was höher ist, gar nicht richtig funktioniert.
Das ist wahrscheinlich Absicht, weil alles, was hier funktioniert, nicht funktioniert.
weil sie unikale Bossen, Mechaniken und Locations haben,
während sie auch gute Gier vermitteln und die Monotonie der Open-Race-Szene verbreiten.
Äh, was sind MMOs, die schwierigst... Moment, da muss ich mal kurz was zu sagen.
Alter, ich hab immer noch irgendwas im Hals.
13 Monate, leck gut, dankeschön.
Ähm, sind MMOs, die schwierigst und komplexest in Spiele, sie zu gut zu gestalten als Developer?
Gut, ich bin kein Spieleentwickler, ich kann da jetzt nicht so aus erster Hand dazu...
Also, ich bin zwar Entwickler, aber ich bin kein Spieleentwickler.
Äh, aus erster Hand nichts dazu sagen, aber ich würde schon sagen, dass MMOs...
Vom Komplexitätsfaktor...
Hab ich dich übersehen?
Nice Subscription hier.
Für alle, die ich jetzt übersehen hab.
Gut, Flo, dankeschön für den Sub.
Ähm...
Ja, also ich würde schon sagen, dass MMOs eines der komplexesten Sachen sind.
Generell, lassen wir mal MMOs Multiplayer-Spiele mit...
Ja, also generell Multiplayer-Spiele.
Zumal MMOs ja noch die extremste Form von Multiplayer-Spielen sind.
Das ist dann nicht nur irgendwie 32, 32, 64, 64.
Wie vielleicht mal Battlefield und das ist schon komplex genug, gehe ich mal ganz stark davon aus.
Ähm, aber natürlich auch ganz andere Anforderungen.
Und...
Aber MMOs stelle ich mir als ziemlich komplex vor.
Ich meine, im Kern...
So die Grundgedanken...
So die Grundgedanken von jedem Online-Spiel sind ja meistens relativ einfach, ja?
Bei MMOs kannst du sagen, so grundgedankenmäßig...
Okay, du hast einen Client, du hast einen Server, die musst du irgendwie Heartbeat-mäßig miteinander synchen.
Du brauchst eine Datenbank, wo das Date-Training gespeichert wird.
Das ist natürlich, in der Theorie klingt das alles immer super, super simpel.
Aber im Detail würde ich schon sagen, sind MMOs mit die kompliziertesten Sachen.
Bei MMOs spielt so viel mit rein.
Du brauchst ja erstmal, selbst wenn du, und das ist schon verdammt schwierig für einen MMO,
wenn du einen guten technischen Unterbau hast, also du brauchst eine gute Server-Seite,
du brauchst eine gute Client-Seite, das muss durchdacht gemacht sein,
zu dem Spiel passend, wie da wann wie was gesynkt wird.
Es darf nicht zu viel, es darf nicht zu wenig sein.
Und so, dass es auch sicher ist, dass es keiner irgendwie exploiten kann.
Selbst wenn du das alles, also wenn du die Netzwerk- und Performance- und die Basics gut hinbekommen hast,
kann dein MMO immer noch scheiße sein, weil das Spiel kacke ist, ja?
Gut, das gilt letztendlich für jedes Game, aber bei MMOs kannst du so viel verkacken, ja?
Investment, Klassen-Balance, irgendwie Fähigkeiten-Balance, Endgame-Balancing, was PvP, Monster-Pass-Finding, alles mögliche.
Du kannst so ultra viel verkacken und ich würde schon sagen, dass MMOs sowohl vom Aufwand her,
als auch von der allgemeinen Schwierigkeit her, mit das Komplexeste und Schwierigste sind, was du machen kannst.
Das würde ich schon so sehen.
Hehe, ja.
Die Jams, Final Fantasy XIV ist ein gutes Beispiel für, wie man es von einem verkackten Produkt zu einem ganz guten Produkt hinbekommt.
Final Fantasy XIV kam ja original raus als Spiel, was glaube ich nicht mehr als 20 Spieler oder so auf dem gleichen Bildschirm zeigen konnte.
Das wissen die meisten heute gar nicht mehr.
Ich glaube es waren 20 Spieler oder so, Max, oder 10 Spieler.
Es war ein Witz für einen MMO am Anfang.
So, und das Original Final Fantasy XIV hat halt so gesagt, dass sie das Spiel nochmal komplett überarbeitet.
Haben die Hälfte der Map weggeschmissen haben, ihr Fake, rundenbasiertes System rausgeschmissen haben.
Dann kam Realm Newborn, hieß das glaube ich.
Und ab da ging es eigentlich aufwärts.
Da hatten sie auch einen neuen Director und alles.
Also bei einem MMO ist es auch wichtig, dass du irgendeinen Typ da sitzen hast, der Warnung hat von dem, was er macht.
Ja, aber die haben es hinbekommen.
Ja.
Ja, es gibt total viel.
Es gibt total viel.
Also ich muss sagen.
Ähm, Ingame, Ingame, äh, technisch was.
Wollen wir kurz ein bisschen Musik anmachen, wenn ich hier gerade am Labern bin.
Also, Ingame-Markt technisch so was, äh, Crafting und, und Preise und Drops und so angeht.
Da muss man sagen, da hat das Path of Exile, finde ich, eigentlich nahezu perfekt gemacht.
Path of Exile hat halt, dadurch, dass du Drops zum Verbessern der Items brauchst, hast du automatisch quasi.
Ein System drin, was Currency wieder vernichtet.
Was praktisch ist, weil ansonsten hast du bei MMOs, die sagen wir mal auf Gold und sowas passieren, das Problem, dass die Leute Monster killen.
Am Anfang ist ein Gold viel wert, in einem Monat ist ein Gold wenig und in einem Jahr ist ein Gold nichts.
Wisst ihr, wie ich meine?
Das wird einfach immer nur mehr.
Und das hat Path of Exile, finde ich, nahezu perfekt gemacht.
Äh, BDO hat es ein bisschen anders probiert.
13, Dankeschön für den, für den Sub.
BDO hat es ein bisschen anders probiert.
BDO sagt, hey, wir geben einfach Preise vor und reglementieren das mit so einem Auktionshaus, dass du nicht direkt an Spieler traden kannst.
Das ist genau das Gegenteil von dem, was Path of Exile macht.
Path of Exile ist im Prinzip eigentlich komplett offen, aber du verbrauchst Currency zum Craften von Items.
Die haben das, finde ich, nahezu perfekt gemacht.
Ja, die Städte sehen ja auch alle gleich aus.
Ja, das ist wirklich beeindruckend.
Das Blizzard.
Weil Love Warcraft damals so gut hinbekommen hat.
Allerdings, ähm, waren das auch, sagen wir mal, Ausnahmezustände.
Und die haben das, die haben das sehr clever gemacht damals bei World of Warcraft.
Die haben sich Leute genommen.
Das ist also eigentlich, ich meine, das war ja, es, es gab ja MMOs.
Ja, auch, auch wenn manche Leute behaupten, Blizzard hätte mit World of Warcraft MMOs erfunden, das stimmt ja nicht.
Ähm, aber die haben das sehr geschickt gemacht.
Die haben sich Leute gesucht.
Jeff Kaplan zum Beispiel, der Overwatch, Papa Overwatch Jeff.
Jeff.
Ähm, der war ja früher Everquest.
Raider, Top Raider.
Da gab's ja, da gab's ja auch Flame Posts von ihm.
Die machen sich die Leute heute noch drüber lustig.
Wo er gesagt, wo er gesagt hat, wie sehr das Game suckt und sowas.
Also, die haben sich damals Top-Leute geholt aus anderen Spielen, um ihr Endgame zu designen und sowas.
Das war schon wirklich schlau.
Dazu kam, dass das einfach, ähm, mit, mit Warcraft 3 eine super Grundlage gab.
Sowohl was Lore angeht, als auch was, was Fanbase angeht.
Das war ein besonderer, also da standen wirklich alle Sterne quasi.
So im richtigen Winkel zueinander für, für World of Warcraft.
Man muss aber sagen, an sich ist das ja kein Hexenwerk.
Andere Spiele haben das ja auch schon hingekriegt, ja.
Guckt man sich mal an, das allererste MMO so richtig, was viele Mainstream-mäßig überhaupt recognized haben, war ja Ultima, Ultima Online.
Danach hast du so Sachen wie, wie Everquest gehabt oder später noch Dark Age of Camelot, was immer noch für mich das beste PvP-Spiel aller Zeiten ist.
Was ich gerade übrigens nebenbei ein bisschen auf einem Freeshot sinnlos im Kreis laufe.
Was, aber.
Sehr langweilig ist und keiner sehen will.
Aber das ist immer noch gut.
Die haben das auch schon hinbekommen.
Und die haben das auch in relativ kurzer Zeit damals entwickelt.
Ich glaube Dark wurde in zwei Jahren oder eineinhalb Jahren oder so entwickelt.
Aber natürlich muss man sagen, die Zugänglichkeit von alten MMOs war halt echt grausam schlecht versus neue MMOs.
Also tausend Slash-Kommandos, die du wissen musstest.
Interface, was kein Mensch bedienen kann.
Und dann kam irgendwann World of Warcraft und hat gesagt, okay, wir nehmen das jetzt und machen da was wirklich Rundes draus.
World of Warcraft im Release war das perfekte MMO.
Ich habe es nie großartig gespielt, muss ich sagen.
Ich habe diesen World of Warcraft, natürlich habe ich ein bisschen gespielt, aber ich war mit anderen MMOs beschäftigt zur damaligen Zeit.
Zur damaligen Zeit galte World of Warcraft als Noob-MMO, weil es für die damalige Zeit weichgespült war.
Heute sagen die Leute Classic War so best ever.
Aber ich muss sagen, Classic War und auch die ersten Anons so irgendwie weit.
Ich habe es mitbekommen, waren mehr oder weniger das perfekte MMO.
Du konntest es gut einsteigen, es hatte aber auch genug Tiefe für absolute Hardcore-Spieler, die No Life 24-7 spielen wollten.
Sowohl von der Geschichte her hat es viele interessiert, vom Suchtfaktor her, vom Item-Train, dass es einfach was Neues war.
Die übelsten Casuals, die keine Ahnung hatten, konnten spielen.
Wie auch die super organisierten High-End-E-Sports-Raid-Typen.
Das war eigentlich insgesamt somit das perfekte Game.
Also für die MMOs der damaligen Zeit.
Das stimmt, ja.
Pogos Gift.
Weiß nicht von wann, aber doch, ich weiß.
Vor, ähm, schon ein bisschen her.
So, jetzt gucken wir aber endlich mal das Video fertig.
Null, bevor ich hier ewig rumgeschwärzt habe.
Gleich erzählt er, was New World alles kleinzeitig macht.
Naja, New World, kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten, ob das gut läuft.
Die haben jetzt erstmal ungefähr 40% der Spieler verloren innerhalb der, äh, innerhalb von zwei Wochen oder so.
Oder drei Wochen.
Und ja, das ist normal, dass es einen großen Spieler-Drop gibt, aber 40% in drei Wochen ist schon krass.
World Boss Farming.
Trust me, I'll cover that one soon, because it's an absolute joke.
Expeditions require Tuning Orbs, which are sort of key to the dungeon.
The problem? Tuning Orbs are bind-on-pickup items that require high crafting skills to make.
That means you need to have someone physically in your group in order to do them who has trained those particular skills, like stone-cutting, for example.
Seems fine so far, but wait until you learn that some of the components for those Tuning Orbs come from corrupted breaches.
Nur weil es mal Games gab, die 80% verloren haben, heißt das nicht, dass es normal ist.
Also, ey, es mag normal sein, aber normal ist auch, dass viele MMOs quasi nach dem Release innerhalb der nächsten paar Monate nahezu dead sind.
Und das ist ja das, was man vielleicht, wenn man New World spielt, nicht unbedingt haben möchte.
Breaches are another large chunk of the endgame, so that makes sense.
And you need the corrupted chunks or fragments or whatever they are, the top-tier ones, which are also bind-on-pickup.
Well, wait a second, because the corruption portals are broken right now and can't be closed, because nearly every single player in the game has an Azoth staff glitch that locks them out of both the 55- and 65-level variant types.
Okay, wenn ich es richtig verstehe, Endgame ist schon mal scuffed.
That's not good, because the corruption breaches in PvE Expeditions...
...are one of the main sources of Endgame gear.
Combined, I would argue, they're actually the majority of Endgame content, and they don't work, leading to a complete stagnation in available activities post-Level 60.
Keep in mind, like or dislike, you benefit me and this video, but what's even more important is realizing that this criticism is not a function of me complaining that the content doesn't exist, it's me claiming that the content does exist and is there, but it just doesn't fucking work.
The PvE and crafting is broken.
And when added to an economy that has no actual basis in financial reason or logic, it creates a gameplay environment that is incredibly frustrating.
Speaking of economic balance here...
Ich meine, man muss auch mal sagen, guckt euch mal im Hintergrund an, ich weiß nicht, was das ist, ob das irgendein Raid ist oder irgendein Expedition oder irgendein World Boss.
Es sieht doch schon, und das ist auch so eines meiner Kritikpunkte, die ich schon direkt in der Beta zu nehmen wollte, es sieht schon ziemlich, wie soll ich sagen, repetitiv ist das falsche Wort, das sind alle MMOs,
braindead aus.
Guck mal, der drückt zwei Skills mehr, kannst du ja in dem Spiel auch nicht machen.
Der muss nichts machen.
Oh, der macht zwei, der macht drei, drei Spels.
Ich meine, sieht das irgendwie spannend aus?
Ja, das ist das, was ich meine.
Du kannst, das ist das, was ich meine.
Du konntest easy as fuck, du konntest Area-Effekte stacken.
Dann sieht das so aus.
Guck dir das mal an.
Null.
Einfach Area-Effekte aufeinanderstellen und AE-Spam.
Easy.
Ach ja, übrigens, was Amazon gemacht hat, meines Wissens nach, sie haben einfach ausgestellt, dass diese Effekte sich überlappen.
Was sie machen ist, naja, die spammen AE-Heal und AE-Damage auf einen Punkt und alles stirbt.
Und alles ist dauerhaft geheilt.
Also muss er diese komischen Flaggen hier capturen.
Und die stellen sich einfach mit 30 Spielern hin und drücken eine Taste.
Und es ist nichts, was der Gegner tun kann.
Also, big brain.
Und Amazon hat jetzt, soweit ich das mitbekommen habe, einfach ausgestellt, dass sich Area-Effekte überlappen können.
Oder nee, dass der letzte, ich glaube, dass der letzte Area-Effekt immer gilt.
Das heißt, jetzt bringt stacken gar nichts mehr, was auch total bescheuert ist.
Eigentlich müssen Area-Effekte gestackt werden.
Und, äh, äh, äh, wie heißt das auf Deutsch?
Dass es immer weniger wird, ja?
Keine Ahnung.
Du machst, du machst ein Heal auf den Boden, der heilt 100%.
Der nächste Heal dabei bringt 80% dabei.
Der nächste Heal dabei bringt 60%.
Irgendwie sowas in der Richtung müsstest du das eigentlich machen.
Sodass es sich quasi, sag mal so, ab 10 Heals quasi nicht mehr lohnt.
Aber die hatten entweder Full-Stack, alles bringt 100% oder nichts.
Oh, how the hell this ended up being a thing.
But their response...
Oh, du hast es an!
...was die Stealth-Nerf...
...all AOEs...
...A-O-E-Abilities, which completely gutted their ability to heal or do damage...
...but didn't solve the lag problem.
Instead of having AOE-Abilities stack, they now...
Guck euch das an!
Das ist so dumm!
Wie kann...
Dass man allein schon daran nicht gedacht hat im Vorfeld.
Guck, das ist so dumm!
Guck mal, die machen nix!
Die stehen einfach an der Flagge und drücken einen Knopf.
...einigen Abilität.
Und es ist nicht die stärkste Instanz...
Das ist so dumm!
...oder der größte Wert oder Damage-Nummer.
Es ist einfach...
Whatever most recent ability was cast.
Das ist so dumm!
Which means in a 50 vs. 50 war, you are probably never going to get...
Und die Gegner machen ja das Gleiche.
Die stehen alle an der Fahne.
Das sind die Gegner.
Die stehen alle an der Fahne und jeder drückt einfach nur einen Spell.
...reasonable damage again with most AOE-Abilities.
Das ist so hängen geblieben.
The lag exploit, the thing this was designed to apparently cure,
there are still ways to do it.
Absolutely genius.
However, that's nothing compared to what comes next.
It turns out, if you shrink your game down to a window
and then click on it...
Ach ja, ja.
Das ist auch geil.
Unverwundbarkeits-Clitch.
Aber, aber, da muss ich sagen, das gab es in MMOs früher auch schon.
Ich kann mich in Dark noch dran erinnern.
Da haben Leute wirklich Fenster getrackt.
Ich muss sagen...
Alter, was ist denn heute los?
Wenn der halb abkratzt.
Ich auch in Dark damals, ja.
Und in Dark war es sogar noch so schlimm,
du konntest damit sogar auf Sachen rauf klitschen,
wo du nicht rauf klitschen solltest.
Aber seitdem haben das MMOs eigentlich den Griff bekommen.
Ihr müsst euch das mal angucken.
Das ist jetzt echter Wahnsinn.
...window and then click on it while dragging it around the screen.
You become invulnerable.
You literally cannot die.
While you drag the window around.
Footage in the background right now on video.
And that might be hilarious and stupid,
but the problem is rooted so much deeper,
it should be immediately alarming to everyone.
You don't just become invincible.
You actually physically lock in place no matter what.
For instance, if you are falling,
you just stop and float there, mid-air.
This can go on indefinitely and the reason it's so ridiculous
is because it indicates that client-side authority is absolute.
The initially discovered lag exploit?
That was client-side too.
Because you can actually still do things on your own screen,
but actions aren't executing for other people.
That kind of client-side control is horrifying
because it means there is an immeasurable amount of influence
that can be exerted over the game by individual players
a million separate ways.
The invincibility?
That's just...
—
oder sowas eingebaut, dass sobald du
dein Fenster bewegst, stürzt
das Game ab.
Ist das kein Witz? Sobald du dein Fenster
im Windows-Modus bewegst, stürzt das Game ab.
Das ist der Fix von Amazon.
Ja, aber was ich sagen wollte ist,
das ist gar kein Problem,
dass die Connection
quasi abreißt und
dann irgendwie ein Spieler in der Luft hängt oder so.
Das hat man in jedem MMO schon gesehen.
Problematisch ist, wenn dieser Spieler dann nicht mehr
damagebar ist.
Also normalerweise ist es ja so,
wenn du Linkdead oder wie auch immer man das
in dem jeweiligen Game nennt, gehst,
dann hängst du halt,
dann sendet dein Client
keine Stats mehr, dein Client verarbeitet
keine neuen Updates mehr,
aber du selbst bist halt auf dem
Server bewegungslos an dieser
Position. Das heißt, wenn dich ein Gegner
angreift, dann kann er
dich einfach killen, ohne dass du was
machen kannst, weil du bist ja quasi dein Spielster
gecrashed. So muss das auch sein.
Auf dem Server lebst du noch, aber es gibt keine Inputs mehr.
Ja.
Ja, das Problem ist, wenn du
disabelst, hast du ja nichts mehr übrig
in dem Game.
Ja.
Was ist eigentlich aus Anthem 2.0 geworden?
Das ist so brocken.
Ja.
Ja, fast alles anscheinend.
Was ist Garbage? Ich habe es nicht verstanden. Was ist Garbage? Die Spieler? Was hat er gesagt?
Ist das ein Raid oder ein Dungeon? Ich glaube, warte mal. Alter, was ist denn heute los?
ETF? Ah, die Community ist Garbage. Ah, okay.
Ich vermute mal, dass das irgendein World Boss ist oder sowas, aber ich bin mir da ehrlich gesagt nicht sicher. Keine Ahnung.
Könnte auch ein Dungeon sein. Ah, keine Ahnung.
Ah, die Community.
Bist du Max FPS? Was? Wie kommst du da drauf?
Licht.
und, nennen wir es mal, besonders hoher Game-Knowledge und vielen Spielern in Kombination,
ihr Vorteile erarbeiten kannst, dann ist es eigentlich immer so,
dass irgendwelche komischen Möchtegern-Elite-Gilden den jeweiligen Server oder was auch immer dominieren.
Das ist eigentlich mehr oder weniger normal.
Es ist halt die Frage, inwieweit das Game das noch zusätzlich fördert oder nicht.
Ich bin mal gespannt, was er dazu zu sagen hat.
Es ist in Dark auch so gewesen.
Das muss ich halt immer als Beispiel bringen, weil ich das jahrzehntelang gefühlt gespielt habe.
Und du hattest da auch sehr viele Möchtegern-Elite-Leute.
Das kann man ganz schwierig beschreiben.
So kennt ihr so Möchtegern-Elite-Leute in MMOs.
Das ist so eine ganz spezielle Gruppe von Leuten.
Das ist...
Das ist sehr schwierig zu beschreiben.
Da wird im Prinzip auch exploitet, was zu exploiten ist, wenn das irgendwie möglich ist.
Ich meine, ich habe den Scheiß, ich habe das ja früher selbst gemacht.
Da wird nicht nur exploitet, da wird auch quasi alles andere gegrieft, was sein muss.
Ich erinnere mich zum Beispiel noch daran, dass auf unserem...
Als ich Dark gespielt habe, auf meinem alten Server,
da ist jemand bei einem Verkehrsunfall gestorben.
Und dann hat man gesagt, hey...
Also die Gilde, die Gilde damals von dem, hat gesagt, wir machen quasi im Grenzgebiet,
und Dark war ja ein PvP-Spiel,
dann hatten sich quasi alle drei reiche Realms getroffen im PvP-Gebiet
und haben quasi da, wie soll man sagen, die letzte Ehre erwiesen.
So, das war ein relativ bekannter Spieler damals.
Da sind dann aus allen drei Reichen die Leute hin
und haben sich halt friedlich zusammen im Kreis hingesetzt,
und es war auch GM dabei, und das war eigentlich ganz cool gemacht.
Allerdings hattest du wieder so Möchtegern-Super-Super-Elite-Typen am Start,
die dann von der Seite reingerusht sind und angefangen haben, die Leute zu killen.
Ja, das Game erlaubt das.
Das Game erlaubt das, aber das ist trotzdem nicht die feine Art.
Ich meine, Real Life erlaubt auch vieles, um nicht zu sagen alles, also rein physikalisch.
Ja, aber erlaubt ist es nicht, und zog das oftmals zu gutem Grund.
So, und die sind dann reingerusht, so, und danach gab's...
Das ist, um jetzt mal zu erklären, was ich mit Möchtegern-Elite-Elite-Leute meine.
Und wir waren damals, muss man dazu sagen, ich weiß, MMO-Schwanzvergleich,
wir waren zumindest auf dem damaligen Saison mit die beste Achtergruppe.
Zumindest in unserem Realm.
Wir haben bei dem Scheiß halt mitgemacht, wie man das macht, man hat sich hingesetzt,
hat keinen Scheiß gemacht.
Kein Scheiß, kein Scheiß gebaut.
Und du hattest allerdings auf der anderen Seite halt Leute,
die auch permanent im Forum immer den Dicken gemacht haben.
Und das waren halt auch die gleichen Leute, die dann damals diese Zeremonie,
nenn ich's jetzt mal, gestört haben.
Und danach im Forum, Riesendiskussion.
Riesendiskussion.
Und da kamen die Leute dann an und meinten allen Ernstes, und da sieht man mal,
was das für, sag ich so, für...
für abscheuliche Leute sind, ja.
Die haben dann ernsthaft geschrieben im Forum damals, kann ich mich noch richtig dran erinnern,
ja, was stört ihr denn auch mein Spiel mit so einer Aktion?
Also aus seiner, also aus der Sicht dieser Leute hat man ihr Spiel zerstört
durch quasi so eine Trauerfeier im Grenzgebiet.
What the, also die sind so, die sind so durch gewesen.
Und es gibt so Möchtegern-Elite-Leute, die gibt es leider oft in MMOs
und halt leider auch oftmals in der Konzentration zusammen in so Möchtegern-Elite-Gilden.
Und das hast du da wahrscheinlich auch.
Und das ist halt auch ein Spiel, was das irgendwie anzieht.
...Leader Buzzcut Psycho, also known as Horrigan previously,
has a bit of a track record in Warcraft.
Oh nein.
Their group was actually banned, I believe, for attracting the attention of a US congressman
because of their propensity to do things,
like roleplay as KKK members.
Die Leute sind ja komplett durch.
Die sind ja komplett durch.
Their group goes all the way back to Planetside in Planetside 2,
where they trolled an in-game funeral for a developer, I think it was,
saying things like, we're glad he's dead.
And even my simple mention of them in a review resulted in their members
joining our Discord server to spam images of minorities being hanged.
Alter, die sind komplett durch.
I didn't even watch those videos.
We filed proper reports to Discord, the whole nine yards,
and we got rid of them, banned them from the server.
But I say this with the utmost sincerity.
The Enclave, supported by YouTubers like SwoleBenji...
Übrigens, dazu muss man sagen, also meinem Eindruck nach,
so diese Möchtegern-Elite-Leute in MMOs, die dann auch auf diesem Level agieren,
die brauchsten das zum Schocken und zum Provozieren.
Gar nicht mal, weil die das irgendwie aus innerer Einstellung her vielleicht geil finden oder so.
Die wollen einfach nur, sagen wir mal so, aufholen,
die wollen einfach nur, sagen wir mal so, Aufmerksamkeit und schocken
und halt zeigen, wie überlegen sie sich fühlen.
Das ist das, worum es bei dieser ganzen Geschichte geht.
Und da hast du halt, gerade in Top-Gilden,
hast du halt immer wieder da so ein paar spezielle Individuen, gerade in MMOs.
Warum Wumplos? Ganz einfach.
Weil ich den Account erstellt habe, bevor ich überhaupt selbst wusste, dass ich streamen will.
Was ist los? Das konnte ich ihm nicht folgen.
Ja, das sehe ich auch so.
Ja, das ist...
Das ist das, was ich eben erzählt habe.
Du kannst einfach Leute, wenn du quasi sagst, hey, keine Ahnung,
stelle euch vor, ihr seid mit euren Leuten auf dem Discord und sagt,
alter, den Typ müssen wir bannen und es reporten einfach 100 Leute aus eurer Gilde einen Typ,
dann wird er gebannt für 24 Stunden.
Weil Amazon so ein automatisches Reporting-System hat.
Ob der was gemacht hat oder nicht, ist vollkommen egal.
Der wird einfach gebannt.
Du kannst den Bann zwar erbinden,
aber du kannst den Bann nicht erbinden,
weil Amazon so ein automatisches Reporting-System hat.
Ob der was gemacht hat oder nicht, ist vollkommen egal.
Der wird einfach gebannt.
Du kannst den Bann zwar erbinden,
aber du kannst den Bann zwar erbinden,
aber das Erbinden dauert länger als der eigentliche Bann,
weil Amazon nicht hinterher kommt.
Das ist richtig Fake.
Ach ja, und die Leute, die das abusen und Banns reporten,
die werden natürlich auch nicht sanktioniert,
weil das kannst du ja nicht machen.
Sobald du Leute, die reportest, sanktionierst,
reportet ja niemand mehr.
Das automatische System ist das Problem.
Das Erbinden dauert mehr als 24 Stunden,
also wirst du einfach temporär gebannt,
für was auch immer der größere Gruppe von Dipshits denkt,
dass du gebannt werden solltest.
Es ist ein Desaster.
Das Spiel ist ein Desaster.
Das Balance ist ein Desaster.
Das PvE ist halb zerbrochen.
Und von zerbrochen meine ich, dass es wirklich nicht funktioniert.
Es blockiert riesige Schwachen der Inhalte,
die tatsächlich existieren.
Es ist also auch noch schlimmer, wenn du daran denkst.
Das PvP wird geboten,
komplett zerstört durch Verwaltungen und Verletzungen.
Die Klientenseite-Kontrolle macht es unglaublich einfach,
sich zu verletzen.
Die Leute werden von jedem anderen gebannt,
für was auch immer unter dem Sonnenlicht.
Und fast nichts davon ist legitim.
Die Kalkulationen sind gebrochen.
Und wenn du noch einen Beispiel brauchst,
was dieses Spiel gerade ist,
dann ist es im Hintergrund.
Das ist das Zustand des neuen Welt.
Du kannst Portale oder Expeditionen nicht machen.
Ich meine, du kannst es sehr unabhängig machen,
aber es ist wirklich unglaublich schwer,
jemanden zu finden, der einen dieser Orbs hat,
und dann es zu machen.
Es kann nicht wirklich gemacht werden,
so wie es geplant ist.
Die Kriege sind gebrochen.
Die Wirtschaft ist verdammt kaputt.
Also, was tun die Leute?
Sie spammen Weltbosses auf der Flucht,
bei denen du einfach französisch versuchst,
Kredite zu töten
oder einen Schlag auf den Kopf zu schlagen,
um den Boss zu töten.
So fast wie ein BDO.
Es gibt keine Fähigkeit,
keine echte Zufriedenheit.
Und du tust alles,
um in secondary Systemen teilzunehmen.
Da kann man hochspringen.
Ja, es sieht ja auch genauso aus,
als könnte man da hochspringen.
New World ist ein botschtes Spiel
in diesem bestimmten Zeitpunkt.
Es ist ein bisschen Spaß,
und wenn du planst,
es in dem meistkassuellsten Sinne zu spielen,
dann sicher.
Aber ich habe entschieden,
dass ich heute den Kanal verwenden werde,
um mich besser zu fühlen.
Denn ich wollte wirklich,
dass dieses Spiel großartig ist.
Ich wollte wirklich,
dass ich dieses Spiel als mein Haupttitel
für Wochen, Monate,
sogar Jahre genießen wollte.
Hoffentlich.
Tja, war wohl nix, ne?
Und was es jetzt ist,
tut weh.
Es tut wirklich schlecht weh.
Wie fixieren sie das?
Disablen PvP...
Aber ich sage es nur ungern.
Ich wusste es von Anfang an.
... sofort,
bis es komplett überholt werden kann.
Mach etwas,
um die korruptierten Portale
wieder funktionieren zu können,
sobald es möglich ist.
Das ist die einzige Priorität
an diesem Punkt in der Zeit.
Und entweder verbinden die Ökonomien zusammen,
oder stoppe die Möglichkeit,
dass sie von überall aus gesehen werden.
All it is right now
is a tedious, broken,
fiskally idiotic puzzle board,
where you try to get around
in two places at separate locations
Jetzt will er es wissen.
While half the endgame
isn't even playable.
And every single war
is inherently a joke.
I have no idea how people
are defending this shit.
I consider this
the end of my New World coverage.
I had initially planned
to do a series of guides,
but all I see now
is the best DPS guide,
or the best crafting methods
for our YouTubers.
Ja, das ist ja normal.
Das ist ja bei Warzone auch so.
Beste Warzone-Klasse.
Gibt's ja auch 500 Stück.
These YouTubers are basing it all
on numbers and bonuses
that don't even compute correctly,
thereby invalidating
all of their content.
But they don't compute
all of their content,
because they don't know
what they're doing.
They don't know
what they're doing
with their content.
What is the actual point here?
I'll still play
on my own a bit.
I will certainly
check out the patches.
That much is definitely true.
Because who knows,
maybe they can pull off
another one.
But I'm done covering it,
because I have nothing
positive to say anymore
about this game.
Okay, er ist richtig
pisst, das merkt man.
Er ist...
Er ist richtig pisst.
Aber ich kann's,
ich kann's,
ich kann es schon nachvollziehen.
Vor allem,
wenn ihr euch
so ein bisschen
überlegt,
dann ist das
ein bisschen
es ist ja auch,
es ist ja auch so,
wenn man sich auf
ein Game rollt
und da quasi
vielleicht sogar
Jahre verfolgt
und da mega gehypt
drauf ist
und es dann so
gegen die Wand
gefahren wird,
das ist natürlich
belastend,
ja.
Ja.
Schon wieder
ein Server
vom Schrott.
Was?
Ist das ein Server?
Das sieht,
das sieht aus
wie
irgendein
olles
frag mich nicht.
Was?
Ist das ein Server?
Ja,
doch,
ich weiß zumindest
von der CPU her
vom Schrott.
Tja,
warum nicht?
Mittlerweile wird
so viel Zeug
weggeschmissen,
weil ich meine,
ich habe vier Rechner
oder so mittlerweile
auf dem Dachboden stehen.
Was soll,
wozu soll ich
noch mehr,
noch mehr hinstellen?
Voll die Weihnachtsmusik,
ja.
Stimmt,
stimmt,
ist ja noch nicht,
ist ja nicht mehr so lang.
Ist ja nicht mehr so lang.
Guck mal,
es ist nur noch,
nur noch quasi
zwei Monate.
Ja,
und wisst ihr,
was das Beste ist?
Das allerbeste,
das
Poggerigste.
Gibt es dieses Wort überhaupt?
Also,
ich muss dieses Jahr noch arbeiten.
Eine Woche,
zack,
eine Woche,
zwei Wochen,
drei Wochen,
vier Wochen,
fünf Wochen.
Ne,
vier,
vier oder fünf Wochen.
Ich habe ja noch ein paar Tage Urlaub
und dann bin ich,
habe ich frei.
Ich habe ab hier
so in dem Dreh,
je nachdem wie viel Urlaub
ich noch übrig habe,
muss ich mal gucken,
ob ich das noch dabei nehme.
Ich habe ab hier so in dem Dreh
habe ich Urlaub
bis nächstes Jahr.
Daily Stream.
Das letzte Mal haben wir
ziemlich viele Streams gemacht.
Du hast bis Ende des Jahres
drei Projekte und Urlaub.
Wir haben auch massig Projekte,
aber das lasse ich mir
nicht in die Quere kommen.
Urlaubssperre ist auch
so ein Ding.
Das geht ja auch nur
sehr,
sehr begrenzt.
Also,
ist ja nicht,
finde ich auch ein Unding,
weil es ist ja nicht
die Schuld,
dass man so viel
Urlaub macht,
weil es ist ja nicht
die Schuld der Leute,
die es am Endeffekt
bearbeiten müssen,
sondern weil Management Fails
gebracht wurden wieder.
So,
also,
was schauen wir uns
als nächstes an?
Ich weiß,
ich weiß nicht,
was heute mit meinem Hals los ist.
Entweder habe ich mir
irgendwas eingefangen
oder ich habe noch was
von letzter Woche.
Keine Ahnung.
Das fühlt sich auch
irgendwie ein bisschen dick an.
Also,
nicht dick,
dick.
Ihr wisst,
was ich meine.
So,
also,
was schauen wir uns
als nächstes an?
Build Home Network Server Rack.
Zehn Jahre
und Battlefield 3
ist still King.
Perfect timing.
Komm,
wir gucken nochmal.
Ich meine,
es ist jetzt schon ein bisschen,
wir gucken nochmal eine Runde.
Neun Minuten
Battlefield 2042
Top Plays aus der Beta.
Übrigens,
wisst ihr eigentlich,
wie schwer das ist,
einen Cutter zu finden?
Wir suchen jetzt schon
eine ganze Weile
und irgendwie findet sich keiner.
Ich wollte ja,
ich wollte ja eigentlich,
weil tatsächlich
mal ein bisschen Geld
in die Hand nehmen,
dass mir jemand
so einen Highlight,
so einen 10,
15 Minuten Highlight
aus den Streams.
Ich glaube,
so 10,
15 Minuten Highlights
kannst du damit
halbwegs schon füllen,
denke ich mal.
Waren ja schon wirklich
ein paar coole Sachen dabei.
Fachkräftemangel,
ja.
Du kannst cutten.
Also,
ich meine,
du musst es halt,
also in Wirklichkeit
ist das Cutten
ja nur die Hälfte.
Man muss halt auch
die Streams durchskippen
und Sachen raussuchen
und so.
Also,
ich habe keine Ahnung,
wo da was ist.
Also,
man muss sich
die Streams
durchskippen
und so.
Also,
wenn ihr wirklich
Interesse habt
am Cutten,
dann schreibt mir mal
eine Mail
an meine Business-Adresse.
Die steht auf dem YouTube-Profil
mit Preisvorstellungen
und eventuell auch,
was ihr schon so gemacht habt
in dieser Richtung.
Dann kommen wir da
bestimmt zusammen.
Ich habe damit
keine Schmerzen,
ein bisschen Kohle auszugeben.
Da hättest du sogar
Referenzen.
Jetzt wird es aber
big brainig hier.
Das wäre cool.
Also,
wie gesagt,
ihr könnt bei mir
auf YouTube
einfach auf den
auf den Channel
die About-Page
und dann könnt ihr euch
meine E-Mail-Adresse
Business Inquiry
anzeigen lassen.
Das wäre cool.
Ich glaube,
da finden wir irgendwas.
Und wie gesagt,
ihr müsst es
auch nicht
umsonst machen.
Aber
zumindest mal
euer Stundensatz
beziehungsweise
was ihr euch so vorstellt,
so grob,
wäre interessant,
weil
5.000 Euro
will ich dafür
jetzt nicht ausgeben.
Ich habe
einen Cutter
schon
und da habe ich
bis jetzt noch
nichts gehört.
Aber wenn das einer von euch
gut kann,
wäre natürlich nice.
Zumal ihr ja auch
ein bisschen mit meiner Art
und mit meinen Streams
vertraut seid.
Das wäre schon recht
nice.
So,
was gucken wir uns
als nächstes an?
I build
Home
Netzwerk
Setup.
Was hat er denn hier
am Start?
Ein Schrank.
Ja gut,
ein Schrank
habe ich auch.
Okay,
er hat.
Ich glaube mal
ein bisschen was dazu.
Er hat Dell Kissen
Dark Fate.
Alter,
das ist ja der
der Edgy,
der Most Emo
Edgy Name
für einen Server,
den ich je gehört habe.
Dark Fate.
Alter,
das,
das musst du erst mal
hinkriegen.
Salve.
Ach du Scheiße.
Das ist ja
die Server Name.
Gut,
ich meine immer noch besser
als nordische Götter
und sowas.
Das ist auch schon
sehr beliebt.
Also ich nenne
meine Systeme mittlerweile
nach Twitch Emotes.
Ich habe sogar eins,
das heißt Eleven Head.
Das ist zwar kein
Emo,
wobei ich weiß gar nicht,
gibt es Eleven Head
als Emo?
Eleven Head
doch hier.
Nee,
das ist kein richtiges
Eleven Head,
wie ich mir das
vorstelle.
Ach,
das sind Terminator Filme.
Ach so,
dann heißen die eben
so Emo mäßig.
Also ich,
ich bin,
ich nenne meine Systeme
nach Twitch Emotes.
Ich habe so,
ich habe schon alles
mit.
Ich habe Pepega,
Ayaya habe ich auch.
Eleven Head
ist im Keller.
Der neue,
der neueste Raspberry Pi
im Keller,
der heißt Eleven Head.
Der macht,
das ist da auch,
wo die Heizung
ausgelesen wird drauf.
Okay,
er hat Dell Server.
Ich vermute mal,
das sind ein bisschen ältere
Gebrauchte.
Das ist übrigens,
das findet man heute
übrigens heute
auch noch öfters,
dass so Kisten
im DVD Laufwerk haben.
DVD Laufwerk
und VGA aus.
Ausgänge
sind alles noch
alive.
Oh,
das ist jetzt hier
neueste,
neueste Feature von Twitch,
sehe ich gerade.
Erste Chat Nachricht
des Zuschauers
Leia BW01
Moin.
Das hier
Massive
Five Head Feature
von Twitch.
Es ist übrigens,
ich will,
ich will das gar nicht hören,
was er erzählt.
Ich will bis jetzt
dazu erzählen.
Das sind,
das sind tatsächlich,
das sind tatsächlich
Terminator Filme.
Aber die sind,
die sacken eigentlich
alle.
Du fragst dich,
warum man sowas
zu Hause betreibt.
Tja,
in dieser,
in dieser Fülle
verstehe ich es auch nicht.
Also,
wenn man daheim
ein paar Controller hat,
sagen wir mal,
vielleicht ein paar Raspberry Pies
oder eine etwas größere Kiste
oder eine Nass
oder so,
kann ich,
kann ich verstehen.
Aber das allein schon
von den Stromkosten her.
Also,
zumindest in Deutschland
sind die Stromkosten
dafür viel zu hoch.
Ich weiß nicht,
wie die Stromkosten
bei den Amis sind.
Wir haben noch
ältere geschenkt bekommen.
Naja,
gut,
aber selbst die verbrauchen
ja Strom.
Terminator 2 beste.
Ja,
sehe ich auch so.
Was hat er denn sonst noch
hier am Start?
Storage.
Ist das 2,5 Zoll?
Das kann man immer
schlecht erkennen.
Amis haben 30 Prozent
von unseren Kosten.
Das ist ein Drucker.
Übrigens,
ich habe gelesen,
Epson
oder was,
Canon,
weiß nicht,
ich sag,
irgendein Druckerhersteller
wird jetzt verklagt
bei den Amis,
weil sie haben
es so gemacht,
dass wenn die Tinte
aus ist,
geht der Scanner
nicht mehr.
Muss man sich mal
vorstellen.
Wenn die Tinte,
wenn die Tinte kaputt,
also wenn die Tinte leer ist,
dann schaltet sich
der Scanner aus.
Ist doch logisch.
Ja,
komplett.
Komplett logisch.
Was ist Canon?
Ich meine,
die haben echt den Arsch
offen.
Übrigens,
was auch geil ist,
manche Designs
verstehe ich nicht.
HP Laser,
Laser Drucker
Multifunktions,
manche Designs
verstehe ich nicht.
Also HP macht ja Werbung,
zum Beispiel
für solche Geräte,
dass sie besonders flach
sind,
nicht flach,
dass sie besonders
kompakt sind.
So,
und dann hat man
solche Sachen.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ob das der hier jetzt ist.
Ja, hier,
guck mal,
genau das.
Man sagt,
der Drucker ist super
kompakt
und dann
macht man
den Stecker
so hinten dran.
Wie dumm
und bescheuert
kann ein Hersteller
eigentlich sein?
Ich meine,
wie,
oh Mann,
das ist so dumm.
Das ist so dämlich.
Hätte man,
man hätte es ins Gehäuse
reinmachen können,
man hätte es im Zweifelsfall
hier seitlich machen können,
aber hinten,
wenn man sich
ein super kompaktes
Gerät kauft,
dann macht man das doch,
damit es eben
in die Ecke passt
und nicht so.
Was, warum?
Und außerdem,
warum so ein fetter Stecker?
Man könnte den Stecker winkeln,
man könnte beispielsweise
ein externes Netzteil machen,
was man auf die Erde legen kann.
Was auch immer,
wegen der Belüftung,
ja vielleicht,
aber dann ist es bescheuert,
ihn überhaupt so klein zu bauen,
weil es einfach nur Augenwischerei ist.
Guck mal hier,
der hat,
der hat es gut gemacht,
der Typ.
Hallo,
ich will dieses Bild
hier aufmachen.
Mein Gott,
Amazon,
sei mal nicht so pip.
Warum ist Amazon so pipiga?
Warum kann ich nicht
dieses Bild aufmachen?
Hier neben,
hier neben sieht man es ja.
Abgewinkelt.
Selbst da braucht es
eigentlich noch mehr als
mehr als gedacht.
Schief.
Hä?
Wo befinde,
erforderlich?
Warum ist es erforderlich?
Warum ist es erforderlich,
meine Postleitzahl einzugeben
für einen fucking Drucker?
Das ist ganz wichtig.
Also,
die Postleitzahl,
die ist enorm,
enorm wichtig
für den Drucker.
Also,
ich wüsste gar nicht,
wie mein Drucker
ohne meine Postleitzahl
überhaupt drucken
und scannen sollte.
Aber,
ich wollte euch eigentlich
nur das mit dem Stecker zeigen,
dass es richtig hängen geblieben ist.
Also,
ich möchte euch
eigentlich nur das mit dem Stecker zeigen,
dass es richtig hängen geblieben ist.
Also,
ich wollte euch eigentlich
nur das mit dem Stecker zeigen,
dass es richtig hängen geblieben ist.
Hängen geblieben.
Hat mein Drucker
auch verboten
ins Internet zu gehen?
Gute Frage.
Ich glaube,
meiner kommt auch nicht ins Internet.
Ohne HP?
Was?
Ohne Account
und Onlinezugang
scannt der auch nicht.
Mein Gott,
ist das bescheuert.
Fünf Sterne Gerät
passt ins Legal.
Ja,
Regal.
wenn das die einzige Anforderung ist.
Also,
ich habe auch
ein Epson Multifunktionsgerät,
leider Tintenstrahldrucker
und ich drucke so selten,
dass ich halt immer
weiß,
dass es dann meistens
eingekrustet ist,
wenn ich schon was drucken muss.
Muss ich erstmal
Düsenreinigung machen.
Aber ich habe,
das ist nicht so schlimm.
Ich habe schwarze Tinte
im 10er-Pack gekauft
von einem Drittanbieter.
Kostet irgendwie nur 15 Euro.
So,
was hat er sonst noch am Start?
Also,
er hat zumindest schon mal
einen komplett,
das ist so,
sieht zumindest wie
ein Full-Size-Rack aus.
Also,
sprich irgendwie,
was ist denn so 80 Zentimeter
irgendwie sowas oder so.
Tiefe
und 19 Zoll Breite
und auch relativ hoch.
Was ist das?
48 HE oder sowas.
Das ist ein normales Rack.
Wird bei mir im Leben
nicht in den Raum reinpassen.
Flix.
W-Flix.
Alter,
was,
was macht der daheim
denn damit?
The fuck?
But why?
Der W-Flix.
Ah,
jetzt,
jetzt erklärt er,
was es ist.
Moment,
das müssen wir uns anhören.
Jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt.
Der W-Flix.
Was?
Yu,
Yu-Gi-Oh!
Pro?
Ah,
Yu-Gi-M.
Yes,
Ja,
ja.
Weil ich habe
Ich wollte mir ja auch schon mal so einen Raspberry Pi Rack ausdrucken, aber dann ist
mir aufgefallen, ich habe keine Raspberry Pis für den Serverraum stehen, außer einen
für den 3D Drucker und der muss oben auf dem 3D Drucker stehen und für den lohnt sich
das nicht.
Aber cool ist es.
Was hat er da hängen?
Ist es ein Zero oder was hat er da dran hängen?
Und eine SSD.
Alter, da willst du aber auch wissen.
Ey, wenn der Strom bei uns nicht so teuer wäre, hätte ich sowas auch.
Aber das lohnt sich, Mann, null.
Also nie.
Das ist ein Zero.
Und das ist die typische Aussage für, das bleibt für immer kaputt.
I get a replacement soon for, das heißt nie wird das replaced.
Also, so cool das von der Technik her ist, man muss immer die Abwägung treffen und ich
finde, gerade wenn man Technik begeistert ist, ich kann mich aber damit auch identifizieren,
ja.
Trifft man die oftmals vielleicht ein bisschen zu einseitig, man muss die Abwägung treffen
zwischen Ausfallwahrscheinlichkeit und zusätzlichem Verwaltungsaufwand.
Und in der Regel ist das im Heimbereich nicht gegeben.
Im Heimbereich, wenn du da einen Backup machst von deinem Netzwerk-Storage auf eine externe
Platte oder meinetwegen Offsite auf irgendeinem Cloud-Drive oder so, reicht voll und ganz.
Die ganze zusätzliche Verwaltung ist nicht gegeben.
Die ganze Zusatzverwaltung, die du dann hast, von irgendwelchen Heartbeat-Configs zum automatisch
umschalten, von irgendwelchen redundanten Anbindungen zu sonst was, Port-Bondings, was
auch immer, machen das in der Regel so unnötig komplex und kompliziert, dass du quasi durch
die Verwaltung viel, viel mehr Zeit aufwendest, als du jemals durch den Ausfall verlieren
würdest.
Und bei dir daheim kostet halt auch ein Ausfall von einer Minute keine Million.
Ja, sehr wichtig, dass das PoE ist.
Muss man wohl richtig Bock drauf haben.
Ich hab da richtig Bock drauf.
Ich mach ja sowas gerne.
Aber ich bin halt mittlerweile auch schon auf dem Stand, dass ich sage, hey, ich will mich
eigentlich möglichst wenig um ein Setup kümmern müssen.
Es soll einfach funktionieren.
Deswegen bin ich mittlerweile auch immer relativ...
relativ schnell dabei, wenn ich irgendwas Neues ausprobiere und ich merke, dass ich
das nicht benutze, das wieder einzustampfen.
Weil es hat echt keinen Sinn.
Also, guck mal, zum Beispiel, zum Beispiel, mal ein Beispiel von mir jetzt oder generell,
was wahrscheinlich viele daheim haben.
Ihr habt so Anforderungen, die ihr abdecken wollt, was weiß ich.
Ihr habt ein bisschen Hardware rumliegen und ihr wollt irgendwie erfassen, wo die Hardware
ist, in welcher Schublade und so.
Ja, da gibt es ja Verwaltungssysteme für.
Dann wollt ihr vielleicht eure Notizen irgendwie synchronisieren.
Dann wollt ihr vielleicht irgendwie einen Cloud Drive haben und sonst was.
Und dann installiert ihr euch, was weiß ich, 15 verschiedene Produkte.
Vielleicht irgendwelche Docker-Dienste.
Macht ihr irgendwie ein Docker-Compose-File, installiert euch irgendwie 15 verschiedene
Dienste, die ihr natürlich alle mit der Zeit warten und pflegen und euch damit auseinandersetzen
müsst.
Und am Ende habt ihr 15 Sachen.
Dann installiert und davon benutzt ihr zwei.
So, und wenn man mal ehrlich ist, könnte man wahrscheinlich 90% davon mit einem problichen
Wiki abfackeln.
Ja, für 5 Schubladen mit Hardware drinne, brauche ich kein Asset-Management.
Da reicht es, wenn ich ein Wiki mit einer Tabelle habe, zum Beispiel.
Das mag zwar alles nicht so fancy sein, wie man das gerne hätte, aber das ist so meine
Ansicht der Dinge mittlerweile.
Man muss die Sache nicht verüberkomplizieren.
Um, um, um des Willens des Verkomplizierens, ja, und ich habe ja auch viele sinnlose Sachen
laufen gehabt und mittlerweile bin ich runter auf, glaub, fünf, fünf Sachen oder so.
Ja, das ist, das ist das, das ist das, das ist, das ist, das ist die Nextcloud, wobei
ich die immer noch hasse, aber das Beste so gerade für Sync ist bei mir, ähm, nen Wiki.
Was hab ich denn sonst noch?
Ich glaub, das, ach so, ja, äh, der, der, ähm, für Let's Encrypt-Zertifikate davor, nen
Loadbalancer und, äh, kein Loadbalancer, Reverse-Proxy und dann noch ein paar Raspberry Pis im Haus.
Aber es ist mittlerweile relativ minim, ach so, mein Home Assistant hab ich ja ganz vergessen.
Was hängst du mit Nextcloud zum Beispiel, wie den, den Passwort-Save und Notizen und
sowas?
Aber ich hasse Nextcloud, ihr wisst, ich mag Nextcloud überhaupt nicht.
Ja, und natürlich die Home Assistant VM mit, äh, Heimatomatisierung.
So, also das sind die fünf Sachen und das reicht, ich brauch keine 15 Sachen, mach so
dünn den erst, nö, wozu?
So, ähm, jetzt wollte ich jetzt sagen, hast du die Namensänderung von McCree mitbekommen?
Ja, hab ich mitbekommen, da ist jetzt, äh, äh, Cassidy, Cole Cassidy oder so, ne, McCree,
die sexistische Sau hier, McCree, endlich umbenannt, bam, also, ja, man, ich will nicht
von dem Thema anfangen.
Aber, Blizzard hat halt damit, na, wie soll ich sagen, das ist so eine typische Blizzard-Aktion,
so, guckt her, wir tun da was.
Äh, niemand, der bei Blizzard irgendwie geschädigt wurde, hat aber was von, dass McCree umbenannt
wurde.
Wann gibt's das Video mit C-Sharp, welches Video?
Wieso war der Name sexistisch?
Weil McCree nach einem Mitarbeiter benannt wurde, der sich da, tja, was, ich weiß gar
nicht, was der Mitarbeiter gemacht hat, aber der soll zumindest in diesen ganzen,
in diesen ganzen, in diesen ganzen, in diesen ganzen, in diesen ganzen, in diesen ganzen,
in diesen ganzen, in diesen ganzen, in diesen ganzen, in diesen ganzen, in diesen ganzen, in diesen
Sexismus und, äh, Belästigungsskandal verwickelt gewesen sein.
Ja, wird mal wieder Zeit, hast recht.
Und jetzt hat Blizzard gesagt, wir haben die Auswahl zwischen, wir klären ordentlich auf
und, äh, versuchen vielleicht sogar, die Leute, die davon geschädigt wurden, finanziell
ein bisschen zu kompensieren oder wir benennen den Charakter um.
Hat sich Blizzard dafür entschieden, naja, gut, wir benennen den Charakter um.
Logisch, was denn sonst?
Man hätte ja auch was Sinnvolles machen können.
Frag mich eh, was bei der ganzen Geschichte rauskommt.
Ich hoffe, die kriegen richtig einen auf den Sack.
Naja, gucken wir weiter.
Für mich ist das irgendeine typische Blizzard,
ihr seht her, wie toll wir darauf reagieren.
Blizzard-Bad-Kill.
Kannst du mich grüßen?
Nein, kann ich nicht, weil ich davon ausgehe,
dass das G-Bait ist.
Und weißt du, warum ich davon ausgehe,
dass das G-Bait ist?
Weil ich davon ausgehe, dass wenn man deinen Namen ausspricht,
weil irgendwas sagt, was man nicht sagen will.
Mein Gehirn reicht gerade nicht dazu aus,
zusammenzusetzen, was es sein könnte.
Aber sus, auf jeden Fall.
Aber ich kann den nicen Twitch-User grüßen.
Das ist okay.
Das kann ich machen.
Aber aussprechen tue ich es nicht.
So, also was hat denn der Typ hier noch am Start?
Ja, weil auch so viel Netzwerkdinger bei ihm immer ausfallen.
Jetzt müsste man ihn mal fragen,
wie oft ist es schon vorgekommen,
dass dein Netzwerkport einfach mal ausgefallen ist?
Oder deine Netzwerkports einfach mal.
Und ich wette mit dir, er sagt nie.
Er könnte es jetzt ja einfach mal demonstrieren,
indem er ein Kabel rauszieht.
Naja, es geht.
Es geht tatsächlich.
Ähm, also gerade bei 10G ist es mit SFP-Modulen fast billiger als mit Kabel.
Es ändert sich gerade ein bisschen.
Aber es ist, also es war lange Zeit so und es ist eigentlich auch immer noch so,
dass gerade wenn du kurz, ja, wenn du da irgendwie was auch immer hinstellst,
aber wenn du dir dann, keine Ahnung, du kaufst dir einen 10G-MikroTik-Switch für 150 Euro,
du kaufst dir einen Direct-Attach-Kupferkabel mit zweimal SFP auf beiden Seiten,
das geht zwar maximal, frag mich nicht, 10 Meter oder so,
dann kostet dich das nochmal 30 Euro und dann bist du fertig.
Und kürzere Direct-Attach-Kabel sind billig als fuck.
Also es ist definitiv günstiger als 10G-Kupfer-Switche mit vielen Ports.
Das ist ja gerade der Witz bei 10G.
In der Regel fährst du mit SFP sogar besser.
Allerdings brauchst du zumindest ein paar Kupfer-Ports,
weil es halt immer noch viele Geräte gibt dafür.
Und was auch nice ist, es gibt vereinzelt relativ günstige SFP auf RJ45-Adapter.
Da muss man aber immer mal warten, bis die im Sale sind oder so,
weil normalerweise sind die in dem Dreh, aber die gehen teilweise runter bis auf 30,
das ist aber, das ist ein 1G, und da muss man mal Ausschau halten,
deswegen habe ich mir da auch mal einen größeren Pack von gekauft.
Ja, hier gehen wir zum Beispiel schon eher in die Richtung,
das kann sich auch lohnen, wenn man zu wenig Kupfer-Ports hat, aber noch SFP-Plus-Ports frei.
Ja, das haben die bei uns auch schon geschafft.
Das haben die bei uns auch schon geschafft.
Man muss sagen, Glasfaserkabel sind, ich bin da immer wieder selbst erstaut,
erstaunlich widerstandsfähig, ja.
Also ich würde...
Also in der Regel, wenn ich die Dinger einmal geknickt habe,
würde ich davon ausgehen, nicht so richtig geknickt, bis es krrrr macht,
sondern wenn ich die Dinger einmal zu eng gelegt habe,
würde ich denken, ich wäre immer, fuck, es ist kaputt.
Aber legit, ich habe noch nie geschafft, ein Glasfaserkabel kaputt zu machen.
Obwohl ich die Dinger schon teilweise mehrfach so gedreht habe,
dass ich mir gedacht habe, fuck, jetzt ist es kaputt.
Ich habe noch nie geschafft, ein Glasfaserkabel kaputt zu machen.
Beste Consumer-Small-Business-Switcher.
Guck dir die MikroTik-Switcher an.
Das ist wirklich nicht schlecht, was die haben, Preis-Leistung.
Preis-Leistungs-mäßig.
Feature-technisch ist Router-OS auch wirklich super,
allerdings busy kompliziert.
Aber Preis-Leistungs-mäßig, guck mal hier, sowas.
Preis-Leistungs-mäßig ist das einfach eines der besten Switcher,
die du dir holen kannst.
24 Gigabit-Ports, 2x10G SFP+,
für 130 Euro.
Switch-OS ist die etwas einfachere Variante.
Da kann man sich echt nicht beschweren.
Also ich bin, ihr wisst, ich bin MikroTik-Fan.
Die sollten mich mal sponsoren.
Pizza oder Lasagne?
Lasagne.
Doch, ich bin für, äh, wie heißt es genau?
Pide.
Pide-Sucuk.
Beste.
Also ich muss ja sagen,
Sucuk-Pide, größer Salami-Pizza.
Aber Pizza oder Lasagne geht natürlich auch.
Eigentlich, eigentlich alles, was gut schmeckt und Pepo-Fett macht.
Hallo, danke für den Sub.
Wie findest du die neuen Mainz-T-Bus?
Habe ich mich noch null mit beschäftigt.
Nein, da ist die Originalfirma drauf.
Man kann manche MikroTik-Geräte flashen.
Mit, äh, ich glaube, ich glaube auch ein WRT oder so.
Der Max hat sich...
Hey, ich bin der Meinung, dass Essen eines der besten Themen für Integration ist.
Ja, da sind sich die meisten Menschen relativ schnell einig.
Anstatt irgendwelche Integrationskurse, sollte man einfach, wir fressen zusammen, Kurse machen.
Und dabei was lernen vielleicht.
Wann kommt wieder Frontend-Web-Dev?
Tja, wir müssen so viel Zeug noch machen.
Als nächstes werden wir Self-Hosted-Discord-Alternativen ausprobieren.
Habe ich nämlich gesehen, gibt es so zwei, drei Sachen und ich vermute mal, sie sind alle kacke.
Hast du deine Temperatursensoren wieder retten können?
Noch nicht, aber es gibt jetzt, ich habe nämlich dem Entwickler drei, drei Exemplare geschickt zum Ausprobieren.
Es gibt seit gestern einen Patch dafür.
Und den werden wir ausprobieren.
Vielleicht sogar heute Abend noch.
Man kann jetzt nämlich flashen wieder.
So.
Schauen wir mal weiter.
Und wo wir gerade, weil der Umut hier gerade geschrieben hat, integrieren.
Ich habe eine mega Cringe-Werbung gesehen von der Telekom.
Die Telekom hat jetzt irgendwie ein Equal-E-Sport-Fest oder sowas.
Und nichts gegen die eigentliche Idee, aber das ist wieder so cringe aufgezogen von der Telekom.
Irgendwelche super Hipster-Leute, wo ich mir denke, was haben die eigentlich mit Gaming zu tun?
Was machen die da überhaupt?
Max, guck dir BigBad an.
Was für ein Ding?
Das sagt mir irgendwas.
Ist das nicht irgendwie so ein Netzwerkverwaltungs-Ding?
Wie hast du denn die Thermostate in HA integriert?
Ich habe ein ESP32 bei mir im Bad hängen, der Bluetooth-Signale empfängt vom Temperatursensor im Kühlschrank, von der Waage und von den Thermostaten.
Und es dann über WLAN, MQTT und Home Assistant schickt.
Alles, was die Telekom macht, ist cringe.
Ja, schon ein bisschen.
Was für Hipster-Leute.
Ich kenne die nicht.
Aber Leute, die einfach richtig krass Hipster aussehen.
Oder sagen wir mal so, wahrscheinlich sind das alles richtig krasse Selbstdarstellungs-Influencer.
Das fand ich ja geil, ne?
Wer hat die Merkel damals interviewt?
Ich habe das schon wieder vergessen.
Aber, wo sie dann gefragt hat, ja und, was machen sie so?
Nur Selbstdarstellung oder so?
Ne, ne, ne, ne, nicht LeFloid.
Irgendeine Frau.
Nein, nein, nein, nicht LeFloid.
Und wurde dann gefragt, und was machen sie so?
Selbstdarstellung oder noch was anderes oder so?
Und die hat das noch nicht mal als Flame gemeint.
Aber es hat sich so krass Flame-mäßig angehört.
Aber die meinte das wahrscheinlich gar nicht so.
Es war, ne, ne, ne, LeFloid nicht.
Das muss ich jetzt mal kurz suchen.
Merkel Interview Selbstdarstellung.
Ja.
Machen sie sonst nur Selbstdarstellung?
Genau.
Moment, wo ist das?
Da musste ich echt kecken.
Richtig, richtig spannend.
Tja.
Keine Ahnung, man findet es, man findet es nicht.
Aber die, die ist das.
Aber ich weiß halt nicht, an welcher Stelle.
Und wir gucken uns jetzt bestimmt nicht das ganze Interview an.
Das ist mein erstes Interview.
Genau das.
Du sagst, das ist mein erstes Interview.
Und dann fragt die Merkel so, was machen sie sonst so?
Nur Selbstdarstellung oder was?
Und ich weiß, ich, also ich weiß, ich weiß.
Ich gehe davon aus.
Das ist kein Flame, aber das hat sich dann einfach so richtig, richtig burned angehört.
Okay.
Lass mal schnell hier das Video weiter gucken, auf fertig gucken.
Also bei ihm weiß ich überhaupt nicht, was da abgeht.
Also er hat gar nicht erklärt, er hat gar nicht erklärt, warum der so viel Zeug hat.
Irgendwie einmal ESX hat er gesagt und dann Storage.
Aber warum?
Und dass er 10G Zeug hat.
Was ist denn das?
Warum, warum, warum leuchtet das da so?
Das, das, grüne USB-Sticks.
Na, so musst du es natürlich machen, ja.
Ganz wichtig, so ein, so ein WLAN-Stecker.
Übrigens, das würde ich, jetzt mal by the way, das würde ich auch so machen, weil
schaltbare, ähm, rack-mountable Steckdosen,
sind unsinnig teuer.
Also so eine schaltbare rack, äh, remote, äh, IP-Steckdose
für rack-Bauweise, da kannst du 500 Euro für bezahlen.
Äh, du kannst dir aber auch einfach eine billige China-Chinesen-Ali-Express-Steckdosen-Leiste
ins rack legen für 20 Euro.
Äh, nein, ich hab kein Home-Story-Cop.
Ich hab auch lange kein StarCraft 2 mehr geguckt.
Maybe 30 minutes total, if the power goes out.
Enough time to get a generator.
Meine USV ist immer noch kaputt.
Und der einzige Ausfall, den ich jemals hatte in meinem rack, lag nicht am Stromausfall,
sondern weil die USV kaputt gegangen ist.
Richtiger Pains-Champ.
Wo wir wieder beim eigentlichen Thema sind, man muss immer abwägen Komplexität zu Ausfallwahrscheinlichkeit
zu Verwaltungsaufwand.
Mein rack hatte nie Probleme und einmal war's aus.
Warum war's aus?
Weil die USV verreckt ist.
Immer noch kaputt.
Und ich mach jetzt auch keine neue mehr dran.
Und dann auch,
keine redundante USV gehabt.
Nein.
Hab ich nicht.
Wie macht man eigentlich redundante USVs?
Steckt man dann die eine USV in die andere USV rein?
Oder wie funktioniert das?
Also steck ich dann quasi die erste USV in die zweite USV und dann in die zweite USV die Rechner?
Oder wie?
Oder wie würdest du das machen?
Ich mein, es gibt bestimmt USVs mit zwei Batterien und so drin.
Aber wenn man's billig machen will,
Y-Kabel, dann wird das nicht funktionieren.
Kein Server mit zwei Netzteilen?
Nö.
Ah, das Interview mit, okay, jetzt müssen wir uns das kurz angucken.
Zack.
Hier hat hier jemand, hier hat hier jemand, äh, das rausgesucht.
Das ist, das ist schon ein bisschen, ach du, cringe, cringe, cringe, cringe warning.
Das ist gut zu wissen, dann bedanke ich mich bei Ihnen, das war übrigens mein allererstes Interview.
Das war wirklich sehr interessant.
Ihr allererstes Interview im Leben?
Ja.
Sonst machen Sie immer nur Selbstdarstellung.
Nein.
Krass geroastet, Alter.
Mehr Produkte oder wie?
Die meinte das ja gar nicht so.
Das war nicht als Flame.
Das war, ich wette mit euch, das war nicht als Flame gedacht.
Aber es ist einfach so geil.
Und was machen Sie sonst für Selbstdarstellung?
Yep.
Es fehlt noch ein paar Ausbildungen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es als Flame gedacht war.
Das ist ja die, jetzt mal ehrlich.
Wie willst du das denn sonst umschreiben, was die meisten Leute machen?
Selbstdarstellung ist eigentlich der korrekte Begriff dafür.
Klingt aber halt so, so, so roasted, ja.
Oh Mann.
Na gut, wir haben es uns, oh, das ist mal Big Brain.
Wie der sein, guck mal hier, wie hat er dann seine Unify-Access-Point.
Unify-Access-Point daneben dran.
Das ist mal hier, 5-Head, 5-Head-Montage.
Ich muss aber dazu sagen,
bei mir im Keller,
ist es ähnlich.
Ich habe ja im Keller einen Access-Point hängen,
im ersten, im Erdgeschoss und im ersten Stock.
Und im Keller ist es so,
ich habe das, ich habe das, das LAN, also das, das LAN-Kabel,
das Netzwerkkabel,
habe ich einfach doppelt um ein Rohr gewickelt
und dann den Access-Point rein, das ist ja PoE,
und dann den Access-Point reingesteckt,
weil nichts zum Festhalten, zum Festmachen war.
Jetzt hängt der halt am Netzwerkkabel da an der Wand runter.
Warum nicht?
Und was ich bis heute nicht verstehe ist,
warum sich meine Lampe im Wohnzimmer im ersten Stock
am Access-Point im Keller anmeldet.
Das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Die könnte sich am Access-Point im ersten Stock anmelden,
am Access-Point im Erdgeschoss anmelden,
aber nein, die meldet sich am Access-Point im Keller an.
Das verstehe ich nicht so genau.
Alles andere kann ich nachvollziehen,
aber warum die den weitesten entfernten Access-Point,
um sich anzumelden, nimmt, keine Ahnung.
Das ist aber auch das einzige Gerät, wo ich nicht verstehe,
warum die sich da anmeldet.
Ganz noch MAC-Adress-Filter machen.
Na gut, das funktioniert, das Rest ist mir egal.
Aber ich verstehe es nicht.
Wahrscheinlich muss der Empfang da aus irgendwelchen Gründen
an dieser Stelle der beste aus dem Keller sein.
Aus Liebe.
Genau, das wird es sein.
Share, Like, Subscribe.
So, next.
Recabeling and Tire.
Alter, was geht mit dem ab?
Warum schreiten die da so rum?
Kekona!
Kekona-Wand.
Wird wieder durchgebohrt.
Just, just Kekona.
Wobei, nee, das sieht eigentlich fast aus wie eine normale Wand, oder?
Oder? Oder nicht?
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, Kekona-Wand.
Kekona-Wand, confirmed.
Ja, die Abis! Die Abis!
Die Abis!
Viel Spaß bei uns in dem Haus.
Aber so ein Gipsding.
Es sieht aber, sag mal.
Das ist eines der schäpsten und hässlich ausgeschnittensten Dinger,
die ich je gesehen habe.
Aber gut, das wird funktionieren, gerade wenn du da so was mit Verkleidung oben draufsitzt.
Hat er erst mal das Cushion besser geholt.
Er hat das Kabel angesägt.
Ach, egal.
Macht nix.
Nee, das macht wirklich nix.
Das macht nix.
Ich würde allerdings an der Stelle dann nicht noch wirklich dran rumfuddeln.
Ich meine, der Vorteil ist, wenn man in so einem Haus lebt,
das Haus ist billiger als ein richtiges Haus zu bauen.
Das heißt, wenn irgend so ein Tornado wieder kommt und das Haus kaputt macht,
ist es wahrscheinlich einfacher, das Haus, also es ist wahrscheinlich billiger,
das Haus zehnmal neu aufzubauen,
als einmal ein richtiges Haus zu bauen, was dann nur halb kaputt geht.
Kekona-Logik.
Holy cow, drei Kabels, OMG.
Da hat er so ein Patch-Panel oben.
Okay, das müssen wir uns jetzt nicht angucken.
Er hat aber ordentlich was zu tun, wenn er das hier alles aufdingsen will.
Wie heißen diese Werkzeuge nochmal, die man dafür braucht?
Also, den letzten Stecker mit so einem, ich hab ja so was ähnliches.
LSI.
LSA?
Ah, ja, genau.
Wir haben ja letztens sowas auch gemacht mit einem Keystone,
mit so einem Keystone-Adapter, das sieht ja auch so aus,
bloß, dass man es dann zuklappt.
Und das habe ich einfach von Hand drauf gemacht
und mit dem Schraubenzieher reingedrückt, das ging auch.
Chat wieder, ja, too smart.
Die Ami-Wand ist der Wahnsinn.
Aber das ist wirklich sehr nice, ich kann euch das mal zeigen.
Guck mal sowas hier.
Das ist wirklich Poggers.
Da musst du nämlich nichts mehr crimpen,
sondern wir können das übrigens mal im Stream machen, wenn ihr wollt, ja.
Du isolierst das Kabel ab
und dann legst du das auf und klappst das einfach zu
und es ist dicht und fest, das ist wirklich Poggers.
Okay, kommt da noch irgendwas Spannendes?
Nope, nope.
Ein Entfernungsmesser oder so?
Übrigens mal wieder so ein Beispiel, für warum es sich nicht lohnt,
billiges China-Kram zu kaufen.
Ich habe mir vor einer Weile so ein China-Entfernungsmesser gekauft.
Wisst ihr ja, wo man da so ein Laser rausschalten,
der das dann anzeigt, wie weit das weg ist.
Und ich habe jetzt mal gemessen, vom Boden bis zum Anfang,
ich wollte wissen, wie hoch es zum Dach ist.
Habe ich dann gemessen, dass es so weit weg ist.
Und dann habe ich mir gedacht, das ist doch nicht so weit weg.
Das ist doch nicht so weit weg.
Habe ich das Ding genommen,
habe es auf die Erde gelegt, habe es ans Dach geleuchtet
und habe gemessen, da kommt dann irgendwie was raus,
keine Ahnung, sieben Meter oder so.
Und dann habe ich noch, ich habe gedacht, okay,
ich messe jetzt noch ein paar Mal
und ich habe, also ich habe wirklich das Gerät,
also ich habe mir wirklich Mühe gegeben,
das Gerät nicht zu bewegen.
Ich habe es an die Wand gelegt, habe es hoch gemacht,
so, Knopf gedrückt und es kam zwischen 6,50 Meter und 7,20 Meter oder so raus.
Obwohl es die gleiche Stelle war.
Also, China-Chinesen-Zeug, kannst du vergessen.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, also ich weiß, es ist ungefähr sieben Meter hoch,
mein Dach, ja, ungefähr an der Stelle, ungefähr sieben Meter.
Aber ist es jetzt 6,50 oder 7,20, man weiß es nicht.
Das China-Ding von Xiaomi, ah, das habe ich nicht.
Ich habe so ein 14-Euro-Billy-China-Ding.
Ja, blablabla, was hatte ich hier?
Ja, Cyberpower habe ich auch eine USV und das ist die, die kaputt gegangen ist.
Kaufe ich mir nicht mehr.
Excellent, okay, next.
Next.
Wir gucken uns jetzt noch mal 9 Minuten Battlefield 2042 Top Plays an.
Da habe ich jetzt Bock drauf.
Attack.
Das Game ist so broken.
Oh, oh, das ist aber nice.
Dazu, dazu kann man eigentlich nur sagen,
hey, das war echt cool.
Welcome to another episode of Only in Battlefield 2042.
This is the second episode that we've done.
It's covering all the other clips that I...
Ich mache den absichtlich nicht so laut, weil ich eh permanent dazwischenrein labere.
...over the course of that beta.
Let's start out with some of my favorite...
Nee, Level-Cap war heute noch nicht.
Bam.
Oh, das war auch ein nicer Snipe.
Kommt er noch rein? Kommt er noch rein?
Er müsste noch reinkommen, wollte ich gerade sagen, weil das Flugzeug geht ja runter.
Oh Gott.
Moment.
Der hat nen Bot gekillt.
Ich hasse es.
Warum sind in diesem Spiel Bots, Mann?
Ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht.
Wahrscheinlich, es macht ehrlich gesagt bei diesem Kill,
macht es eigentlich kaum nen Unterschied.
Ganz im Ernst.
Das könnte auch genauso gut ein Spieler sein, den er umgeht.
Aber ich finde, es nimmt den kompletten Wert...
aus diesem Kill raus,
weil es ein Bot war am Ende.
Letztendlich macht es keinen Unterschied.
Es könnte auch genauso gut ein Spieler gewesen sein, der da unten rumeiert.
Das war eh lucky as fuck, dass der gehittet hat.
Aber es ist ein Bot.
WTF.
Richtig dumm.
Richtig hängengeblieben, dass es Bots gibt.
Halets.
Am Start.
Ich bin ja überrascht.
Oh.
Bam.
Und jetzt...
Ziehen, ziehen, ziehen.
Okay, der hat keinen Bock.
Ich bin ja überrascht, in wieviel schlechter Quali es die Leute haben, wenn wir am PC aufziehen.
Zack, Headshot.
Wusste ich.
War klar.
Sonst hätten sie es nicht gezeigt.
Und jetzt noch in den Chat.
Jetzt in den Chat reinspringen.
Spring in den Chat rein, Alter.
Jawoll.
Oh, girls.
Richtig nice.
Easy.
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
Okay, okay.
Oh, oh.
Ich dachte, hinter der jetzt noch.
Schreckt.
Die Gegner machen da gar nichts.
Oh, lol.
Oh, lol, lol.
Oh, da werden sie weggesprayt.
Auf der einen Seite registrieren die Hits teilweise nicht in Battlefield 2042 und diese Movement-Pattern der Gegner sind sehr abgehackt. Das kann man schlecht prädikten.
Übrigens, irgendwas richtig gemacht müssen die mit dem Game haben. Ich habe es ja relativ geflamed und ich hätte jetzt aber trotzdem Bock gehabt noch ein paar Runden zu spielen. Also ich freue mich trotzdem aufs Release.
Und ich werde zu Release ein bisschen Sellout machen. Habe ich schon mit EA besprochen. Ich mache ein paar Sponsored Videos zu Release. Muss ja mal wenigstens ein bisschen was mit verdienen, wenn man schon die Gelegenheit hat.
Aber es sind wahrscheinlich ganz normale Videos, die ich auch so machen würde. Deswegen habe ich gesagt, mache ich. Weil ich mache eh Videos dazu.
Oh, nice. Jetzt registrieren alle Hits. Nice, der war gut. Das Release ist in drei Wochen oder so. 19. glaube ich, oder?
Und für Early Access oder für Pre-Order noch früher? Wann ist 12. oder? 12. kann das sein?
Also guck mal, es sind noch, es sind 1, 2, drei Wochen sind es noch.ón halb Wochen, dann ist Release.
Naja, es kelt
Deswegen kriege ich ja auch kein Geld, wenn ich keine mache.
Ah, das ist eine Drohne. Ich wollte gerade sagen.. Hä. Häh? Langsame Rakete. nice. Leute, ich wusste das schon Mal. what has any d d drie s
dabei gedacht
Es gibt nen koreanischen Open in Südkoreanischen Unidos.
Wie adressiert?
Das ist soisch Rei, richtig mistakes.
einen südkoreanischen Operator,
der hat so eine Brille auf und das sieht
maximal hässlich aus, wie es
auf dem Kopf ist. Guckt euch das mal an!
WTF?
Dice! Please!
Warum sieht das
so scheiße aus?
Das ist eine Brille, die kann man runterklappen,
aber das sieht so dermaßen dämlich
aus mit diesem Ding auf dem Kopf.
Und mal ganz davon
abgesehen, ist euch mal aufgefallen,
wie low-quality diese ganzen
Models sind? Guckt euch mal die Backen an!
Die Backen sind total eckig!
Es wären bloß noch 5 Polygone übrig gewesen.
In zweieinhalb Wochen
kommt das Game raus.
Das kennen wir ja!
Nate und 85 Milliarden Kills.
Das ist ja auch der Selbstmord-Tunnel.
Da geht man ja auch nicht rein.
Zumal man ja auch nicht mal einen Granaten-Indikator hat,
der angeblich jetzt eingebaut wurde.
Pssst!
Oh! Bam!
Nice! Ich würde sagen,
2042 ist das schwierigste Game,
ähm,
Luft-Dinger abzuschießen,
weil das noch von der Skalierung her
größer ist. Am einfachsten
gehen wir mal davon aus, es gäbe
einen AT-4, ja?
AT-4 in Bad Company 2 am einfachsten,
weil Bad Company 2 alles relativ groß,
langsam und big ist, ja?
Nächstes Battlefield 3,
Battlefield 4, da ist alles schon deutlich
kleiner, schneller und auch von der Skalierung
her größer. Aber Battlefield 2042,
damit war es auch abzuschießen,
ist wirklich schwierig.
Die Entfernungen und alles
sind viel, viel größer.
Hast du das Beta-Resümee gelesen?
Ja, ja. Hab ich.
Nicht schlecht!
Moin, der hat den headshottet im Jet.
Alles klar.
Oh, und jetzt,
pass auf, bam!
Das ist nice. Also, das haben sie gut
hingeschafft. Also, Headshot,
Headshot-Feeling und so ist wirklich nice,
wenn du da eintrittst mit dem Bling.
Oh!
Bro, get turned, man!
What?
Oh, oh, oh!
Okay, komm, Bratz!
Oh!
Mami, get the camera!
What an awesome clip from Savon Jenkie.
One of the best sniping feeds I've seen.
Naja, gut. Das ist, hey, cooler Clip ist es,
aber ich meine, die haben sich nicht bewegt
und nicht in seine Richtung geguckt.
Also, das hätten wahrscheinlich andere
Spieler auch genauso gut hinbekommen.
Aber trotzdem.
Das muss wahnsinnig viel Glück dabei sein.
Das kann man nicht sagen.
Erfahrung mit MikroTik-Access-Points.
Nein, würde ich mir auch nicht kaufen.
Die haben, glaube ich, immer noch keine gescheiten 5 GHz-Access-Points.
Also, WiFi 5 Access-Points haben die, glaube ich, keine gescheiten.
Und jetzt ist ja schon WiFi 6, 6e in den Startlöchern.
Ja, das wollte ich mir schon immer.
Ich wollte...
Sag mal.
Leute, Sekunde, Sekunde.
Ist das denn WordArt?
Ich habe lange keine WordArts mehr gesehen, aber...
Das sieht krass nach WordArt aus.
Das ist doch ein WordArt.
Das sieht original aus wie ein WordArt.
Falls das einer nicht mehr kennt.
WordArt, genau.
Guck doch mal.
Das sieht mega aus wie WordArt.
Ja.
Trouble-Free-Experience.
Ja, für...
Man weiß ich, wie viel Geld.
Man sieht nix.
Man sieht einfach nix.
Man sieht...
Guck mal, die Skalierung in dem Game ist so fucking groß.
Das kann mir doch keiner erzählen, dass das großartig calculated war.
Ja.
Da sind auch ein paar Back-to-Backs in hier.
Ich meine, er wollte den vielleicht hitten, aber...
Nicht mal da bin ich mir sicher.
Es ist in dem Spiel aber auch schwieriger als in anderen Games.
Einfach weil, wie gesagt, die Entfernung und die Skalierung ist alles viel kleiner dadurch.
Äh, größer, größer.
Oh, bam.
Boah, guck.
Wie er einfach ein Auto voller Bots gekillt hat.
Und das ist übrigens ein Bug, dass sechs Kills angezeigt werden,
obwohl es bloß drei waren.
Easy.
Eats.
Kann man das?
Eats AF.
Das sind coole...
Das ist jetzt nice, dass er den gehittet hat.
Das war jetzt auch predicted und gekonnt und absichtlich, ja.
Der Name ist so feldschirm.
Many the many will.
Oh.
Was zum...
Ist das ein Controller?
Okay, das war einfach nur in die Richtung geschossen und er ist reingeflogen.
Okay, wir haben Tank Clips gleich geschafft.
Oder?
Ja, 20 Sekunden.
Schreckt, Alter.
Ja, ja.
Das stimmt schon, da findet man immer...
Oh.
Ah, voll.
Das ist halt auch dumm.
Das ist spawnen so random alles um dich drum.
Also das Spawn-System ist wirklich echt fucked.
I get fucked up in the ass over here.
Ich probier jetzt mal den Battlefield 3-Soldat zu...
Strom-Soldat zu zitieren.
Oh.
Nice.
Also der Headshot-Sound und alles, das haben sie schon gut hingekriegt.
Hatten sie ja, glaube ich...
Der Typ wieder.
Der macht nichts anderes.
Dieser Big E.
Der macht auch den ganzen Tag Battlefield.
Wie drei Caspian Border steht er am Ende der Map und guckt irgendwie auf die einzelnen Pixel und snipet dann irgendwie zwei Leute pro Game.
Und jetzt ans Seil dran.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Wow, nice.
Also der Headshot-Sound ist schon gut.
Der ist ähnlich zu Battlefield 5, oder?
Da macht's ja auch so ein Pling.
Wadda-Dings-Bums.
60%.
10 Monate eigentlich für den Sub.
Trickshot-Montage aus MW2.
Ja, naja.
Da müsstest du jetzt erstmal Ladder-Jump, Claymore-Switch, Swiffer-Scope machen.
Ja, calculated.
Ist klar.
Natürlich.
Predicted.
Ja, ist natürlich.
Natürlich.
Alles klar.
Kofax 10 Monate.
Danke für den Sub.
Danke.
Alter, wie immer einer abgeht bei.
Oh, oh, nice.
Oh, noch der Heli hinten rauf.
Komm, gib ihm.
Ja, Heli.
Stell's.
Bam.
Pock.
Jetzt ist er aber am Eskalieren hier.
Ist das alles Skill oder Massive Luck?
Naja.
Ich glaube, es ist schon Predicted zum größten Teil.
Also sie wollen den schon treffen.
Aber.
Aber es ist auch viel Glück dabei, also du, du musst vielleicht 50 mal in so eine Situation
kommen, dass es dann auch klappt, gerade in dem Game, wo Shots nicht hinten, obwohl sie
hinten sollten und so.
Den checken wir, den checken wir jetzt nicht out.
Max hätte das hier einreichen sollen.
Das ist bestimmt irgendwas, wo ich einfach runterfalle, ohne dass was passiert, oder?
Da ist er.
Pass mal auf.
Vielleicht geht es.
Pass auf, der trifft, der trifft.
Jawoll.
In your face, man.
Ich glaube, das geht nicht als Top.
Ich glaube, das geht nicht als Topplay durch.
Ich meine, ich werfe halt eine Granate hoch und er stirbt dran.
Richtig in your face, Alter.
In your face.
Man muss sagen.
Da ist er.
Die, die Granate ist schon ein schlecht gewesen, oder?
Guckt es euch mal an.
Hier.
Pass auf, der trifft.
Der trifft.
Die ist sogar noch gebounced da oben dran.
Die ist, die ist, die ist hier an den Balken und dann runter, das war eigentlich die perfekte
Granate.
Jawoll.
Ich könnte das tatsächlich einschicken.
Ich glaube, wenn Deutsche, wenn, wenn, wenn Deutsche quasi commentaten, das mögen die
Amis.
Da sagt er, nice reaction oder sowas.
Oh, wir können uns noch eine Runde Battlefield 3 Topplays angucken.
Aber wir können uns noch eine Runde Battlefield 3 Topplays angucken.
Aber wir gucken uns erst mal was anderes an.
GG Eats.
Moin.
Holz 0815.
Wir refreshen nochmal.
Vielleicht schlägt uns YouTube was Gescheites vor.
Höcke bricht Interview ab.
Nein, das gucken wir uns jetzt ganz bestimmt nicht an.
Rack Building.
Okay, nochmal ganz schnell drüber geskippt.
Ich finde diese Videos immer richtig interessant.
First Steps of our 10 Gigabit Fiber Network.
Okay, auf geht's.
Welcome to the server room.
Was ist das für ein Intro?
Welcom to the server room.
Was ist das für ein Sound am Anfang?
WTF?
Was ist das?
Ich wüsste gar nicht, wie ich den Audio machen soll.
Welcom to the server...
Warum steht da einen Sattel ? Na ja, Kekona halt.
Der geht wahrscheinlich danach irgendwie auf die Farm oder so.
Ew.
Also, ich habe falsch E-Mode eingeblendet.
Ist es Garage oder ist es Garage?
Ich habe jetzt schon irgendwie verschiedene Aussprachen davon gehört.
Garage?
Ich glaube, das ist wahrscheinlich davon, je nachdem, wo du daherkommst.
Okay, auch wieder 50 Milliarden Dinger vom Ast.
Der Ast.
Kann mal einer Kokona erklären?
Nee, nee, das hat nicht mit Corona zu tun.
Kokona ist dieses Ami-E-Mode hier.
Das da.
Das ist halt so der typische Stereotyp Ami.
Und das E-Mode heißt halt Kokona.
Alter, was geht mit dem Typ ab?
Der hat ja überall...
Der hat ja überall mit seinem Label-Drucker draufgelabelt.
SW1, SW2.
Gut, wenigstens einer, der keine Cringe-Emo-Namen draufmacht.
Ich meine, Dark Fate, Alter, was war denn das für ein Name?
FW2, SW1, SW2.
Okay, eins würde ich noch machen.
SW ist eine dumme Abkürzung.
SW könnte für Switch oder für Switch stehen.
Also, wisst ihr, wie ich meine?
Chat, hat das irgendjemand verstanden, was ich jetzt gerade gesagt habe?
Ich glaube nicht, oder?
Das war, glaube ich, zu pepege.
Aber vielleicht gibt es ja...
Ihr kennt mich mittlerweile, vielleicht versteht ihr, was ich meine.
Also, ich meine damit, es könnte für den Schalter hier stehen
oder halt für das Netzwerkgerät Switch.
Ja.
Deswegen finde ich Switch, SW, eine vielleicht dumme Abkürzung,
weil du weißt nie, ob es quasi eine Remote-Steckdose ist
oder der Switch,
oder ob das die Remote-Steckdose für den Switch ist oder sowas.
Das ist eine unglückliche Abkürzung, finde ich.
TP-Link, jawoll.
High-End-China-Chinesen-Zeug.
Aber das ist wirklich ein realistisches Ding.
Man sieht sofort, dass sich das über ein paar Jahre angebaut hat.
DS-LPT-Disk.
Aber sind wir irgendwie in Zeiten von DOS, wo man alles abgucken muss?
Servers, Bedroom.
Aber der mag sein Labelgerät, definitiv.
That big bunch of purple cables, the newer stuff is,
because we've got a shit-ton bunch of servers.
Wie findest du Dr. Racket?
Was ist denn das?
Sagt mir gar nichts.
Was ist das?
Racket ist eine Multiparadigme.
Lisp.
Monka S.
Will man wirklich Lisp als Einstieg machen?
Boah, Klammer.
Oh Gott, Lisp.
Also nur Erlang hat noch mehr Klammern.
Nur Erlang hat noch mehr Klammern.
Warum um alles in der Welt gibt man sich sowas wie Lisp?
Lisp ist so...
Nur Erlang hat noch mehr Klammern.
Guck mal.
Das ist kein gutes Beispiel.
Ja, guck mal.
Nur Erlang hat noch mehr Klammern.
Aber ansonsten...
Aber ansonsten ist Lisp, was Klammern angeht, schon der Wahnsinn.
Warum macht man das eigentlich heutzutage?
Also was ist der Sinn davon?
Und Racket ist, glaube ich, was relativ Neues.
Aber...
Also ich weiß nicht.
Ich mag die ganze Lisp-Syntax mit diesen 30 Milliarden Klammern nicht.
Ich habe ja noch eine Weile ein bisschen Emacs verwendet.
Da musstest du ja auch vieles in Emacs-Lisp machen.
Das sieht dann so ähnlich aus.
Und das ist halt eklig.
Wollt ihr mal richtig...
Wollt ihr mal was richtig Hässliches sehen, Source-Code-technisch?
Passt mal auf.
Ich mache mal random irgendwas auf.
What the hell?
Das kann doch nicht den Ernst sein, oder?
Das ist so...
Wer hat sich gedacht, das ist eine gute Idee?
Und am Ende...
Am Ende, Klammer zu, Klammer zu, Klammer zu...
Zehn Klammern hintereinander, ja?
Das ist echt so.
Ich meine...
What the hell?
Wer dachte sich, das ist eine gute Idee?
Wer dachte wirklich, das ist eine gute Idee?
Das ist doch...
Das ist doch das Schlimmste, was...
Eieiei.
Oh, das ist doch schöner.
Lisp-Code, ja?
Nee, nee, nee.
Also, der Mark...
17!
Hat er gar nicht 17 Servers?
Was macht der denn damit alles?
Business.
Wir machen weder Lisp noch Kobol an Silvester oder Weihnachten.
Also das ist so ein typisches Setup.
Wenn da irgendwann mal was kaputt geht,
hat keiner wieder einen Plan von, wie man das wieder
zu Gang bringt.
Ansonsten muss man sagen,
ist das Rack nicht verkehrt, ne?
Also wenn er hier drüber
scrollt, ist doch durchaus in Ordnung.
Warum ist da...
Aber ansonsten kannst du
das halt mit der Zeit gewachsenes
Rack, das ist ja in Ordnung.
Spoda!
Spodamon!
Die Ami-Stecker.
Immer wenn ich die sehe...
Ist euch mal aufgefallen, dass
die Ami-Steckdose
wie so ein Zed-Smiley
aussieht?
Also als wäre er traurig irgendwie.
Na gut.
Okay, genug.
Zack.
New useful
Smart Home Gear. Gratis.
Laptop. Was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Philips Hue. Was will Portal
in... Ah!
Wir lassen uns von Levelcap-Matschi-Baden
kurz ne Runde.
Ja, nachdem sie alles, was auf Github
an Fan-Projekten war, niedergestrikt
haben.
Sony made a big God of War
announcement and much more.
Kommt übrigens jetzt auf den PC, God of War.
Kann er endlich auch spielen.
Ich meine, ich hab ne PS4, aber ich hab
keinen Bock, PS4 zu spielen.
... Blogpost recapping all the
beta feedback that they got and all of the
updates that they've made to the game since
the beta build was branched back in
August, which looked fantastic.
DICE made several videos highlighting these
improvements and across the board players
are generally pleased with the changes.
There are some lingering concerns about performance
and missing features that might not be
ready for launch, but where the
public perception really took a turn for the worse
was the reveal of the
remaining five specialists. Each
one has some sort of element to their
kit that just doesn't sit well with the
community. Sundance's wingsuit looks
dope, but she also has a homing grenade
that took out a helicopter.
Ja, das hab ich auch, pass mal,
das müssen wir uns gleich angucken. Also
die revealten Specialists hab ich auch
so meine, meine
teilweise größeren Zweifel, wie
sinnvoll das im Battlefield
funktioniert, ja.
... that looks like it could be overpowered.
Dozer has a riot shield, which has
generally been a pretty unpopular pick
in previous Battlefield games.
Ist es wahrscheinlich jetzt auch.
... that are going to clearly be useful,
but also gives everyone armor when he
revives them, which could mess up the
standardized team of the player code.
Was war übrigens bei den Specialists,
das will ich Ihnen jetzt nicht vorwerfen, ja, aber was man
bei den Specialists diesmal wieder richtig schön
sieht, ist halt der aktuelle Zeitgeist.
Also, ich wette
mit dir, die haben mindestens einen
Diversity-Experten mit dabei,
wenn es darum geht, die Specialists zu erstellen.
Dass da alles
schön abwechslungsreich,
möglichst Shitstorm-frei
repräsentiert wird.
Garantiert, ich wette ich mit euch,
dass sie da mindestens ein, zwei Leute
dabei sitzen haben, die genau auf sowas achten, weil
ihr wisst, wie einfach das ist, ja.
Mal irgendwie den Knopf
an der falschen Seite gemacht, schon ist der
Twitter-Shitstorm wieder angesagt.
Das fand ich übrigens cool, mit dem
wir reinfliegen. Es wird zwar
in echt kaum vorkommen, aber
das war wirklich die coole, coole, coole, coole.
Und mal ganz davon
abgesehen, ich verstehe den Sinn von
dem Wing-Suit nicht wirklich,
wenn ich ehrlich bin, weil man kann
einfach Webster nehmen und
sich grappeln,
ähnlich zu dem, wie sie es gemacht hat
und vorher halt mit dem Fallschirm fliegen.
Man macht den Fallschirm auf,
macht ihn wieder weg, geht runter,
macht auf, Grappling-Hook und macht wieder weg.
Also du kannst ähnliches Movement und Grappler mit dem
Grappling-Hook auch machen, nur dass es halt deutlich universeller
ist. Ja, und jetzt
kommt das, was mich
auch ein bisschen
fragwürdig
gestimmt hat. Es gibt jetzt
Granaten, die
wie eine Rakete in ein Heli
killen. Guckt euch das mal an, Clay.
Guck mal.
What the fuck?
Was ist das?
Eine Zielsuchgranate.
Ernsthaft? Seriously?
Oh, das sieht so kacke aus.
Diese Brille sieht so dumm aus.
Ich finde das mit den...
Jetzt muss ich mal was sagen.
Ich finde das mit den Specialists
an sich
nicht schlimm.
Was? Die Augen...
Die Auswirkungen, die das hat, die werden nicht richtig
angegangen, ja? Zum Beispiel bräuchten...
müssten die Specialists zumindest von Team
zu Team unterschiedliche Skins
beziehungsweise klar in
Teams einteilbar sein
von der Optik her. Bisher sehen die halt auf
beiden Seiten gleich aus. Das ist dumm.
Das darf nicht so sein. So, wenn das
gegeben wäre, hätte ich wenig Schmerzen
mit den Specialists. Ich verstehe
den Vorteil von Specialists schon.
Das ist einfach eine bessere
Monetarisierungsmöglichkeit für EA.
Und dass das Spiel langlebig ist,
können sich ja im Prinzip auch nur die Spieler
wünschen, wenn sie das gerne
spielen.
Und
ansonsten kannst du ja
gar nicht sagen, dass es so weit weg ist.
Die Specialists können ja immer noch die
klassischen Kids auswählen, haben aber Sonderfähigkeiten.
Was ziemlich dumm ist, ist, dass
Specialists einfach
Must-Haves sind. So was wie
Webster.
Webster ist halt einfach so...
Also wenn der Grappling-Hook so bleibt, wie es
jetzt ist, ist es einfach das OP-ste, was es gibt.
Ich meine, klar, jeder Specialist hatte
irgendwelche OP-Geschichten, ja?
Mit Maria Falk konntest du dich
selbst medipacken, also mit der Pistole,
sodass du fast nicht richtig killbar
warst. Aber die Mobility
von Webster, dass du
auf Plätze wie Dächer kommst, wo sonst
niemand hinkommt, da sind ja meistens noch nicht mal
Leitern hoch, das ist einfach
OP as fuck. Machst nix?
Guck mal,
Boomer-Spieler wie ich, 30, 40
Kills die Runde. Easy.
Ohne großartig was zu machen.
Also, sagt schon alles.
Es sollte nur ein
Spesserlicht-Po-Squad sein, ja, dann meckern die Leute
herum, wer ein Specialist werden darf.
Nee, an sich finde ich das mit den Specialists gar nicht
schlimm, aber so ein paar
Sachen wie die Visibility, da muss
was dran gemacht werden.
Das Wiederbeleben ist auch zu langsam.
Rockstar revealed
footage of their upcoming GTA
Classic Trilogy Remasters
and they're pretty impressive looking.
Visually, the more cartoony, low-poly
aesthetic of the original game has been preserved.
Was wird in sich
Scharpfels CQRS
eingesetzt? Oh, da hab ich mich noch nie mit
großartig beschäftigt.
Irgendwelche Message-Queue-Geschichten.
Also, ich weiß, dass RapidMQ relativ
überliebt war eine Zeit lang,
aber ansonsten...
Kafka ist so eine Wissenschaft für sich,
was Message-Queues angeht, keine Ahnung.
Im Zweifelsfall
Azure-Dings-Bus. Ich weiß nicht,
wie heißt das? Azure-Event-Bus?
Oder wie heißt dieses Ding
von Azure? Das ist wahrscheinlich bei Microsoft
Leuten immer sehr beliebt.
But the textures and model detail
have been overhauled with a cleaner look.
And in hindsight, the original Grand Theft Auto
games did look pretty cartoonish.
Still, it's tough to say how much of that
original look was intentional versus
the result of compromises made
because of technical limitations.
The remasters are a giant
leap regardless and go quite far
beyond what some players might have been expecting.
Rockstar re-released the
classic GTA games on new
platforms over the years, and most of the time
the graphics have stayed the same, while
things like resolution and frame rates
got a bump. But for a long time, the modding
was where all the big leaps in fidelity
actually were coming from.
Rockstar's official remasters take things
a lot further than their past re-releases
without... Ich bin ja aber auch jemand, der es
GTA ausspricht. Ich kunde...
Leute, das ist natürlich... GTA!
...transformieren die Spiele wie die Mods.
Die Remaster-Kollektion startet
am 11. November.
Die Remasterung von GTA San Andreas
wird auch am 1. Tag
auf dem Xbox Game Pass geöffnet.
Vice City und Grand Theft Auto 3
werden in Bundles mit San Andreas
für Konsole und PC eingestellt.
Der totale Paket ist 70 Dollar.
2018's God of War
kommt auf PC
im Januar 2014.
Das ist schon wieder ein drei Jahre altes Game, ja?
Es ist eines der am meisten gefeiertsten Spiele
in der Franchise. Guck mal!
Guck mal, wie seine Hand
einfach so groß ist wie der Kopf
vom Boy.
God of War on PC will support
4K native output, enhanced
graphics options and an unlocked
framerate. The biggest tech upgrades
are of course Nvidia's DLSS
and their reflex low-latency
options. Microsoft and AMD
finally released fixes for a Windows
11 bug that slowed down Ryzen's
CPUs by up to 18%. Stimmt, da war ja was!
Da war ja was! ...compared to their performance
in Windows 10. Da war ja was.
Schade hab ich. The bug caused extreme caching latency, which slowed
down other critical tasks. Microsoft's
fix is currently available as
an optional Windows update. AMD
released a new chipset driver that is
that addresses another bug related to
which cores do this assigns to specific
tasks. These fixes combine
shipping, performance backup to
parity with Windows 10.
The launch trailer for Apex Legends
next season is Skate
packs a ton of info. We get a
cinematic look at a new tropical
map with hostile alien creatures roaming
around. The new legend, Ashe, has
some pretty interesting abilities like a sword,
tracker that potentially reveals
enemy locations and a portal
similar to Wraith's. We also get a
first look at the new car SMG
coming with the update. And despite
the somewhat rough state that Apex is
currently in thanks to server issues,
the reaction to the trailer has been overwhelmingly
positive. It's just the right
blend of cinematic storytelling,
lore, character development and useful
info. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass Apex so
viel lore hat. Das einzige was ich von
der Apex Story kenne ist, dass
es wohl im gleichen Universum wie Titanfall
spielt. Wie erklären die eigentlich in
Apex, dass es das Titanfall Universum
ist, aber keine Titans und sonst nichts?
Na egal.
Da bin ich mal gespannt. Ich bin wirklich
gespannt, ob
dieses Halo
diesmal ein bisschen länger
Bestand haben wird. Ich meine, Halo 3
auf der originalen Xbox
war ja mega beliebt.
Ja? Also Halo 3
war ja quasi neben Call of Duty damals
so das Ding. Die ganzen
MLG legit
Leute in ihrer MLG Playlist und
sowas. Aber danach
hat Halo nie wieder zu dieser Stärke
zurückgefunden.
... AMD to add the tech to the game, which is
a good sign for anyone that doesn't own
one of the Nvidia RTX GPUs.
AMD's ray tracing solutions
are platform agnostic,
so they should also run quite well on
Nvidia GPUs. There's no ETA
on when ray tracing will be added,
but Infinite launches on December 8th
for all platforms.
The RPC S3
PlayStation 3 Emulator just achieved
a major milestone.
Every PlayStation 3 game ever
made now boots successfully
in its latest update.
Ja, habe ich auch schon gesehen.
Habe ich letztens mal ein paar Videos
angeguckt. Problem ist halt,
dass die Games aktuell noch teilweise
Grafikglitches haben und halt
performance-technisch...
Ja, ne?
Übrigens, ich bin immer noch beeindruckt,
dass das überhaupt funktioniert. PS3 Emulator
habe ich noch vor nicht allzu langer Zeit
gesagt. Ich bin mal gespannt, ob wir
jemals einen PS3 Emulator
sehen werden.
Ich meine, PS3 zu emulieren
ist eines der schwierigsten Sachen überhaupt.
Also das
ist äußerst beeindruckend.
... progress towards a more accurate
and reliable emulator. In the future,
it's likely whatever fixes were made to
ensure that every game boots will evolve
to more and more games being easily
playable. Emulation is an
excellent way of preserving classic
games for future generations,
but the PlayStation 3 in particular
is very hard to emulate.
Ja, PS3
ist wirklich schwer.
Wieso ist das so schwierig? Weil die PS3
von der Architektur absolut nichts
mit dem gemein hat, wie so ein
Computer funktioniert aktuell.
Also allein schon die CPU-Architektur
ist komplett anders.
Also das
ist eigentlich, wenn man es so will,
ist die PS3 so die letzte
richtige Konsole gewesen
in dem...
ja, in so diesem Bereich. Ab der PS4
und der Xbox...
Xbox One ist das ja im Prinzip
eigentlich
nur ein ganz normaler x86
PC mit AMD Grafikkarte
und AMD CPU.
Die Xbox war ein Power-PC.
Die Xbox 360 war ein Power-PC.
Die PS3 wurde auch
bei IBM entwickelt von den gleichen Leuten,
die auch den Xbox, die Xbox-CPU
gemacht haben. Aber die hatten ja ihre komische
Cell-Architektur mit...
Oh, ich krieg das nicht mehr zusammen.
Was war das? Sechs Computer...
Computeinheiten und ein...
irgendwie Power-PC-Dings...
Ach, ich weiß es gar nicht mehr. Oder war es acht?
Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr genau.
Aber die hatte eine sehr
abgedrehte Architektur, die PS3.
Die PS3 war ja im Prinzip rein von der
Rechenleistung her doppelt so leistungsfähig
wie die Xbox 360, aber
bis auf wenige Hersteller, die vielleicht irgendwie
Naughty Dog mit Uncharted oder so, hat das
kaum einer richtig ausgenutzt.
Was für eine Grafikkarte-CPU
hast du? Ich hab ne 8700K
und ne 1008GE.
...
Was bin ich denn da überhaupt
sehend gerade?
...
Oh, der Patch aus der Hölle.
Ach, nochmal ein Sky.
So.
Ach, das gibt es gar nicht auf der Konsole aktuell.
Ich dachte, Among Us gibt es überall mittlerweile.
Ja, super.
Jetzt kommt es auf der Konsole raus.
Jetzt, wo es keinen mehr interessiert.
Habt ihr euch ja super Timing ausgedacht.
Mal gucken, wie viele Leute das jetzt noch spielen gerade.
Ja, niemand.
Ja, das ist natürlich jetzt nicht so clever gewesen.
Jetzt, wo es keine mehr haben will.
So, leave a comment with your top story
and be sure to subscribe so you don't miss any future news content.
Preloading for Forza Horizon 5 is live on PC and Xbox consoles.
The download weighs in at a hefty 100 gigabytes.
Current-gen console players and PC players using FastSS
can expect very snappy load times
since the game was optimized for the Xbox Series'
high-bandwidth storage system.
The game launches on November 5th
for Premium Edition owners
and November 9th for everyone else.
And that wraps it up for this week in gaming.
As always, guys, thank you so much for watching.
Forza könnt mich auch kaum weniger jucken.
Signing off.
Unglücklich, jetzt, wo es kein Mensch mehr interessiert.
Ja, und wichtig ist die CPU-Architektur.
Das Ding hat nur noch 15 Grafiker und nur noch 15 CPU.
Das reicht.
Damit sollte man Spiele relativ easy auf dem PC laufen zu...
Laufbar bekommen.
Was man ja auch daran sieht,
dass seit der letzten Konsolengeneration
viel, viel mehr Games auf dem PC rauskommen,
die früher konsolenexklusiv waren.
Guck mal.
No Man's...
Nicht No Man's Sky.
Dings hier.
DHL-Simulator.
Wie hieß es nochmal?
Nicht No Man's Sky, sondern...
Wie hieß denn der DHL-Simulator?
Death Stranding.
Ja, genau.
Und jetzt God of War und...
Ich kann mir die Game-Titel nicht mehr merken, Alter.
Wie hieß das mit Aloy und den Dinosauriern aus Metall...
Horizon Zero Dawn, genau.
Das kommt ja auch auf dem PC oder ist schon auf dem PC raus.
Also, das gab's...
Die Generation davor nicht.
Ja, richtig, richtig.
Boomer-Timer.
Wieso eben?
Das war doch der beste Beweis für...
Ich kann mir...
Ich kann mir Spieletitel nicht mehr merken.
Ja.
Also, das hätte es die Generation davor nicht gegeben.
Uncharted PC-Version.
Wenn es das mal irgendwann geben soll.
Aber ich glaube, da hat Sony keinen Bock drauf.
Ach, da?
Na, das ist ja...
Poggers.
Die würde ich tatsächlich noch mal spielen.
Das ist ja nice.
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich fand das erste Uncharted immer noch am besten.
Vielleicht, weil ich das erste Mal gespielt habe.
Vielleicht deswegen.
Keine Ahnung.
Erster Trailer.
Oh ja, den Trailer zum Uncharted-Film habe ich auch gesehen.
Ich finde...
Ich finde, ganz ehrlich...
Ich meine, es ist ein Sony-Produkt.
Ja, so wie Spodermann-Lizenz.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass Spodermann Nathan Drake spielt.
Das liegt bestimmt an...
Irgendwelchen Lizenz-Geschichten.
Sony hatte irgendwie Spodermann-Lizenz.
Er spielt Spodermann.
Vielleicht haben die da irgendwas gedreht und gemacht.
Keine Ahnung, ja.
Aber ich finde, Tom Holland sieht nicht aus wie Nathan Drake.
Und...
Das da soll Sully sein.
Also mal ganz im Ernst.
Da fehlt das Schnurrbart.
Auch wenn das früher spielt.
Da fehlt die Zigarette.
Nicht die Zigarette.
Die Zigarre und das Schnurrbart.
WTF.
Die sehen sich überhaupt bei absolut null ähnlich.
Ich weiß nicht.
Hat jemand von euch...
Diesen Uncharted-Fanfilm damals geguckt?
Fanmovie?
Hat jemand das hier mal zufällig geguckt?
Wir gucken uns das jetzt nicht an.
Aber guckt euch mal.
Den Typ, den sie da als Nathan Drake hatten,
der sieht dem mega ähnlich.
Wartet mal.
Hier.
Der sieht...
Sag doch mal.
Der sieht dem brutalst ähnlich, oder?
Also wenn...
Das ist original.
Also...
Das sieht aus 1 zu 1 wie der Typ ein paar Jahre älter aus dem Spiel.
Der sieht dem übertrieben ähnlich.
Also das ist halt mal vom Cast her gefällt mir der Trailer überhaupt nicht.
Und der hat auch noch den gleichen Vornamen.
Naja.
Ich hab's doch gerade gezeigt.
Ja, ich glaube die scheißen auf Gamecanon gerade.
Kanon...
Ach, was weiß ich.
Ich glaube da filmen wir eh nix.
Es gibt...
Was gibt es für gute Spielverfilmungen?
Gibt es irgendwelche guten Spielverfilmungen?
Was sind gute Spielverfilmungen?
Das sind Screams.
Lul, Alter.
Assassin's Creed hätte durchaus Potenzial gehabt, aber die haben es auch verkackt.
Dungeon Seed.
Lul.
Dass sich da jemand dran erinnert.
Uwe Boll, Alter.
Far Cry.
Far Cry gab's auch.
Max Payne.
Naja, so gut fand ich Max Payne auch nicht.
Ähm...
Die Witcher-Serie.
Ganz ehrlich.
Die Witcher-Serie hatte echt so ihre Probleme, aber von den ganzen...
Naja, das ist aber keine Spielumsetzung eigentlich.
Es ist...
Es hat beides die gleiche Vorlage vielleicht.
Der Warcraft-Film war...
Ansatzweise brauchbar, ja.
Der erste Tomb Raider-Film.
Der war tatsächlich ganz okay, fand ich, den ersten, ja.
Slenderman.
Dazu gab's den Film.
Wirklich?
Will ich das wissen und nachgucken?
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Äh, naja.
Wo ist der Detektiv Pikachu?
Weiß ich nicht, hab ich nicht geguckt.
Naja, aber...
Es gibt...
Es gibt auf jeden Fall nicht viele.
Der Final Fantasy-Film.
Gut, es ist ja keine Spielumsetzung.
Das ist ja...
War ja quasi...
Äh...
Einfach nur der Name.
Der war aber wirklich ganz okay.
Noch dunkel dran erinnern.
Naja.
Was können wir uns sonst jetzt noch hier angucken?
Sehen wir mal.
Bill King.
New Useful Smart Home Gear.
Ja, das ist das Richtige für mich.
Das ist ein lustiges Emote.
Ich glaub, das mach ich rein.
Chat, was sagt ihr zu dem Emote?
Ups.
What the fuck?
Chandler hatte immer gute Emote-Vorschläge.
Yep, cock.
Das mach ich mal rein.
Wartet mal.
Add, add channel.
So, ist drinne.
Yep, cock.
Muss die Musik ausmachen.
Und kann in euer Zuhause gebracht werden, um euch mehr Zeit in eurer Leben zu erlangen.
Und für mich ist Smart Home um mehr Zeit zu erlangen und sogar Geld zu erlangen in einigen Situationen.
Aber einer der...
Also, dass man da irgendwie großartig Zeit spart...
Spart halte ich für ein Gerücht.
Man steckt so viel Zeit rein, das aufzubauen, zu konfigurieren.
Das ist hauptsächlich Spaß da dran.
Und Spaß da dran, wenn es dann am Ende funktioniert und einem das Leben leichter macht.
Aber unterm Strich glaube ich, dass du ganz schön lange Zeit brauchst, dass die Zeit, die du da reingesteckt hast, um das aufzubauen, wieder rausbekommst.
Da, naja.
Ja.
Ja, Voice Assistants sag'n' ja auch.
Moment.
Ist das ein Sellout-Video, einfach nur gut verpackt?
Ist das ein Sellout-Video?
Es ist nicht einfach nur ein Knopf.
Nein, es ist ein drehbarer Knopf.
Never seen before.
Ein drehbarer Knopf.
Übrigens ist die Idee mit einem rotierbarer Knopf
überangebunden über ZigBee und so ist es tatsächlich gut,
weil oftmals hast du ja die Sache,
du willst nicht nur einen Input machen.
Also ich habe ja auch so einen Schalter.
Ich habe hier zum Beispiel so einen ZigBee, so einen Teil.
Und da kannst du total viel mit abbilden.
Du kannst Single Press machen.
Du hast sechs verschiedene Buttons,
für Single Press.
Du kannst Single Press machen, Double Press, Triple Press,
Hold.
Also du kannst allein schon pro Button
vier verschiedene Funktionen abbilden.
Aber trotzdem muss man sagen,
damit jetzt beispielsweise so eine dimmbare Lampe zu steuern,
ist nicht so schön.
Ich meine klar, du könntest sagen,
an, niedrigster Stufe, nächste Stufe sowieso.
Aber da ist sowas zum Drehen schon nicht verkehrt.
Well, and even music.
Double Hold.
Ja, das ist jetzt nächste Mode.
Wie auch immer, wann entscheidet man, wann das zweite Hold anfängt.
... six services.
So this is going to get really wild.
And when we saw what Flick could do with just a button,
I'm really excited for how useful Flick Twist is going to be.
Ich glaube, das ist jetzt das war der Sellout.
Das war der Sellout.
Der Sellout ist jetzt vorbei.
Smart Home products are pretty good at keeping you from having to touch a lot of surfaces in your home.
And while that's great, one of the other things you can do is to just simply wash your hands.
So das ist übrigens so die gleiche Kamera, die ich auch im Flur habe.
Die habe ich mir mal in einem Fünferpack oder so bei Amazon.com bestellt,
dass ich das gelohnt habe.
Die neuen kann man leider nicht mehr custom flashen und deswegen bin los.
... wash your hands.
But you've got to do it right.
And to be honest, as I've been watching my child over the last few years,
he doesn't always do a great job.
Ist das ein Mass Effect?
Ist das ein Mass Effect T-Shirt?
... the price tag of the Amazon Soap Dispenser sometimes or...
Was?
... most of the time is going to exceed its usefulness.
... it's been pretty useful here at making sure that my kids...
Seriously?
... ...
... his hands for 20 seconds.
This is due to the visual display on the top of the soap dispenser and the fact that it pairs directly with Echo speakers
and automatically starts music and turns off that music once the time period has passed.
...
I could add more to that routine if I did.
... I could add more to that routine if I did.
... and the soap dispenser itself puts out more soap if you're a little bit lower down,
The soap dispenser itself puts out more soap if you're a little bit lower down,
so its a pretty good little device.
So its a pretty good little device.
und ergonomischen Eindruck muss ich sagen.
...
naja.
Was ist denn, wenn dein Internet ausfällt?
조
Amazon Echo Products. Und wenn wir über diese Amazon Echo Products sprechen, dann ist das neue Echo Show 15
ziemlich nützlich in einigen Fällen. Die Möglichkeit, das Echo Show 15 auf der Wand zu montieren, wird...
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Ich mache mir garantiert kein Amazon Echo-Dings hier so an die Wand.
Ich habe ein Amazon Fire Tablet und das habe ich als Dashboard an der Wand, aber auch mit eigenen Sachen und nicht mit Amazon drauf.
It can dual purpose as both a smart home control interface as well as a electronic art frame.
This one will have a few extra features that make it a little bit better than some of the others.
And the first one is the smart home control widget.
Och doch, kein Mensch. Geh mal fort, kommt da noch irgendwas Gescheites.
Aber das ist nur Amazon Shit, oder?
Ja, es ist garmarson.
Was? Was?
Da fährt ernsthaft so ein Ding durch meine Wohnung mit einer Kamera und filmt alles.
Das kann sich dann Bezos angucken, wenn er ins Weltraum fliegt, oder was?
Ne, ne.
Also, was ist das?
Also, ihr wisst, ich bin sehr aufgeschlossen, was Smart Home Sachen angeht und ich bastel da seit Jahren dran rum.
Aber es gibt auch irgendwie Dinger, die muss ich mir nicht ins Haus stellen.
Verstehst du, die Leute, die ein iPad Pro an die Wand hängen, ist doch mega, weißt du?
Ne, verstehe ich nicht.
iPads eignen sich nicht wirklich als Home.
Home Automation Dashboards an der Wand.
Da sind Android-Geräte deutlich besser.
Gut, wenn man HomeKit...
Alter, jetzt habe ich aber hier gerade Pause gedrückt.
WTF?
Ähm, Monk, MonkHS, Alter.
Ähm, wenn man HomeKit verwendet vielleicht, ja.
Oh Mann, was ein Schwachsinn.
Seriously.
Wie, wer hat denn das Bier da reingestellt überhaupt?
Die Frau in der Küche, oder was?
Oh, wir sind ja diverse, sorry, vielleicht der Mann in der Küche.
Ähm, und bringen sie ihn jetzt aufs Sofa, ans Sofa.
Ach ne, Moment, die Frau.
Die Frau, ach sorry, falsch rum.
Die Frau sitzt auf dem Sofa und der Mann hat sie in der Küche reingestellt.
Ach so.
Debated.
Also, na ne, nicht wirklich.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, das Problem ist bei solchen Dingern,
das funktioniert ja nur in Wohnungen, die so aussehen, wie das, was sich Amazon denkt.
Ja?
Bei mir würde der beispielsweise schon sofort,
an irgendeinem USB-Kabel hängenbleiben, was irgendwo runterhängt, oder so.
Die haben immer so super geleckte, äh, stylische Wohnungen in diesen, in diesen Spots.
So wie kaum ne Wohnung in echt eben aussieht.
Ich mein, die hat sogar, da siehst du mal, wie komponiert dieser Shot wieder ist.
Die hat sogar Schuhe an, guck mal.
Die hat sogar Schuhe an, die farblich zu den Sachen da im Hintergrund passen.
... as the Echo Show 15 to give you alerts when someone should...
... can be there.
Earlier in the video I said that smart homes are pretty good at keeping you from having
to touch surfaces, and one of the best devices for that is a smart switch.
Which is exactly where the new Illumino Switch from Aeotech comes in.
Now, these are going to work...
Kekona Switch kriegst du bei uns so nicht an die Wand.
... with a number of smart homes...
Typischer Kekona Switch.
... and they have just two models with a switch and a dimmer version, and they do require
a neutral.
But after that...
... these are gonna work...
... work in almost every configuration or in every switch in your home.
So that design is great, and honestly, most of Aeotechs designs are really good, but there's
a bunch of reasons...
Sollen die barfuß?
Nee, einfach Socken.
Ich hab nie Hausschuhe an, ich nehm immer Socken an.
... that I really like the new Aeotech Water Sensor 7 Pro.
One of the places...
Pro!
Nicht einfach...
Das ist nicht einfach nur ein Water Sensor, das ist der Water Sensor.
Pro!
... as soon as I could...
Das ist übrigens, jetzt mal ganz im Ernst, das ist wirklich sinnvoll.
Ich hab auch im Keller, nee, sowas, was auch immer das hier ist, hab ich nicht.
Ich hab auch im Keller zwei Stück Leak Detection, weil einmal, als es richtig geregnet hat, hätte
davon ein Video machen sollen, ich hab davon, ich hab davon ein Video, das wüsste ich tatsächlich
mal raus, ich hab davon ein Video.
Ich hab mal...
... als es richtig, richtig krass geregnet hat, drauf.
Ja.
Also ich bin dann nach draußen, hab ich im Erdgeschoss gestanden und da war's ganz...
es war leise im Haus und ich dachte mir, irgendwie plätschert's im Keller.
Und da bin ich in den Keller runter und da ist aus dem Loch in der Wand einfach ein
Wasserstrahl rausgekommen.
Einfach so.
Loch in der Wand, da kam ein Wasserstrahl raus, so ungefähr so 30 Zentimeter in den
Raum rein.
Einfach ein Wasserstrahl aus dem Raum, aus der Wand.
Da war ein Loch in der Wand, da kam Wasserstrahl raus.
Aber das hat sich halt einfach gestaut draußen.
Wir haben, man muss dazu sagen,
vor dem Haus ist, ähm,
an dieser Ecke ist, ist aufgefüllt
mit so Kies.
Zu Kies aufgefüllt. Also da geht's ein bisschen
nach unten. Und das ist wahrscheinlich einfach
vollgelaufen, weil's so,
weil's so krass geregnet hat.
Und die Kellerwand war halt, ist halt schon alt,
da, ne, mal ganz dicht, da kam halt einfach
ein Wasserstrahl aus der Wand. So.
Und, äh, seitdem ich das mal hatte,
hab ich zwei Wasser-Leak-Detektor
aus Sensoren unten hingelegt.
Ja.
Was ist das?
Worüber schließt man den an?
Das müssen wir uns jetzt mal kurz angucken.
Das find ich tatsächlich ganz interessant.
Äh, wie heißt die?
Äh, Leak-Sensor.
Water-Leak-Sensor.
Naja, das ist der nicht.
Hat er das verlinktes Zeug?
Water-Sensor.
Okay, okay, ah, hier ist es doch.
Z-Wave, passt sogar.
Water-Sensor 7 Pro.
Blood-Sensor-Leak-Sensor-Safety-Sensor.
Custom-Firma, dafür braucht man keine Custom-Firma.
Das find ich tatsächlich, äh,
sehr, sehr sinnvoll, ja.
Post.
Das zeige ich ja.
Hier in 49.9, das geht sogar.
Das ist durchaus okay.
Hat Amazon das Teil mittlerweile?
Ha?
Ne, das ist, boah.
Gudokui.
China-Chinesen-Zeug.
Control your home.
Das ist bestimmt ne Kokona-Seite.
Bei Ebay.
Klasse Firma auf den Seifenspender.
Z-Wave, na, das passt bei mir.
Ich hab relativ viel Z-Wave am Start.
Ich glaub, den kauf ich mir.
Erkenn also...
F-F-F-F-F-Lek-Lek-A-Lekagen?
L-Lekage?
Lek...
Was ist denn, was ist denn ein Lekagen?
Gewichtsverlust durch Verdunsten oder Aussickern.
Lekage?
Wie spricht man das aus?
Lekage.
Lekage!
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass dieses Wort existiert.
Lekage.
Was sollten wir angucken?
Das Problem mit USB-C hat vorhin einer geschrieben.
Okay.
But why?
USB-C ist perfekt, sagt man ja auch.
USB.
ist weiter von entfernt perfekt zu sein, vor allem
das USB-Forum. Ich meine,
es ist ja die Frage, ob was wir meinen, USB
3.0, 3.1, 3.2
oder vielleicht sogar 3.2
Gen 1, Gen 2, 2x2
oder was auch immer, ja, das weiß man ja nicht so genau.
Wobei
3.0 und 3.1 gibt es ja nicht mehr.
Der Fibaro Fluid-Sensor
sieht besser aus, ja,
aber ich glaube, anwendungstechnisch ist das
EOTech-Ding besser.
What the fuck?
Laut der E-Kommission soll ab 2024
also heute in ziemlich genau zwei Jahren
die Ladeanschlüsse von Smartphones, Tablets, Kameras,
Spielekonsolen, die Portablen
und Lautsprecher komplett vereinheitlicht
werden, sprich, fast alles wird
per USB-C aufgeladen.
Und obwohl ich mich unfassbar darüber freue,
künftig... Na, Apple wird dann irgendwas anderes
machen. Einfach nicht noch ein extra Ladekabel
einpacken. Ich meine, Apple hat ja jetzt schon, ich glaube,
die Neuen haben ja schon USB-C, aber ich bin mir sicher,
Apple schafft es in den nächsten fünf Jahren,
was Eigenes zu machen.
... hat USB-C doch noch
so einige Probleme, von denen noch nicht jeder
Bescheid weiß.
Alter, das ist ja wieder so
typisches deutsches Influencer-Kram.
Da kriegst du ja Anfälle, das kannst du dir gar nicht in Ruhe
angucken.
Weshalb USB-C perfekt ist, aber eben auch
nicht.
Die sind aber so mega hektisch alle.
Also erstmal zu USB-C.
Was macht dieses Kabel, oder anders gesagt,
dieser Anschluss so perfekt und warum
sollte jedes Gerät
alle Anschlüsse rausschmeißen und nur noch USB-C
verwenden? Sollte es überhaupt
nicht.
Sollte nicht jedes Gerät USB-C verwenden.
Wozu?
Es ist dieser kleine, schicke Anschluss, der so
ziemlich alles kann. Mit diesem
Anschluss kann ich Daten in eine
enorme Geschwindigkeit übertragen.
Serielle Schnittstelle
beste.
Leute.
USB weg.
Ja und?
Das braucht kein...
Mit der Geschwindigkeit...
Teil ist er nun wirklich jetzt nicht das Ding.
USB-C, vor allem in Kombination halt auch mit
sagen wir mal Thunderbolt oder USB-4
ist
wirklich nice.
Also da sind wirklich viele coole
Dinger dabei. Ja, zum Beispiel
dass du da quasi
PCI-Express sogar drüber machen kannst
und sowas.
Ein USB-C Kabel kann enorm
viel Strom liefern mit bis zu
100 Watt. Und das funktioniert alles
parallel. Ich kann also mit...
100 Watt über USB-C. Was ist denn
das dann? Wie ist denn das?
5 Ampere, 20 Volt oder
was machen die?
Ich meine, mehr als 5 Ampere würde ich immer so diese kleinen
USB-Ederchen nicht drüber machen.
Wie setzen sich denn
die 100 Watt zusammen?
Sind das 20 Volt,
5 Ampere oder was?
Ah ja, hier 20 Volt, 5...
Ja, alles andere würde es auch keinen Sinn ergeben,
weil, ähm,
ich meine, ich hatte ja schon mal
die Ehre, vielleicht erinnert sich irgendjemand
an das Weihnachts-LED-Video
von vor
einem Jahr,
zwei Jahre.
Da haben wir ja über so einen 5, da hatten wir
5 Volt-LEDs und ich hatte
glaube ich einen 12 Ampere-Netzteil
dran.
Und dann haben wir
5 Volt, 12 Ampere gemacht über so
Jumper-Kabel. Und die
Jumper-Kabel haben tatsächlich mehr oder
weniger Monarch-Est im Street.
Also kurz davor, die waren kurz davor.
Die waren kurz davor.
Also lange hätte man das nicht betreiben
sollen. Also 12 Ampere
über diese kleinen Putzkabelchen, das waren
schon...
Sportlich,
sportlich auf jeden Fall.
Deswegen, und im USB ist es auch nicht so
sonderlich dicke Kabel drin.
... 10 Kabel in mein Macbook ans
Monitor anschließen, dort die ganzen Eingänge
nutzen, um zum Beispiel den Sound auf den Laussprecher zu
spielen, Daten zu übertragen auf einen externalen
Display, eine Festplatte...
Der Macbook ist ja schon mal das erste Problem.
Alle Peripherie-Geräte, die am Monitor angeschlossen
sind, nutzen wie zum Beispiel Maustastatur und Drucker.
Und währenddessen wird das Macbook
aufgeladen. Das passiert
alles gleichzeitig. Das ist schon nicht schlecht.
Das ist nicht der Hammer.
80% von euch wissen tatsächlich schon, was mit
dem Wunderkabel hier alles möglich ist.
Das liegt überhaupt nicht am Kabel, dass
das möglich ist.
Das Kabel ist da wirklich der kleinste Faktor bei.
Kommen wir zu dem Problem des
Warum ist Macbook das erste Problem?
Weil Apple seit einer Weile der Meinung
ist, keine Anschlüsse mehr an Macbooks
dran machen zu müssen.
Was jetzt?
Was zum...
Der größte Nachteil,
nämlich, dass dieser Anschluss komplett einheitlich
ist, sorgt nämlich für sein größtes Problem,
die unfassbare
Intransparenz. Ein USB-C Kabel
kann dir alles geben, aber eben auch
nichts. Das ganze teile ich in drei
Sachen. Das hat mit dem Kabel nichts zu tun.
Das liegt daran, dass das USB-
Forum und die Standardisierung einfach
komplett für ein Bobbes ist.
Ich hab dazu auch mal ein Video gemacht.
Bisschen, bisschen zu viel drüber rum gerantet.
Okay, vielleicht. Aber ich hab hier...
Ja, hier.
Hallo Jungs und Mädels.
USB 4 ist da und mein Hirn explodiert.
Da erklär ich das doch irgendwann zwischendurch.
Damit man versteht, warum USB 4...
Ich zitiere mich jetzt mal kurz selbst.
...zu Fake News. Der Kram
heißt offiziell nicht mehr so.
Den Namen von USB-Standards
oder USB-Spezifikationen
zu ändern. Ihr habt bestimmt
alle Mainboards, wo USB 3.0
oder USB 3.1 draufsteht.
Oder Festplatten, externe Geräte
mit USB 3.0.
Das Problem ist jetzt... Pass auf.
Jetzt kommt die Erklärung.
...an der Grenze zu Fake News.
Der Kram heißt offiziell nicht mehr so.
Ich finde es irgendwie eine bescheuerte Idee,
im Nachhinein seine Produkte umzubenennen.
Aber wie gesagt, das USB-Forum
macht das gerne. Und zuletzt im Juli 2019.
Das ist noch gar nicht so lange her.
Und das Ganze...
Thunderbolt ist nicht USB-C.
USB-C ist der Stecker.
Äh...
Thunderbolt ist
quasi USB von Intel.
Das Ganze. Nur grob.
Dass man es ungefähr nachvollziehen kann.
Es gibt sowas hier wie USB 3.2
Gen 1.
Generation 1.
Das ist der neue Name für das originale USB 3.
Also sprich, auch übrigens
genannt Superspeed USB.
Mit 5 Gigabit pro Sekunde.
Also sprich, wenn ihr eine USB 3.0 Festplatte habt
oder ein USB 3.0 Zubehör,
dann würde sich das jetzt neuerdings
USB 3.2 Gen 1 nennen.
Dann gibt es als nächstes,
das ist das ehemalige USB 3.1,
USB 3.2 Gen 2.
10 Gigabit.
10 Gigabit die Sekunde.
So weit, so gut, noch halbwegs nachvollziehbar.
Man würde jetzt vielleicht erwarten,
dass Generation 3 als nächstes kommt.
Oder vielleicht sogar gleich USB 4.
Aber...
Nicht mit dem USB-Forum.
Die brauchen dann nochmal eine Extrawurst.
Und zwar das richtige USB 3.2.
Jetzt kommt's.
Wie gesagt,
die anderen USB 3.2,
die ich euch vorher erzählt habe,
sind ja eigentlich bloß 3.0 und 3.1
umbenannt in 3.2.
Nennt sich eigentlich
USB 3.2 Generation 2
mal 2.
Auch genannt Superspeed USB 20 Gigabit.
Tja, wer sich jetzt fragt,
was mit denen los ist,
das kann ich euch leider auch nicht beantworten.
Das ist das eigentliche Problem.
Das ist das eigentliche Problem,
dass der Scheiß von dem Gremium
so unglaublich undurchsichtig ist.
Allerdings kann ich euch erklären,
woher die mal 2 kommen.
Die mal 2, also Generation 2 mal 2...
Woher kommen die 2 mal 2?
Das ist die unintuitivste Beschreibung
aller Zeiten, 2 mal 2.
Die 2 mal 2 kommt daher,
weil es zwei Datenleitungen sind.
Wer um alles in der Welt hat gedacht,
der Kunde interessiert sich dafür
und muss wissen, wie viele Datenleitungen da drin sind.
Bezieht sich darauf, dass es zwei...
Nicht etwa, weil es doppelt so schnell ist.
Okay, jetzt habe ich mein eigenes Video geleakt.
Die nächste Generation ist oder so.
Das wäre auch zu logisch.
Bezieht sich darauf,
dass es zwei Datenkabel
oder zwei Datenleitungen im USB-Kabel gibt.
Krunker.
Anscheinend denkt sich das USB-Forum,
es interessiert den Endkunde
in irgendeiner Art und Weise,
wie viele Datenleitungen
in so einem USB-Kabel drin sind.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr schon mal
einen Endkunde oder Konsument habt,
der euch gefragt hat,
wie viele Datenleitungen sind eigentlich im USB-Kabel drin?
Das interessiert die Leute nicht.
Ich glaube, das kommt so gut wie nie vor.
Ich kann nichts daran ändern.
Das USB-Forum hat das so entschieden
und die dürfen das entscheiden.
Und jetzt gibt es USB 4.
Und jetzt wird die ganze Sache noch verwirrender.
USB 4 kann man sich glücklicherweise ganz gut merken.
USB 4 hat eine Geschwindigkeit
von bis zu 40 Gigabit.
Das ist eine schöne Kombination.
USB 4, 40 Gigabit kann man sich merken.
Und USB 4 hat auch schöne,
viele gute Neuerungen.
Eigentlich ist fast alles gut an USB 4.
Außer die Benahmung.
Bloß die Benahmung wird nicht unbedingt besser.
Bei manchen Endkunden
oder bei allen
wird auch nicht gerade weniger werden durch USB 4.
An sich hat USB 4 jede Menge gute Sachen.
Zum Beispiel,
es ist zum Glück weiterhin ein USB-C Stecker.
Also sprich,
es gibt Gott sei Dank keinen neuen
Connector, keinen neuen Stecker.
USB 4 ist kompatibel
zu allem was davor
gekommen ist.
Man erkauft sich das zwar durch
unglaubliche Komplexität an manchen Stellen,
aber du kannst in USB 4
reinstecken, was es vorher auch schon gegeben hat.
Das ist auch ein richtig großer Pluspunkt.
Und ein weiterer Pluspunkt ist,
dass USB 4 endlich
oder eigentlich
nur ein bisschen anderes
Thunderbolt 3 ist.
Thunderbolt ist quasi das Intel USB,
wofür man eigentlich Lizenzen bezahlen musste
als Hardware-Hersteller.
Also sprich, wenn man als Hardware-Hersteller gesagt hätte,
Leute, ich möchte
Thunderbolt 3 implementieren, musst du
Lizenzgebühren an Intel bezahlen.
Und Intel hat das Ganze jetzt freigegeben.
Das ist ein netter Schachzug von Intel.
Hat das Ganze freigegeben, hat gesagt,
ey Jungs, Alter, lasst mal USB und
eigentlich wollte ich euch jetzt nur noch
erklären, wie das jetzt mit USB 4 wird,
weil die ganze Sache noch verwirrender wird.
Deswegen ist USB 4
wird Thunderbolt 3
und USB 4 noch eine gewisse Weile
der Anschluss der Wahl wieder werden.
So, wie gesagt,
USB 4 ist
bis zu 40 Gigabit schnell.
Die machen hier den Provider-Trick.
Bis zu 40 Gigabit. Vielleicht habt ihr das rausgehört.
Denn eigentlich ist die korrekte Bezeichnung
für USB 4, also für das schnelle USB 4
USB 4
Gen 3 mal 2.
Also es ist die Generation 3 mal 2
Datenleitung, was auf
Gen 4 3 mal 2
wie das berechnet wird, aber auf 40 mögliche
40 Gigabit kommt.
Um die Sache jetzt allerdings nicht zu einfach zu machen,
haben die sich überlegt,
man muss keine 40 Gigabit unterstützen,
um USB 4 draufschreiben zu können.
Um USB 4 draufschreiben zu können,
reicht es, wenn man USB 3.2
Generation 2 mal 2 unterstützt.
Also auch genannt
Superspeed USB mit 20 Gigabit.
Es macht es
natürlich nicht unbedingt klarer,
wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel ein Kabel,
oder ich frage mich, wie das wird, ehrlich gesagt,
wenn ich mir jetzt ein Kabel suche,
wenn ich als Endkunde sage,
hey, ich habe hier eine externe SSD,
ich möchte die so schnell wie möglich anschließen,
dann brauche ich ein Kabel mit USB-C.
So viel ist klar.
Und ich frage mich,
schafft das Kabel dann 20 Gigabit
oder schafft dieses Kabel dann 40 Gigabit?
Ich meine, da steht USB 4 drauf.
Da bin ich mal gespannt,
wie sie das Ganze machen, ehrlich gesagt.
Und mich würde es nicht wundern,
wenn die Verwirrung nicht noch weiter zunehmen würde.
Ja, also das ist das eigentliche Problem bei USB,
dass das Gremium nicht in der Lage ist,
ordentlich zu standardisieren
und dass sie das Schlimmste machen,
was du eigentlich bei einem Standard machen kannst,
quasi retroaktiv
alte
Namen umbenennen.
Eigentlich sind Standards ja dafür da,
dass du dich darauf verlassen kannst.
Aber wenn du anfängst,
drei Jahre später was Altes umzubenennen,
ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Das machen die halt.
So, und jetzt können wir uns das andere Video fertig angucken,
was er uns zum Stecker erzählt.
Was zum Teufel?
Typische Apple user halt wieder.
...
Wohingegen das hier
100 Watt schafft.
Das Kabelproblem ging dann soweit,
dass ich eine Zeit lang dachte, mein Handy wäre defekt.
Hier ist es nämlich so, dass ein Pixel 5
nicht mit einem OnePlus 8 Kabel geladen werden kann.
Gar nicht.
mit einem anderen adapter das ist das problem was ich gerade gesagt
habe dass das gleiche draufsteht aber es nicht klar ist was es eigentlich genau
ist wohingegen das huawei p40 pro problemlos kann
ein anderes beispiel um die ganze sache übrigens noch komplexer zu machen
mittlerweile hat intel auch eingesehen dass das usb forum absolut unfähig ist
für usb standards und macht jetzt ja noch mal einen neuen thunderbolt es gibt
jetzt ja es gibt jetzt ja quasi dass das intel thunderbolt 4 intel hatte ja
eigentlich keinen bock mehr auf thunderbolt und hat gesagt usb leute
macht das mal und internet aber gedacht die sind jetzt zu unfähig wir machen
jetzt noch mal ein neues die kamera die in 63 mit einem verbauten usb anschluss
lässt sich nur dann aufladen wenn man das mit einem usb zu usb kabel verbindet
wie
das glaube ich nicht dass liegt er daran was einskollen kabel ist dumm das
ganze ist das glaube ich nicht das drünben wenn man videos ist der kamera
doch vollkommen egal von dieser kamera auf seinem mac übertragen möchten denn
dann muss man die kamera über ein usb czu usb kabel so ein usb a2 usb adapter
an den mac verbinden
jetzt aber eher am controller liegen das ganze gilt aber auch bei der geschwindigkeit für die
datenübertragung wie gesagt usb c ist nicht gleich usb c das stimmt im endeffekt usb c ist halt
einfach nur der stecker man muss halt gucken was draufsteht auf der anderen seite es ist natürlich
nicht seine schuld und das ist das was ich meine video auch sagen wollte du kannst es von von einem
normalen anwender gar nicht erwarten dass er dadurch blickt vergiss es ich habe es ja in
meinem video gesagt dass das ist nicht möglich dadurch zu blicken sie ist nur ein anschluss in
dem auch landebutt stecken kann was wie gesagt bis zu 40 gigabit pro sekunde überträgt oder
auch usb 3.2 was nein nein nein oder usb 4 gen 3 x 2 20 jahre oder auch usb 3.1 gen 2 nein nein
das stimmt nicht das heißt nicht usb 3.1 gen 2 genau usb 3.2 gen 2
und im schlimmsten fall steckt hinter diesem anschluss ein popeliger 2.0 anschluss aus der
steinzeit was mit 4.0,48 gigabit schafft zudem unterstützt nicht jedes usb c kabel ja gut das
liegt aber dann daran was dein control also was du auf der anderen seite hast dass die wieder dem
kabel ist das ziemlich egal das hat man nicht jedes also beziehungsweise mit dem usb c schrauben
ja gut das liegt aber dann daran was dein control also was du auf der anderen seite hast das wie gesagt dem kabel ist das ziemlich egal also beziehungsweise mit dem usb c schrauben
ist das ziemlich egal also es ist aber wir haben ich gebe ihm recht es ist unglaublich mehr
smartphone bild ans fernseher zu übertragen und der letzte nachteil von usb c hier bezug auf den
lightning anschluss von apple ist die bauform dadurch dass ein loch in der mitte des anschlusses
wird der anschluss deutlich dicker und breiter gleichzeitig aber auch instabiler zudem kann sich
hierin sehr viel dreck ansammeln gut das sind punkte die man getrost ignorieren kann in anbetracht
der ganzen pustet einfach ein kabel nehme ich denn nun und woran erkenne ich das richtige kabel kurzantwort
gar nicht online lese ich immer die ganzen weisheiten nehmen einfach das neueste kabel
oder nimmt einfach das was man kann das na ja doch man kann das insofern erkennen wenn die
hersteller was ordentliches drauf drucken würden aber das ist tatsächlich schwierig
ja dabei war na ja wenn ich immer für jedes gerät das kabel mitnehmen soll was im lieferumfang dabei
war hätte usb c keinen wirklichen sinn und das neueste kabel zu nehmen scheint auch nicht aber
man muss sagen in der regel funktioniert es einfach bis zu dem zeitpunkt wo es halt nicht
funktioniert dann bist du am suchen lösung zu sein denn das aber zu 99 prozent funktioniert
nimmst usb c kabel stöpselt das dran oder geht es nie genau neu und ist trotzdem nicht für das
märkte gerade wenn du aber solche sachen machen willst wie bis mit bis zu 100 watt laden und so
was da dann wird es natürlich schwieriger mittlerweile so viele usb c kabel zu hause rumliegen
haben ja ja einzige tipp den ich euch empfehle ist die usb c kabel mit dem usb c kabel zu hause rumliegen haben ist der einzige tipp den ich euch empfehle
gut willst du sagen ist halt der übliche wahnsinn ach so wir waren ja wir waren ja noch bei
new useful smart home gear was kommt denn da sonst noch
speaking of z wave products well zeusen come out with a couple of new products that i think are very useful too and their first one is another leak sensor now this one's called the xs or the zse 42 this one doesn't have a long lead on it or a long probe so it can't go into something
but where it can go is under a lot of appliances or a lot of spaces because it's just zero that's video
war etwas panes champ point three inches thick plus with its low price tag this is pretty useful for
not a lot they also released a new open in closed door or windows sensor called the zse 41 now this
one again very soos soos expensive plus it has me das ist das ist das ist
so so das ist das wie die nicht soos nicht nicht nicht ich würde eher sagen zeus die
amis sprechen zeus das hat man ja auch gerade bei gso4 netzplays und sowas gesehen die sprechen dass
er soos aus soos auch kein mensch das braucht ganz ehrlich ich für für fenstersensoren
ist das beste der billigste aliexpress fenstersensor einfach weil du davon viele brauchst
euros moment da ist gar kein kokona
ich habe nichts gesagt
denen lügen nicht
ja moment logitech hat den krempel aber mittlerweile eingestellt logitech hat es
ja einfach gedacht wie ihr habt eine 500 euro fernbedienung gekauft ist uns egal wir stellen
das einfach mal ein
wurde eingestellt hast du gelitten
art home platforms if the developer has their way
dabei waren die dinge zumindest so war es ja das gesicht habe keine aber die
hatten ganz haben ganz gut eindruck gemacht
plus it will locally control your devices where that's even a possibility
and it will have its own charge base and an ire extender funktioniert die logitech
fernbedienung nicht mehr ich denke mal jegliche funktionen wo du halt
dich zu einem service connecten muss werden nicht mehr funktionieren
ich könnte mir vorstellen dass der hub an sich noch offline funktioniert wobei ich
nicht weiß keine ahnung wie iot und always on da kam es
das
moment du kannst remote mit irgendeinem motor das was ist das
oder
das
ist
die
im
gewanna
jetzt
ist
SEI
TAC
das
rein
__
automation
akast
am keller dann quasi das
was auch immer ich hab im keller nicht so ein schalter aber man könnte
dass auf ins wut drin oder so
hail
laut
youtube
leras
sprich
new
priker
hub
viel
auch kein mensch
another
Wozu? Ich habe einfach mein Handy, wenn ich irgendwelche Sounds brauche oder Nachrichten.
Ich will das Zeug gar nicht mit Amazon integrieren.
Ich will das mit meinem Zeug integrieren.
Alter, das sieht hässlich aus.
Das sieht aus wie ein Notfallknopf im Krankenhaus.
Oder irgendwie ein Rentnertelefon mit Kurzwahl.
Das würde ich mir nicht daheim hinlegen.
Oh, sieht das scheiße aus.
Wie oft hat eigentlich Amazon schon gesagt in diesem Video?
Ich würde mal sagen, bestimmt 20 Mal.
Ja, die sind wirklich nicht schlecht, allerdings nicht die aktuelle Version.
Ah, die V2, weiß nicht, ob man die flashen kann.
Nur die, die man custom flashen kann, weil da kann man nämlich das hier drauf flashen.
Und das ist Poggers.
Dann hat man eine ordentliche Firma mit Webinterface für die Kamera.
Oh.
Also ja, ich habe auch meine Kamera geflasht.
Du wirst bei mir, wird alles geflasht.
Aber so lange du ihre Cam Plus Subscription für 1,25 Dollar pro Kamera pro Monat hast,
dann wirst du diese tollen Notifizierungen mit deinen Amazon Echo Smart Displays bekommen.
Und das erlaubt dir, die Kamera-Fee automatisch auf deinem Smart Display zu bringen.
Wenn du möchtest, oder um andere Events und Notifikationen und Automatisierungen zu machen.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ja, okay.
Und dann ist dein Internetzugang weg und nichts geht mehr.
Never sub, never donated Adblock on free entertainment.
Genau.
It's not really expensive even over time.
But Wyze has been doing this with a couple of other devices.
And the new Wyze Scale S is only $15 US.
And that's an incredible price for a smart scale and to its...
Übrigens, jetzt wo ich es gerade sehe, die haben ihre kompletten Kundendaten, by the
way, geleakt.
Unter anderem Gewicht der Leute.
Also ich würde mir im Leben von denen nichts holen, was ich nicht irgendwie flashen kann.
Hier im Wyze-Leak, das haben die Leute wahrscheinlich schon wieder komplett vergessen.
Und die haben...
Unter anderem Gewicht, hier, Höhe, Gewicht, Gender, Bone Density, Bone Mass, Daily Protein,
das hat auch deine Kacke analysiert wahrscheinlich, Health Tokens, die haben alles geleakt.
Die haben alles geleakt, komplett.
Und die Videofeeds waren über den China-Chinesen-Server abrufbar.
Also das würde ich mir im Leben nicht in die Wohnung stellen.
More expensive $20 Counterpart.
It's only really giving up a few features.
Das haben die Leute schon wieder vergessen.
From the measurement standpoint, it's just that heartbeat, which...
By the way, das ist doch ein Reskin von der Xiaomi Mi Scale, oder?
Das sieht original so aus, man.
Weil die habe ich bei mir im Bad.
Das ist doch...
Das ist doch einfach ein Reskin in anderer Farbe.
Können mir nichts erzählen.
Wozu smarte Wagen?
Na, du kannst dein Gewicht automatisch protokollieren.
Das ist tatsächlich ganz nice.
Also ich habe ja auch so eine hier.
Ich habe ja auch so eine hier.
Und der schickt nach einem Wiege-Waage-Vorgang, schickt der per Bluetooth eine Message.
Und ich habe einen Controller, der die Message abgreift und bei mir den Home Assistant schreibt.
Das heißt, ich habe so eine History, Grafverlauf von wie pepo fertig bin.
Okay.
Hast du die geflasht? Nein, die ist nicht geflasht, aber die geht offline. Ich habe die nie gepairt mit irgendeiner App oder sonst was. Die schickt per Bluetooth einfach die Nachricht raus und fertig ist.
Ja, wie ich scanne.
Oh, was ist das für Big Brain Zeug?
Moment, was ist das?
Ein Vorhangs-Auf-und-Zumacher.
Tja, das wäre eine coole Sache, aber ich habe keine Vorhänge.
Und ich habe bei mir in der ganzen Wohnung keine Vorhänge.
Doch, stimmt nicht, im Bad habe ich einen.
Max lügt.
Im Bad habe ich einen.
Ähm...
Ich habe aber Rollläden, die man teilweise steuern kann.
Aber...
Coole, coole Sachen.
SwitchBot macht coole Sachen.
Wisst ihr, was wirklich nice ist von SwitchBot?
Der originale SwitchBot, den habe ich auch.
Habe ich auch welche? SwitchBot.
Der originale SwitchBot, der ist wirklich cool.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Richtig Big Brain.
Hier.
Ist das nicht Poggers?
Der kann für dich Knöpfe drücken, die du nicht smart machen kannst.
Ach, er wieder hier.
Guck mal.
Das ist richtig nice.
Das braucht man alles nicht dafür.
Viel zu teuer.
Weiß nicht.
Weiß gar nicht mehr, was es gekostet hat.
Guck mal, das finde ich richtig cool.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was es gekostet hat.
Ich habe die mal gekauft, als es die kurzzeitig bei Amazon gegeben hat.
Das ist richtig nice, das Ding.
Also für alles, was es kostet.
Was du nicht smart machen kannst, ist der SwitchBot wirklich Poggers.
Was kostet der gerade mittlerweile?
Ich gucke mal kurz bei Amazon, was ich dafür bezahlt habe.
Ich sage es euch gleich.
Amazon.
Orders.
Your Orders.
Switch.
Bot.
So.
Switch Bot.
Zwei Stück.
29 Euro habe ich dafür bezahlt.
Für einen.
Anscheinend.
Das ist doch okay.
Man braucht davon ja nicht viele.
Es gibt ja eh nicht viele Sachen, die man nicht automatisch.
Also, ne?
Ach, guck mal da.
Die China-Chinesen-Sachen sind natürlich wieder gleich viel günstiger.
Bluetooth Smart Fingerbot.
Der Fingerbot, alles klar.
Warum nicht?
Ja.
Aber die Idee finde ich, finde ich wirklich sehr nice.
Wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Ah.
Wo ist das Video, Leute?
Habe ich das zugemacht?
Ah, ich kacke nur.
Ich habe es zugemacht.
Aber wir sind, glaube ich, durch, oder?
Ja, NFC ist eh total unterschätzt.
NFC ist eines der besten Technologien, wenn du beispielsweise aufs Klo gehst und hast ein Handy dabei und willst damit irgendwas triggern.
Überall, wo du dein Handy dabei hast, um was auszulösen, sind NFCs die billigsten Schalter.
Das ist, um an oder aus einem Lichtschalter zu drücken.
Aber ich wollte ein bisschen Kontrolle über die Dämmung mit diesen NFC-Tags.
Na gut, das Gute ist, dass Switchbots uns neue Smart-Bulben und einen neuen Smart-LED-Strip bringen.
Ja, das juckt mich nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, was die noch haben.
Wieso nicht gleich auf dem Handy triggern?
Naja, weil du das Handy entweder entsperren musst oder Knopf drücken musst auf dem Handy.
Es ist einfacher, das Handy beispielsweise abends nebers Bett zu legen und es triggert ein alles Licht aus, anstatt dass du dann irgendwas drauf drücken musst.
Aber man kann das, also bei iPhones, weiß ich, bei Android geht das garantiert auch.
Du kannst dir mit Home Assistant auch so ein Widget machen.
Das scrollst du dann raus, also dann musst du bloß zweimal, zweimal drücken oder so.
Aber einfacher als NFC-Tag halten ist natürlich noch einfacher.
Ne, Alexa meine ich.
NFC-Tags.
Home Assistant Amber finde ich unsinnig, brauchen wir nicht.
Brauchen wir auch nicht.
Brauchen wir alles nicht.
Schon wieder, schon wieder, sette Cornerstecker.
Weckdose.
Ne, ne.
So.
Wollen wir uns auch ne Runde Battlefield 3 angucken?
Ähm.
Weißt du, ob ohne Programmer wieder möglichst Tuya-Lampen zu flashen haben soll?
Das kommt drauf an.
Kommt drauf an, wenn du Glück hast und findest welche, die noch gehen.
Ähm.
Es gibt da keine Updates in der Zwischenzeit zu.
Also, das Problem dabei ist ja auch, dass die China-Hersteller mittlerweile anfangen,
ihre Produkte nicht mehr unbedingt mit ESPs auszubauen.
Und spätestens dann ist es mit Custom-Firmware eh vorbei.
Also viele der neuen China-Tuya-Sachen sind halt keine ESPs mehr drin.
Und dann kannst du es eh vergessen.
Leider, leider.
Es ist wirklich statge...
Es war das...
Eigentlich war das das Beste für aus allen Welten, ja.
Die Noobs konnten die App verwenden.
Die Leute, die keine Probleme mit der China-Cloud hatten, konnten es verwenden.
Und wir, sagen wir mal, etwas...
...anspruchsvollere User, konnten den Kram flashen und damit machen, was sie wollten.
Aber ich hab vor zwei Wochen Steckdosen geflasht, das ging noch.
Aber die waren auch schon ein bisschen älter.
Felix, danke für den Sub.
Schon die News vom Battlefield?
Ja, hab ich, hab ich.
Hab ich mir schon angeguckt.
Ist ja nichts wirklich großartig Spannendes drin.
Gibt es jetzt einen Granaten-Indikator?
Es gibt ein paar neue Specialists.
Ja, dann kannst du...
Du meinst, du könntest sie vielleicht aufschrauben, aber Lampen kann man nicht gut aufschrauben.
Steckdosen schon, Lampen kannst du eigentlich eher vergessen.
Ist dann oftmals auch zugeklebt und sowas.
Wobei ich auch schon eine Steckdose hatte.
Da ging...
...gar nichts.
Also das war ein ESP, aber man konnte sie nicht flashen.
Kein Cringe zum Abschluss.
Nee, nee.
Das... Ich finde aber schon, dass die das interessieren sollte, weil die Leute...
...sagen wir mal so, die enthusiasten Benutzer kaufen den Kram ja letztendlich auch.
Und dann kaufen es weniger Leute.
Ich glaube, das lag weniger an den Herstellern...
...sondern an den Resellern, dass sie das nicht wollten.
Tuya selbst dürfte das egal sein.
Ja, 5% so, dann schlecht, oder?
Aber Tuya selbst dürfte das egal sein.
Die Reseller fanden das glaube ich kacke, dass die Leute die Geräte verwenden konnten, ohne quasi ihre Services zu verwenden.
Und deswegen haben die das glaube ich gemacht.
Ansonsten, warum nicht? 5% mehr sind 5% mehr.
Und hätte für sie ja keinen Unterschied gemacht.
Also macht ja keinen Sinn, es aktiv zu blocken.
Wenn man neue Chips verwendet und sagt, man hat dadurch andere Vorteile, ja, dann wäre es mir auch egal.
Aber beispielsweise Firmware-Updates zu entwickeln, die diese Sachen quasi ausbauen, die vorher möglich waren, das macht ja keinen Sinn.
Das ist mehr Aufwand für den Hersteller.
Und bringt ihnen ja auch nichts.
Und das haben die bestimmt auf Druck der Reseller gemacht.
Vermute ich jetzt einfach mal.
Ja.
Und ergeblich geht das mittlerweile sogar offline.
Aber ich denke mal, du brauchst immer noch eine App zum Setup.
Müsste ich mir mal angucken.
Würde Sony oder Nintendo einen besseren PC bauen?
Ups.
Hab ich irgendwas angeklickt? Wollte ich gar nicht.
Fight & Go, oder was?
Ähm.
Nintendo garantiert nicht.
Sony wahrscheinlich auch nicht.
PC ist halt eine sehr individuelle Geschichte.
Es gibt ja immer wieder so Sachen.
Es gibt ja eh nicht den besseren PC.
Es gibt ganz gute Builds für den jeweiligen Einsatzzweck.
Und da bezweifle ich, dass Sony oder Nintendo das irgendwie besser machen würden.
Guck mal, angeblich sieht das aus wie 4K.
Ja, das sieht eher aus wie 4K.
Ah, yes. Battlefield 3.
Ich überleg grad, ob ich vorher noch das...
Was haben wir hier sonst noch?
Gratis Laptop plus...
Oh, was? Letzter Preis.
Okay, dann gucken wir doch erstmal das an.
Wurde mir vorgeschlagen.
Ich hab von ihm noch nie was gesehen.
Hat auch nicht viele Subs.
Was? Letzter Preis.
Ich hab aber nie...
Legit, ich habe nie
eBay Kleinanzeigen benutzt.
Ich hab da immer einen riesen Bogen drum gemacht.
Da kann man tatsächlich auch Sachen suchen.
Richtig oldschool, Frank.
Und gucke, ob vielleicht sich wer meldet,
der bereit ist, seine Hardware,
Smartphones, was auch immer, abzugeben.
Ha, eBay Kleinanzeigen.
Suche kostenlose Laptop.
Für umsonst.
Möglichst gratis.
Wenn man mal ganz kurz hier auf eBay Kleinanzeigen guckt,
sieht man, dass es wirklich einige Leute gibt, die sowas versuchen.
Was meistens tatsächlich auch
erfolgreich ist, kann ich aus Erfahrung sprechen.
Und ich werde, wie gesagt, in diesem Video
einfach mal selber das nochmal versuchen.
Mal gucken, wie viel Hardware,
PCs, was auch immer, man tatsächlich gratis bekommt.
Als erstes muss ich
natürlich eine Anzeige erstellen.
Und das mache ich jetzt einfach mal.
Und ich werde das Ganze mal benennen.
Ja, ich suche PCs, Smartphones und Laptops.
Weil das so die Sachen sind, mit denen ich gerne rumbastel,
mit denen ich gerne was mache.
Ob sich da Leute melden?
Also ich frag mich gerade, was ist der Anreiz?
Warum geht man auf eBay und sagt,
ah ja, da sucht einer einen kostenlosen PC,
ich fahr da mal vorbei und geb dem einen.
Gut, wenn du ihn loswerden willst.
Wenn du kostenlos loswerden willst.
Da würde ich ihn sogar lieber noch auf den Müll schmeißen,
als zu irgendjemand hinzufahren
oder den abholen zu lassen oder sonst was.
Also ich würde es wahrscheinlich
einfach in den Müll schmeißen.
Ich würde es kaputt machen und in den Müll schmeißen.
Dass dann keiner meinen Müll rumwühlt.
Wo sollen die Geräte abgeholt werden?
Sie sollen möglichst gratis sein.
Auch das Ganze möglichst nett.
Und dann natürlich noch Fotos hinzufügen.
Und da habe ich mir gedacht, ich nehme einfach mal Symbolfotos.
Die mache ich natürlich selber.
Also erst mal drei Rechner, mache davon ein Foto.
Dann ein Laptop, mache davon ein Foto.
Dann Smartphones
und mache davon auch ein Foto.
Das Ganze dann auch schön zuschneiden.
Und zack, ist die Anzeige auch schon fertig.
Und ja, dann müssen wir sie einfach aufgeben.
Das mache ich jetzt auch einfach mal.
Und dann mal gucken, ob sich wer meldet.
Nach drei Stunden hatte die Anzeige schon
42 Aufrufe und wurde schon einmal gemerkt.
Und ja, ob ihr es glaubt oder nicht,
ich habe schon eine Anfrage bekommen,
wo jemand anscheinend einen defekten Laptop abzugeben hat.
Das hat mich natürlich auch sehr interessiert.
Und so wie ich bin, ich frage eigentlich in der Regel
immer nach Fotos vorher, damit ich einschätzen kann,
ist es das wert, zum Beispiel,
wenn das jetzt irgendwas ist, mit dem ich gar nichts machen kann
und ich dann ganz weit fahre, nur um das abzuholen,
ist das auch irgendwie doof.
Aber, als er mir dann tatsächlich die Fotos geschickt hat...
Wahrscheinlich wieder 500 Kilometer
gefahren für einen kostenlosen Laptop.
Konnte ich meinen Augen gar nicht trauen.
Ja, sieht doch ganz gut aus.
Und ja, ich habe es richtig gesehen.
Der wollte tatsächlich diesen Laptop einfach verschenken.
Und ich meine, selbst wenn der einen Totalschaden hat,
das ist Core-E-Serie, irgendwelche mindestens
sechste Generation, also das war wirklich Wahnsinn.
Ja, und das Gespräch ist auch gut verlaufen.
Er hat gesagt, ich kann den Laptop am nächsten Tag abholen.
Und das hat mich wirklich
sehr gefreut. Ihr könnt euch das gar nicht vorstellen.
Dann am nächsten Morgen,
dem Tag darauf, habe ich dann noch eine Anfrage bekommen.
Ich glaube, dass manche Leute
einfach nett sind.
Also,
man kann sich...
Ich persönlich kann mir das schlecht vorstellen,
weil ich
nicht nett oder Kontakt
mit fremden Leuten da irgendwie haben will.
Aber...
Ich glaube, manche Leute sind einfach
nett.
Ich habe Teile vom PC
nur Abholung.
Wer kennt es nicht?
PC-Teile.
Beziehungsweise noch einer, der gesagt hat,
jo, du kannst das haben. Er hat mir Hardware-Teile angeboten.
Gut, also mit Rechtschreibung muss man sich eh verabschieden
auf eBay Kleinanzeigen.
Wobei ich damit überhaupt kein Problem habe.
Ihr kennt meine Tweets, die sind auch nicht gerade sonderlich
Pfeifert-Grammatik.
Wie ihr hier auch erkennen könnt,
und das war jetzt nicht wirklich special,
aber da das tatsächlich im gleichen Ort lag
und nicht so weit entfernt war, habe ich überlegt,
jo, das nehme ich dann auch noch mit.
Also habe ich das auch klar gemacht.
LC-Power-Netzteil, Leute, ich sage es euch.
Das smokt.
Das raucht ab nach Einschalten.
Ja, leider habe ich jetzt nicht wirklich
was beim Abholen aufgenommen.
Deswegen gehen wir jetzt direkt wieder hier zu mir nach Hause
und ich zeige euch einfach mal,
was ich so alles bekommen habe.
So, ich bin jetzt hier wieder zu Hause
und habe noch ein bisschen mehr mitgenommen,
als nur die Sachen, die ich erwähnt habe.
Zum Beispiel auch dieses Soundsystem oder die Mäuse,
weil der eine eBay-Typ hat mir da noch ein bisschen mehr gegeben.
Der eBay-Typ hat gesagt, wenn sie gerade schon da sind,
nehmen sie den ganzen Scheiß mit.
... links den PC als erstes anschauen,
danach die PC-Teile,
danach das Soundsystem und danach die Mäuse und den Laptop,
weil das Beste kommt zum Schluss.
Ja, der Rechner, wie auch schon auf dem Foto
erkennbar war, war ein Acer
und der war auf jeden Fall auch witzig verpackt.
Oder Archer, wie meine Oma
immer gesagt hat.
Der halbe Rechner ist mir schon zusammengefallen,
das war ein bisschen komisch.
Allgemein waren auch irgendwie die Seitenwände nicht richtig dran,
also irgendwas ist damit auf jeden Fall passiert.
Wie man hier vorne erkennen kann, ist verbaut
oder sollte verbaut sein ein Quad 2 Quad.
Meine Oma hat immer gesagt Archer.
Eine ATI-Radeonkarte und Windows Vista,
aber ob da noch eine Festplatte oder irgendwas
der Teile drin ist, weiß ich natürlich nicht.
Okay, das ist ziemlich olles Zeug.
Aber Hauptsache erst einmal
zwei DVD-Laufwerke.
Und ja, der Kartenleser,
der vorne eigentlich drin sein sollte,
auf der Rückseite des PCs haben wir
ein normales Netzteil.
Oh, PS2, aber
schon USB, USB
ist am Start, wahrscheinlich zwei,
wenn man Glück hat schon.
DVI, VGA,
das sieht aus wie so ein PC von, was weiß ich,
2008 oder so.
VGA, viermal USB, einmal Ethernet und drei
Audioanschlüsse, ebenso wie noch eine
LAN-Karte, so wie es aussieht, die unten verbaut ist.
Und das Öffnen des Rechners war wirklich, wirklich
schwer, nämlich die ganze Seitenwand hat geklemmt,
sonst was. Aber als ich ihn dann aufbekommen habe,
habe ich auch gesehen, yo, da ist nicht mehr die original...
Ah, guck mal hier, der hat es damals richtig,
der hat so einen Schraubenzieher mit...
Wie heißt das? VDE?
Ausführung? Wie nennt man das denn?
Mit die isoliert sind.
Aber als ich ihn dann aufbekommen habe, habe ich auch gesehen,
yo, da ist nicht mehr die original Hardware verbaut, also
damit ist schon irgendwas passiert, beziehungsweise
der wurde auf jeden Fall umgebaut.
In den RAM-Slots waren außerdem zwei unterschiedliche
RAM-Regel verbaut und eine Festplatte
war leider auch nicht mehr drin.
Der Rechner also angeschaltet, mit dem On-Off-Knopf,
der hier so halb raushängt, weil er ist oben nicht mehr angeschlossen.
Lull! Besser, besser
On-Off-Knopf! Es sollte es auch anders sein,
der Rechner ging nicht an, also wirklich gar nichts.
Keine LED, kein Lüfter
und da habe ich immer schon gedacht, oh, da ist bestimmt
irgendwas richtig faul.
Da ist wahrscheinlich einfach irgendwas nicht richtig angesteckt.
Was ich als erstes gesehen habe, war, dass der
CPU-Lüfter tatsächlich gar nicht an den vorgesehenen
Anschluss angeschlossen wurde, sondern an den Anschluss
für einen Gehäuse-Lüfter. Und was ich
dann auch gesehen habe, oh, das was
ich gedrückt habe, war tatsächlich der Reset-Button, der
hat komplett gefehlt.
Umgesteckt. Also ich könnte mir
tatsächlich vorstellen, dass der Kram funktioniert,
man glaubt das gar nicht, aber Hardware ist,
wenn man da keine Löcher
reinmacht oder irgendwie es wirklich
dass Komponenten
davon abfallen oder so, einfach
nur wenn Hardware rumsteht,
geht Hardware
meiner Erfahrung nach zumindest so
gut wie nicht kaputt.
Also du kannst eigentlich
einen PC, also hätte irgendjemand
einen 486er PC
vor 40 Jahren auf den Dachboden
gestellt und man würde den heute runterholen
und anschließend die Chancen,
dass der geht, wären relativ hoch.
Einfach auf die Pins für den
On-Off-Button gesteckt und
dann ist der Rechner tatsächlich
auch angegangen. Das Bild kam allerdings
erst nach circa einer Minute, aber
es kam, da war ich schon glücklich und
nach einer Minute. Da kann man auch mal kurz sehen, wir haben
einen AMD-Adlon-Dual-Core-Prozessor
5050E, das heißt wir haben
eine AMD-Plattform und keine Intel-Plattform mehr,
wie das Gehäuse ja vormunkelt.
Auch ins BIOS kommen wir rein und wie man
auch schon sieht, wir haben 1 GB RAM. Das liegt daran,
dass ich den Ein-RAM-Regel rausgebaut habe, da er sonst
nicht angehen will, also ist das wahrscheinlich auch ein Fehler.
Aber ansonsten funktioniert der Rechner, da
habe ich jetzt eigentlich keinen Zweifel dran.
Ja, die Sache ist nur die, du hast
das Ding jetzt zwar kostenlos auf Ebay bekommen,
aber was willst du denn damit machen?
Also ich meine, du hast den dann ja schön
und gut. Und dann? Also
und weiter?
But why? Also was
denn jetzt?
Bitcoin meint er, das bringt es ja damit nicht.
Ich weiß, es ist G-Bait, aber was willst du machen, ja?
Also was machst
du damit dann im Endeffekt? Basteln?
Ja, der hat wahrscheinlich aber schon 50
Bastelrechner.
Mit 20 Festplatten steht das, selbst dafür lohnt sich
das nicht.
Was ich mit dem Rechner mache, muss ich mal gucken.
Das ist ja ein ziemliches Wrack, aber die hat...
Siehst du, du kannst eigentlich nichts machen.
Also mal gucken, kann man sicherlich irgendwie weiterverwenden.
Aber ich glaube, das Gehäuse kann ich
wirklich entsorgen, weil das hat abgebrochene
Stellen. Zu was willst du es halt verwenden?
Es gibt halt nichts. So, als nächstes kommen wir jetzt zu den PC-Teilen.
Die ja vom gleichen eBay-Typ stammen.
Und ich mache hier mal kurz einen Schnelldurchlauf der Teile,
die wir bekommen haben. Testen werde ich die jetzt nicht.
Das sind CPUs von 2005 oder so.
Da könnte sogar ein
aktueller Raspberry Pi schneller sein.
Als erstes haben wir
ein Asus A8NE-FMS
für den Sockel 939, ohne
CPU. RAM ist auch nicht verbaut und
I.O.-Blende fehlt, soweit ich weiß, auch. Aber vielleicht
ist hier noch... Was ist denn
das hier für ein Ding? Ich meine, ich würde
sagen, das ist ein Soundausgang eigentlich.
So einen
...
Ich habe vorhin wieder vergessen, wie die Dinger heißen. Aber warum hat das hier so einen komischen
SPDIF? Ja, kann
sein. Aber so ein analoger noch.
Das, was es heute eigentlich nur
im Petos-Link gibt. Ist das
ein Firewire-Anschluss?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Ist das auch Firewire?
Okay, das ist oldschool.
Ob das so ein Firewire-Anschluss ist?
Ja, das war noch aus
Zeiten, wo Mainboards
braun oder gelb...
braun oder grün oder blau waren.
Da war es noch nicht so, dass
die irgendwie Killer Fatality
Headshot iScopes
Pro hießen und irgendwelche komischen
Silber-verpläneten
Dinger drauf hatten.
Ich denke mal, das Mainboard wird wahrscheinlich noch funktionieren,
aber ich werde es jetzt wie gesagt nicht testen.
Als nächstes haben wir, so wie es aussieht,
das Mainboard für den Acer-Rechner tatsächlich,
weil verbaut ist ein Quad-Spy-Quad
und was mich auch gewundert hat, auf dem Mainboard
liegt einfach die CPU rum und
wie sich daraus schließen lässt, ist, dass tatsächlich die CPU
für das Asus-Board, also die ist einfach nur abgefallen
aus irgendeinem Grund. Die CPU ist
leider unfassbar beschädigt, beziehungsweise
die Pins sind verbogen. Ich glaube, das kann man
reparieren, aber ob es ein Wert ist, ist die andere Frage.
Wozu? Wozu?
Als nächstes haben wir hier 2x 1GB DDR400-RAM.
Weiterhin waren noch 3
Festplatten in der Tüte, 2 Seagate und eine
Mac-Store. Wetten, wenn du die
anschließt, findest du massig private Sachen.
Die Leute sind da so leichtsinnig.
Allerdings hören die sich nicht mehr wirklich gut an,
wenn man die... Ah, Festplatten, die kaputt sind,
immer noch der beste, beste Sort.
Festplatten, ich versuch das mal kurz
nachzustellen, ja. Festplatten, die angehen
und kaputt sind, die machen meistens am Anfang
Also
starten und dann macht's auf einmal
Und dann weißt du,
okay, RIP.
Ein bisschen neigt, dann hört man darin schon so ein komisches
Klicken, also ich glaub nicht mehr, dass die funktionieren.
Der erste Klick ist normal.
Das dreht an
und dann ab einer gewissen Geschwindigkeit
klappt das Zeugs
irgendwie aus. Also der erste Klick
dieser erste
Klick und dann
ist normal
bei der Festplatte, aber wenn's dann
weiter die ganze Zeit macht, dann weißt
du, RIP.
...bestimmt irgendwie da rumgeschüttelt wurden im Karton. Ich hab zwar
sehr aufgepasst, aber... Ich seh in dem Chat, gefällt
meine Interpretation der Festplattengeräusche.
Ich glaube, die sind kaputt. Als letztes in
der Tüte war noch... Pass mal auf, das
mein ich. Broken
HDD Sound. Gibt's bestimmt
hier als Sound. Ja!
Das! Alter!
Ist der am
weinen?
...
natürlich der core 2 quad und vielleicht auch ein paar der rahmenregel könnte ich noch was ist denn
mit dem notebook muss ich gucken die cpu kann man wie gesagt auch noch reparieren insgesamt
ja zum basteln sicherlich ganz interessant so als erst mal abholen dem hier das hat er ja in
einen karton reingepackt und es ist auch wirklich ziemlich abholen auf müll fahren und ich werde das
ganze jetzt einfach mal auspacken und aufbauen ob ich testen kann weiß ich nicht aber mal gucken so
das ganze habe ich jetzt erstmal ausgepackt erscheint ein 5.1 soundsystem zu sein auch
mit dem receiver und ich kenne mich jetzt nicht wirklich das alte zeug ist oftmals gar nicht so
schlecht soundmäßig gut damit aus also sorry ich werde das ganze jetzt mal so weit wie es geht
aufbauen und gucken ob ich damit irgendwas machen kann okay ich habe das ganze aufgebaut und wie
auch schon sehen könnt es geht auch an und es kommt auch so ein rauschen besonders wenn die
lautstärke hoch dreht das problem ist dass ich das ganze jetzt nicht wirklich auf die schnelle
testen kann ich nehme aber mal anders noch funktioniert ich meine warum sollte so was
kaputt sein und da gibt es ja ganz viel ersatzteil auch dazu aber ich denke macht er nun an und
verkauf wahrscheinlich nicht
ich verstehe den sinn davon auch nicht aber der einzige also der sinn ist ja schon mal hier
ganz gut zu sehen er kann wenigstens youtube videos von machen ich meine das ist ja auch
eine möglichkeit ob ich damit was anfangen kann muss ich mal gucken ansonsten werde ich weiter
verschenken so jetzt kommen wir zum großen finale und zwar zu dem laptop und den mäusen ich glaube
darauf habt ihr auch schon gewartet weil der laptop ist jetzt wirklich was ich kann es kaum
noch erwarten und ja ich würde mal sagen ich stelle ich erst mal kurz die mäuse vor wir haben ja mal
einen rocket kain oder kain und eine rocket zart originalverpackung ich dachte so okay und ja beim
aufmachen zeigt sich natürlich erst mal der laptop selber ebenfalls aber noch drin sind noch die
bedienungsanleitung und das aufladekabel also das komplette set ich weiß wirklich nicht warum ihr
das abgibt aber kann ja sein dass der laptop total schon hat dann könnte ich es auch irgendwie
verstehen beim aufklappen des laptops zeigt sich auch er sieht ich im sehr sehr guten volkskazane
sieht sieht echt noch gut in schuss aus er hat keine kratzer oder irgendwas und ja wie man unten
rechts auch sehen kann das habe ich auch echt nicht fassen können weil ich wusste zwar irgendeinen core
ein core i7 und dann auch noch so ein neuer das habe ich wirklich das hat mich wirklich sehr
gewundert wie schon gesagt sieht der laptop relativ gut aus das display auch noch auf der
unterseite sieht der laptop auch noch ganz gut aus und was die ports angeht haben wir einmal
den stromanschluss ein ethernet port ein hdmi-anschluss ein usb-port und ein kartenleser
und auch dann hat er einen kopfhöreranschluss zwei usb-anschlüsse ein cd-laufwerk bzw dvd-laufwerk
und ein kensington lockt beim ersten versucht den laptop anzuschalten über den akku ist natürlich nix
aber ich habe den laptop dann an das ladekabel angeschlossen und unten links kam tatsächlich
eine weiße led was er schon mal sehr gutes zeichen ist dass er zumindest erkennt dass
was angeschlossen wurde und beim anschalten habe ich tatsächlich selber nicht glauben können aber
der laptop ging an nach einer zeit kam dann tatsächlich der ladebalken von windows 10 und
nach einer zeit war ich dann auch wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich immer noch komplett mit user daten
und alle ich die leute so leistet also erst ganz normal angegangen als ob er einfach gestern runter
kommen das ist sogar ein windows 10 auch das touchpad funktioniert die tastatur
funktioniert bei der passwort eingabe also das gerät war wirklich noch einwandfrei am laufen
natürlich kann ich jetzt hier nicht viel machen deswegen werde ich jetzt erstmal ins bios gehen
und wie man hier auch schon erkennen kann haben wir ein core i7 6500 eine 1 terabyte was wenn
bios gigabyte ram also das ist ein richtiges monat s bios das ist das wie bei den ersten
efi bios dinge als die festgestellt haben man könnte man kann jetzt ja ein bisschen grafisch
machen und maus support und so
Da haben die quasi Windows-Menüs nachgebaut.
Richtig, richtiger Paints-Champ.
Ordentlicher Laptop.
Ich habe dann Windows neu installiert, aber die Installation mit der HDD hat wirklich ewig gebraucht.
Also wirklich sehr, sehr lange, untypisch lange.
Echt, sieht das immer noch so aus, Badel?
Deswegen habe ich einfach die HDD rausgebaut und eine SSD reingebaut.
Und hier kann man mal kurz sehen, das ist wirklich super einfach.
Jetzt flutscht es mit SSD.
Also sehr gut austauschbar.
RAM, selbst BIOS-Batterie und den Akku kann man auch noch rausnehmen.
Und nach dem Einbau der SSD habe ich dann Windows 10 installiert.
Und es läuft einwandfrei.
Ich habe bei der Installation gar keine Probleme gehabt.
Diesen USB-Stick, Leute, wer hatte den auch schon?
Ich sage jetzt, 50 Leute schreien jetzt hier.
Weil diese Sorte USB-Sticks, das ist der typische billig-China-Chinesen-USB-Stick, den hatte jeder schon mal.
Jeder hatte den und die sind schlecht.
Die sind richtig schlecht, diese Dinger.
Die Frage ist eher, wer nicht.
Ja, wer nicht.
Ich frage mich wirklich echt, warum hat der?
Beziehungsweise, warum hat er ihn mir geschenkt?
Ich, neugierig wie ich bin, habe ihn tatsächlich nochmal gefragt, was der mit dem Laptop eigentlich sei.
Weil das hat er mir ja gar nicht gesagt, auch vor Ort nicht.
Und er meinte dann, dass er den Rechner mal Gebrauch gekauft hat und der manchmal nicht richtig hochgefahren ist und dann irgendwann gar nicht mehr ging.
Aber anscheinend geht er ja jetzt einwandfrei und bisher konnte ich auch keine Defekte feststellen.
Auch beim Installieren der Klassik-Treiber von AMD.
Hier ist übrigens verbaut eine AMD Radeon R5 M335.
Ich glaube, das ist auch nicht so schlecht.
Das ist auch nicht so schlecht.
Und ich hoffe mal, das bleibt auch so.
Um eine gute Funktion zu gewährleisten, werde ich den Laptop jetzt noch den Abend hier testen.
Und werde euch dann morgen, beziehungsweise jetzt gleich im Video, mal kurz das Ergebnis sagen, ob das noch alles gut funktioniert.
Weil der Laptop muss ja auch ein bisschen getestet werden.
Und mal gucken, ob er dann immer noch geht.
So, jetzt hier am nächsten Tag, ich melde mich wieder.
Und tatsächlich, der Laptop hat keine Probleme gemacht.
Einmal ist er ausgegangen, weil der Akku leer war.
Und da kommen wir auch schon zum nächsten Thema.
Der Akku funktioniert auch.
Ist zwar nicht mehr der Beste.
Aber immer noch brauchbar.
Ich habe gestern auch auf dem Minecraft gespielt.
Und es hat auch funktioniert.
Na gut, Minecraft.
Na gut, das stimmt gar nicht.
Minecraft ist tatsächlich viel anspruchsvoller, als man so denkt.
Also, der Laptop scheint wieder sehr gut zu laufen.
Ich kann es mir, wie gesagt, immer noch nicht erklären.
Aber ich würde mal sagen, Jackpot.
In Zukunft werde ich ihn auf jeden Fall noch etwas weiter nutzen.
Und euch dann vielleicht irgendwann mal wieder sagen, ob das Ganze noch funktioniert.
Aber das ist wirklich einer der besten, ich sag mal, Funde, die ich jemals hatte.
So, so nice.
Kann man wenigstens was anfangen im Vergleich zu dem anderen Kram.
Und ich fange jetzt hier einfach mal mit der Rocket-Kammer an.
Alter, die sieht ein bisschen versifft aus.
Die sieht leider relativ dreckig.
Aber ich denke mal, das ist nichts, was man jetzt nicht bereinigen könnte.
Und beim Anstecken ist tatsächlich nichts passiert.
Also dachte ich, die Maus ist vielleicht auch einfach kaputt.
Aber beim zweiten Anstecken, warum auch immer, kam dann unten eine rote Beleuchtung.
Und die Maus ging einwandfrei.
Also, ich weiß nicht genau, was da los war.
Auch bei Installation der Rocket-Treiber, das habe ich jetzt hier nicht gezeigt, funktioniert die Maus sehr gut.
Allerdings kann ich aus irgendeinem Grund die Beleuchtung nur...
...nur in verschiedene Farben ändern.
Und ich glaube, so 70% der Farben funktioniert hier nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, woran es liegt, aber die Funktion der Maus ist auf jeden Fall gewährleistet.
Also, wenn RGB nicht geht, ist sie ja quasi gleich kaputt.
Ohne RGB, wer will denn sowas?
Nice.
Echt pock.
So, jetzt gucken wir zum Schluss nochmal eine Runde Battlefield 3 Top-Players.
Da habe ich jetzt nochmal Bock drauf.
Zack, in den Kopf.
Next, in den Kopf.
Alter, da werden sie weggesprayt.
Zack.
Sehr nice.
Next.
SV98 ACOG, das sieht man auch selten im BF3.
Zack, wir müssen noch was gucken.
Was meint ihr, wie viele Spieler hat Venice heute?
Wie viele Spieler hat Venice heute?
Also, ich tippe auf, der meistbesuchte Surfer hat drei Spieler.
Ja, drei.
Drei Spieler würde ich auch sagen.
Vier.
Ah, noch nicht.
Zack.
Comeback, comeback.
Comeback.
Ja, es ist ja auch ein gutes Game.
Ist ja auch ein gutes Game.
Kein Wunder, dass das noch Leute spielen.
Warum hast du es noch nicht deinstalliert?
Warum soll ich?
Kannst du einfach ab und zu mal reingucken.
Kann mich nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Zack.
Er muss mit dem Fuß schießen, oder was?
Ja.
Ah, das kommt jetzt wahrscheinlich, das
Huge Play.
Jawohl, Spawnpunkt, Spawnpunkt, die Gegner
checken es wieder nicht. Excellent, excellent, so muss das sein.
Oh!
Ah, ich dachte, es gibt jetzt Collateral durch
drei Gegner durch.
Der benutzt sogar seine Drohne, guckt euch das mal an.
Gibt's selten.
Nice.
Sein paar Killstreaks sind selten.
Ah,
Rex, beste.
Weggerext.
Nice.
Deswegen mag ich Battlefield 3.
Alter, die werden ja weggesprayt,
die Leute, ey.
Das ist nicht der Spawn von denen.
Der Spawn von denen ist da hinten,
wenn sie Base spawnen, hier hinten.
Die spawnen absichtlich bei den Leuten
und lassen sich bashen.
Der ist gut.
Wenigstens labert er heute nicht dabei,
das finde ich nice.
Aber Metro, ist halt immer Metro, ne?
Sag mal, von der
Auflösung her könnte das fast Xbox sein.
Es
ist aber PC.
Der Sound, der Sound von
Battlefield 3 ist auch nice.
Das hat mir ja in Battlefield 2042
noch ein bisschen gefehlt.
Und jetzt für eine kurze Botschaft
von dieser Episode, Sponsor Apex Gaming PC.
Der erste, der die M416
auf Gran Bazaar benutzt.
Das ist eine Map, die ich wirklich hoffe,
M416, beste.
Es ist so ein Klassiker
und eine der besten Rush-Maps.
Ende Tingo.
Ich mach Big Shark eigentlich.
M16, M16, M416.
Das war, wisst ihr,
natürlich hatte Battlefield 3 OP-Shit.
M16 war OP.
Aber es war zumindest
noch ein bisschen
Variation drin. Du konntest M416
spielen, M16 spielen, AEK spielen.
Boah, das ist schon mal ganz gut.
Du konntest sowas wie AS Val
und so auch ohne Probleme spielen.
Bei den Sniper konntest du auch verschiedene Sachen spielen.
Bei den Engineer-Waffen, P90,
sonst was. Also,
du hattest schon, so sagen wir mal,
so sechs, sieben
Dinger.
Das reicht eigentlich.
Viel mehr wirst du eh nicht balanced kriegen.
Zumal, was cool war,
du hattest ganz klar Schwerpunkte
der Waffen und das hat auch funktioniert.
Du hattest eine M16, das war natürlich allround
OP as fuck, das war natürlich die beste Waffe
im Spiel. Aber du hattest sowas wie eine AEK,
die dich schon,
oder eine AN-94 oder sowas,
die dich schon schlagen konnte, wenn du
dir Mühe gegeben hast.
Natürlich, allround-mäßig war das einfach
besser als alles andere.
Du hattest eine M416, die alle M16-Leute
gespielt haben, die nicht geschimpft
bekommen wollten, dass sie OP-Waffen spielen.
Ja, nice.
Und die Pistolen
gingen halt auch gut ab.
Alter, was ein Krach.
Und das war, was ich halt richtig mag an Battlefield 3,
das ist halt
richtig schön fast-paced.
Du kannst da nicht, also
du musst da nicht ewig rumstellst und sonst was
und du bist auch schnell wieder in der Action,
selbst wenn du fünfmal auf den Sack kriegst,
weil ungünstiger Spawn, das sechste Mal
kriegst du dann, kriegst du einen guten Flank hin,
machst irgendwie 15 Kills oder so.
Der ganze Spielfluss
und die Maps und das alles im Gesamtpaket
war einfach richtig nice in Battlefield 3.
Siebertower!
Revive Train,
den ich ja persönlich
gut fand.
Er musste nicht viel machen und hat
trotzdem Teamplay quasi gefördert.
Weil wer revived
in Battlefield, jetzt mal ernsthaft,
wie oft wurde in der Battlefield 2042
später revived?
Ich denke mal, insgesamt wurde ich vielleicht
zehnmal revived, wenn's hochkommt.
Und ich hab selbst vielleicht auch zehnmal revived.
Dudududududududud.
Wo ist der Hugeplay? Bam!
Gesprüht und gebetet hier.
Das war typische Battlefield-Hit-Detection.
Er ist eigentlich schon weg
und stirbt dann noch.
Jawoll.
Siehste?
So muss das mit dem Wiederbeleben sein.
Ansonsten ist es doch, guck mal,
wie hätte der jetzt hier
wirklich diese zehn Sekunden Battlefield
2042 Wiederbelebung
machen sollen? Da werden die doch alle verreckt.
Einfach hin.
Bipp. Weiter. Zack.
Das sind zwei Sekunden.
Fördert Teamplay und, und,
fack dich nicht selbst
in die Ass, ja?
Natürlich war's op, aber
das hatten alle Seiten. Ich hab da, also
das fand ich jetzt wenig problematisch
in Battlefield 3.
100 HP,
100 HP reviven
konnte nur dieser
eine Specialist, den man hatte.
Ähm,
angeblich.
Laut DICE-Beschreibung.
Und
der andere Specialist,
der andere Specialist, der andere Specialist, der andere Specialist, der andere Specialist, der andere Specialist, der andere Specialist, den andere Specialist, der andere Specialist, der andere Specialist, der andere Specialist, der andere Specialist.
andere Medicspecialist, den es jetzt gibt, der kann
schneller reviven.
Aber reviven an sich kann ja jeder.
Der Sound war richtig nice, ne?
Oh!
Hä?
Ich hab's nicht gecheckt.
Hat der grad was gekillt? Ich hab's nicht gecheckt.
Hat der... Hä?
A horizontal rendezvous. You don't see them
very often at all in Battlefield 3
as people usually go for the easier vertical
rendezvous. Hittert das jetzt gleich noch, oder was?
And then the second clip that you'll see in the second clip
is an anti-air clip
from the ground in a tank.
Just incredible accuracy.
Oh, nice!
Das war cool.
Das machst du...
Das musst du halt 500 Mal machen, dass es halt mal klappt.
Okay, ein bisschen übertrieben.
50 Mal.
100 Mal.
Ja, gut. Das war gut Glück.
Das war auch gut Glück.
Der wollte den zwar hitten und hat in die Richtung gezielt,
aber das war trotzdem viel Glück dabei.
Das war jetzt nicht auf den Millimeter
calculated.
Next up, we've got two clips
from Laki. The first one
is from GammaVampire.
Bam! Intervention.
Rust one-on-one
intervention only.
A lot of easy shots here as players
aren't really paying too much attention and clearly,
he's not getting shot by most of them.
A nice streak though to start us off
and it's actually a good talking point
really for the next Battlefield game.
Battlefield Portal is going to allow us
to recreate some of these classic moments.
Sure, we might not get access to
Damovan Peak right at the start,
but there is a new map coming with
2042 that does have the classic
base jump. It might then be possible
to create your own
classic rush mode, just like
we had in Battlefield 3.
We've already seen that you can have the Battlefield 3,
three classes, and the old medic,
support, recon,
and engineer, just like
you can see in the background.
We're in the same world as well.
I'm really hoping that there's a lot of similarities.
So, we're not going to play this game,
but we're just epic.
The second clip is on Mushar Canals,
and this is a map that we will be seeing with Battlefield Portal.
Enjoy this aggressive sniping stream.
If you press long, you get the kill animation.
I think if you press short,
you get the kill animation from the ego perspective.
So, is it both in there?
Or was it turned around?
Zack, oh, in the sack shot.
That's what I was saying, in the sack shot.
Can you still remember my in-game name
in Battlefield 3?
On the PC?
No, in BC2.
In BC2 was it, I think.
It was called from some code,
and it was called from some code, I think.
It was called from some code, I think.
For some reason, Info-Hoden.
I have no idea why.
It just comes to me.
A really tight-knit name.
Info-Hoden.
There he sits in the corner.
Huh? Ah, he.
Okay, Smoke.
He will definitely smoke at the start.
He always smokes half of the map when he plays.
I really want to play Battlefield 3.
Okay, well.
Well, you know what the players say.
We have quite a routine here.
I just wanted to get this truck organized.
Where we are almost there in real life.
But right now, we need to do something about this map.
But people, I know what you need.
You can if you can feel and play around your level.
I have made a series of
trying maps.
I gave it a show.
Boah, Alter, kriegen die auf den Sack.
WTF.
Krass, das war ein nicer Play.
Das Ding hat ja kaum einer gespielt, M417.
Jetzt ist er suppressed.
Alter, werden die weggesprayt.
Fuck, Alter, die haben richtig, die wurden richtig weg.
Gachi-Bust.
Domi, danke für den Zap.
Alter, die kriegen auch auf den Sack.
Nice.
Das waren jetzt irgendwie 30 Kills in zwei Minuten.
Was, wie?
Wie hieß der andere Typ im Squad?
Lord of your...
Naja.
Battlefield-Reihennamen halt.
Archer, using the SKS on Metro, we will of course be seeing a bunch of Metro clips,
because Battlefront 3 is mostly Operation Metro and has been for the past few years.
This one's a nice clip though, using that SKS...
Ich bin ja kein so großer Metro-Fan.
Schub, schub, schub, schub, schub.
Fuck.
Alter, die werden auch...
Haha, das war's, das war's, all.
Wollte grad sagen, was jetzt.
Oh, nice.
Schon wieder Magnum in the Kop.
A short clip from MadKorean, playing on Operation Metro with the SCAR-L.
He goes on a really good flank, around the side of the enemy team, pushing towards...
Ich glaube, mir hat wenig, also mir hat in kaum einem Spiel so viel Bock gemacht,
wenn du mal richtig abgegangen bist in Battlefield 3.
Ich meine, Aunen macht in jedem Spiel Bock.
Aber Battlefield 3 war schon was.
Besonderes in der Richtung.
Du konntest in Battlefield 3 auch so unglaublich viel durch Laufwege und Timing machen,
was mehr zugute kommt mit 37 mittlerweile, ne?
Laufwege und Timing kann man mit 37 auch noch.
Jetzt eine super krasse Headshot, Five Head Flick, Twitch, Aim, vielleicht nicht mehr, ja?
Beep.
Thanks for watching this episode of the Battlefield 3 Top Plays.
Nice.
As I said, Battlefield 3, 10 years old.
Amazing it's got to this milestone.
And we're still...
Mit 40 bist du alt, ja?
Ab 40 habe ich dann Commander Krieger Aim.
Hast du eigentlich dein BLE-Thermostat wieder gefixt bekommen?
Ja.
Ja, hab ich.
Du kannst...
Du kannst die offizielle Firmware zurückflashen.
Die Dinger sind nämlich noch erreichbar über Bluetooth.
Und mittlerweile gibt es auch eine neue Firmware, die...
die Revision unterstützt, die ich habe.
Das flashen wir demnächst.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob wir das heute noch flashen oder nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Ludl.
So.
Der Harald ist am Start.
Moin.
So.
Was machen wir denn jetzt?
Ich würde sagen, ich gehe jetzt essen.
Richtig Pipo-Fett.
Richtig Hoste.
Dort V-Peak.
Ja, den könnten wir tatsächlich hosten.
Was macht er denn gerade?
Bluetooth-Reverse-Engineering.
Excellent.
TCP-Dump macht er.
TCP-Dump.
Bluetooth-Stells.
Ah, Big Brain Time.
Okay.
Hosten wir ihn.
Raid.
Das ist excellent.
Was macht eigentlich der Frasier?
Was macht der Frasier?
Der Frasier war vor zwei Tagen.
Da hat er irgendwelche Weep-Games gespielt.
Alles klar.
Okay, Leute.
Wir sehen uns vielleicht heute Abend nochmal.
Vielleicht flashen wir dann wirklich die Thermometer wieder.
Also bis dann, Leute.
Wir sehen uns.
See you.